GOOD MORNING I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY WELCOMING ALL OF YOU
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
TODAY IS APRIL EIGHTH AND THIS
IS OUR FIRST HEARING OF THE
YEAR HEY LET ME START OFF BY
ALSO EXTENDING MY SPECIAL
WELCOME TO OUR NEW MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BENNETT LEE AND
CUNNINGHAM. WELCOME OFFICE ALL
I ALSO LIKE TO GET- GET SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE MATTERS. OF THE
WAY HOW WILL CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL. SO ONLY A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE MAY WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ALSO REQUIRING THAT
MASKS BE WORN IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SAYING BE MAINTAINED
BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING. WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. WE HAVE A VERY FULL AGENDA
TODAY AND HAVE A HEART STOP AT
ONE THIRTY THIS AFTERNOON. SO
WE HAVE PASSED AUTHORS TO BE
BRIEF AND LIMITED A WITNESSES-
TO TWO MINUTES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO MINUTES IN OPPOSITION
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY.
INDIVIDUALS ARE TESTIFYING. NOW
WHEN THIS IS MADE TESTIFIED BY
PHONE VIDEO CONFERENCING- AT
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED IN THE CAPITOL BUILDING
HERE. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON HIS BEGINNING ARE
THEY'RE BUILT PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON
WHAT THE SUPPORT FOR OPPOSE THE
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
POLICE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT MATHIS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAW ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC. SO
HEALTH CONCERNS AS WE FACE. WE
ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON
CONSENT TODAY. AS INDICATED ON
THE AGENDA. THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED. A FULL
CONSENT AND THEY ARE. AB THREE
FIVE THREE THREE FIVE. AB THREE
ONE THREE FIVE TWO A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE AB OURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE. A. B. TWELVE TWENTY ONE
AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE. EIGHTY
EIGHT OH NINE AB SEVEN NINETY.
N. A. B. E. TWELFTH. AND I WANT
TO TAKE UP A MINUTE ALSO TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF. ON
BOTH SIDES- TO- FOR YOUR HARD
WORK BECAUSE OF YOUR HARD WORK
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PLACE A
LOT OF THESE. ITEM ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. IT IS ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SINCE THE
COMMITTEE WHICH DID NOT CHANGE.
FROM LAST TIME THERE'S NO NEED
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT. THE
RULES TODAY. LOOKS LIKE WE
STILL DO NOT HAVE A QUOTE PUTS.
THREE FOR. ALL LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO. HI MR
SECRETARY- POLICE A CALL THE
ROLL. CHAPTER HERE KILEY BAROKA
HAVE. BENNETT HERE CORREA
CUNNINGHAM GABRIEL YEAH
GALLAGHER. IRWIN LAKE. WEST WE
DO HAVE QUORUM SINCE WE HAVE
QUORUM WE MAY WANT TO ADOPT
TODAY'S THE CONSENT AGENDA AT
THIS TIME LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ADOPT TODAY'S CONSENT
AGENDA. A CONSENT AGENDA HAS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE A SLASH A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA. CHAPTER
HERE YES I TURNED OUT HIGH
KILEY. KILEY AYE OUR CAMP.
BENNETT BENNETT I CARILLO. HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE
GABRIEL GABRIEL HI GALLAGHER.
IRWIN WHEN I LEE. WICKS. OKAY
LET THE RECORD EFLECT AS THE
SEVENTY ZERO IS THE COUNT AND
THAT IS IT CONSENT AGENDA HAS
BEEN ADOPTED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WITH THAT WE CAN TURN
TO ALL BILLS ARE BEFORE US SO
WE STARTING WITH UP THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THAT'S AB THREE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND TODAY WE'RE
GOING WITH THE FINAL ORDER. CAN
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER WITH US SO WELCOME
WELCOME TO OUR COMMITTEE. YOU
FOR. THIS IS A GETS HIS FIRST
COMMITTEE MEETING AB ARE I
PRESENT TO YOU AB THREE SEVEN
ONE REGARDING SHARED MOBILITY
LIABILITY- CHERT DEVICE
LIABILITY AND BRAILLE
COSPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE FOR THE BLIND
THE GOALS OF THIS BILL ARE
EQUITY IN A SENSIBILITY AB
THREE SEVEN ONE REQUIRES
EXISTING LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
BE EXTENDED TO PEDESTRIANS IFTHEY ARE INJURED BY A SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE SUCH AS AN
ELECTRIC SCOOTER OR BIKE
COLLECTIVELY E. DEVICES WHETHER
IN USE OUR PART THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES ADDITION OF BRAILLE
AND TACTILE SIGNAGE WITH REYES
CHARACTERS. FOR PEDESTRIANS WHO
ARE VISUALLY IMPAIRED ALLOWING
THEM TO RECEIVE THE NECESSARY
CONTACT INFORMATION TO FILE
INTO REPORT BEFORE PROCEEDING
FURTHER I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
LOCATED ON PAGES FOUR AND SEVEN
ON THE ANALYSIS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE THAT
THERE IS AN INDEMNITY FOR COULD
COMPANIES IF AN ACCIDENT IS
CAUSED BY USER NEGLIGENCE SUCH
AS DRIVING WHILE INTOXICATED
ADDITIONALLY THESE AMENDMENTS
DELETE ALL REFERENCES TO
TRACKING. AS P. DEVICES BECOME
A MORE POPULAR MEANS OF
TRANSPORTATION PEDESTRIANS FACE
AN INCREASED RISK OF INJURY
IMPROPERLY PARKED YOU DEVICES
AND WRITERS USING THE DEVICES
AND A PEDESTRIAN WALKWAY POSE A
GREATER DANGER IN CAN LEAD TO
SEVERE INJURIES FOR PEDESTRIANS
ESPECIALLY THE VISUALLY
IMPAIRED WHO RELY ON CLEAR
WALKWAYS FREE OF HINDRANCE
EXISTING LIABILITY COVERAGE IS
ALREADY EXTENDED TO USERS
INJURED AS A RESULT OF
OPERATING DEVICES BUT DOES NOT
COVER PEDESTRIANS AND ACCIDENT
VICTIMS CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION STATE THAT NO SUCH
LIABILITY EXISTS FOR ACCIDENT
VICTIMS. HOWEVER THAT IS NOT
THE CASE AS OTHER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION SAID THAT THE
CAR INSURE LIABILITY COVERAGES
AFFORDED TO THOSE INJURED BY A
USER OPERATING THESE DEVICES-
THUS EXISTING INSURANCE.
ASSEMBLY BE EXTENDED TO
PEDESTRIANS IN YOUR BY DEVICES
AS THE BURDEN OF LIGHT RESPONSE
CHAU NOT FOR ON THE- VICTIM.
ADDITIONALLY OPPA AS WE CONCERN
AS TO WHY THIS BILL APPLIES TO
THOSE RENT THE VEHICLE DOES NOT
APPLY TO THOSE WHO DON'T
PERSONAL MOTORIZED VEHICLES.
THE KEY DIFFERENCE THERE IS AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS A GREATER
PROPENSITY TO INSURE. TO INSURE
THEIR OWN DEVICES PARK LOCKED
AND STOWED AWAY PROPERLY OUT OF
HARM'S WAY WHEREAS THE PURPOSE
TO BE DEVICES TO. BE FREELY
LEFT IN PUBLIC WITH LITTLE
REGARD FOR PEDESTRIANS. PASSAGE
WAYS YOUR TYPICAL USER OWNED
DEVICES LOCKED AND STORED AS
OPPOSED TO THE SHARED DEVICES
WE HAVE ALL SEEN LITTERED AND
WALKWAYS. FURTHER THE ABSENCE
BRAILLE AND TACTILE USES TO
PREVENT INDIVIDUALS WITH VISUAL
IMPAIRMENTS FROM ASSESSING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DEVICE
COMPANY AFTER AN INJURY. THE
ADDITION OF SUCH SIGNAGE WILL
GUARANTEE PEDESTRIANS WITH
VISUAL IMPAIRMENT CAN PROPERLY
IDENTIFY THE DEVICE PROP
PROVIDERS CONTACT INFORMATION
TO FILE NEED TO REPORT. AB
THREE SEVEN ONE DISPLACES THE
BURDEN OF RESPONSIBILITY AWAY
FROM ACCIDENT VICTIMS. BY AND
ENSURING PEDESTRIANS ESPECIALLY
THE VISUALLY IMPAIRED OR FORTY
EXISTING INSURANCE PROTECTIONS
AND ACCESSIBLE CONTACT
IDENTIFICATION. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AT THE
BILL'S SPONSORS- JEFF TOM. OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE
BLIND. AND- AND PRIVILEGE. MY
BROTHER DR FRED JONES. A MEMBER
OF THE NON VISUAL COMMUNITY.
WHO WHEN I GOT IN MY FIRST
MARRIAGE WHEN I WAS- MARY. AND
I TURNED ON THE LIGHT FORM IN
THE BATHROOM HE TOLD ME. WHY
YOU TURN ON THE LIGHT ON BLIND.
THAT SHOWED ME THAT I NEED TO
TALK TO THE VISUALLY IMPAIRED
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND. THEIR
THEIR DILEMMA SO HE'S THE FIRST
PERSON I CALL UPON THIS BILL.
TO GET INFORMATION. SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LET'S START
START WITH THE FIRST ONE IS
THEN. DR JONES. WELCOME TO OUR
COMMITTEE. MMHM MEMBERS BACK
TO. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JEFF TOM ON THE GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF ON. AT THE OUTSET
LET ME THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER FOR AUTHORING AB
THREE SEVENTY ONE. THIS BILL IS
NOT INTENDED TO HARM THE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE INDUSTRY.
RATHER THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS
TO SOLVE A SIGNIFICANT
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY ISSUE. THESE
HE DEVICES SHARE THE SIDEWALKS
WITH PEDESTRIANS. PEDESTRIANS
CAN BE INJURED EITHER FROM
DIRECT COLLISIONS WITH THESE
DEVICES OR BECAUSE OF INJURIES
SUFFERED WHEN FALLING OVER
CARELESSLY LEFT DEVICES IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SIDEWALK IN FACT
MEMBERS OF MY OWN ORGANIZATION
HAVE SUFFERED INJURIES IN THIS
VERY WAY. THERE IS NO EXISTING
INSURANCE THAT COVERS- CONDUCT
BY THE END USER. OR THE
COMPANIES WITH RESPECT TO
DAMAGES SUFFERED BY A
PEDESTRIAN. THIS BILL WOULD
MERELY APPLY EXISTING LIABILITY
INSURANCE ALREADY REQUIRED TO
SITUATIONS INVOLVING CONDUCT BY
THE END USER OR THE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE PROVIDER. WHEN
A PEDESTRIAN SUFFERS PROPERTY
OR PERSONAL INJURY. I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
AND URGENT IVOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
TESTIMONY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
ONE IS SO AND JUST A REMINDER
THAT THERE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CALLING IN. EITHER IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION THE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO SO LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINE- MR MALEMA
AT&T OPERATOR. PARDON ME MISTER
CHAIR ARE YOU ARE YOU READY TO
TAKE COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC
OR WAS THERE A DID AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESS I BELIEVE
THERE'S ANOTHER WITNESS. OKAY
DR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EMPIRE ME
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE A
WITNESS- INVITED TO SPEAK ON
THE CALL YOUR LINE SHOULD BE
OPEN RIGHT NOW. HI THIS IS
BRETT MILLER I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF SPEND IT. IS THIS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE OPPOSITION
TO RAISE THEIR CONCERNS. NO SIR
ARE WE DOING SUPPORT- WITNESSES
AT THIS POINT. IF YOU CAN HOLD
ON A LITTLE BIT LONGER. GARCIA
THANK YOU. AGAIN MISTER CHARLIE
ABOVE PAULA JONES FOR THE
CONFUSION MAY I HAVE THE NAME
OF THE WITNESS PLACE. DR FRED
JONES. THE CHAIR WILL ATTEMPT
TO IDENTIFY IS LINE OF HE IS ON
THE CONFERENCE RIGHT NOW. GET
YOURS BEST WE CAN DETERMINE HE
IS NOT ON THE PHONE LINES ARE
SURE THANK YOU AND WE CAN
COLLECT. WE COME BACK HOW CAN
COME BACK TO DOCTOR JONES- A
BIT LATER SO UP. MR OPERATOR
WHICH YOU OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
INDIVIDUALS CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AB. THREE
SEVENTY ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE LINE
IT SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK WITH HIM TO GO TO LINE.
THIRTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS
REGINA BRANCH AND I AM A
RESIDENT. SACRAMENTO I ALSO- I
AM TOTALLY BLIND AND TRAVEL
INDEPENDENTLY I HAVE HAD
EXPERIENCES WITH THIS AND URGED
SUPPORT FOR THIS. LEGISLATION
FOR SAFETY REASONS AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. AND
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL AND I
JUST LIKE TO REMIND THAT OF
EVERYONE THAT- FROM THIS POINT
ON IF YOU CAN JUST IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND ALSO THE ASSOCIATION THAT
YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH WE'RE
NOT TAKING TESTIMONY OTHER
THAN. DOCTOR FRED JONES. MR
UPGRADER WHICH A CHARGERS NO L.
TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WHICH ALSO
PLEASE CHECK TO SEE IF DOCTOR
FRED JONES IS BACK ON. DR JONES
IF YOU ARE ARE PRESENT FOR THIS
CONFERENCE RIGHT NOW AND YOUR
LINE IS SOMEHOW MUTED. YOU MAY
I NEED YOUR PHONE LINE-
OTHERWISE YOU CAN PRESS ONE
ZERO DID TO SIGNAL THAT YOU ARE
ON THE CONFERENCE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN GROWTH TO AT THE END
DOES NOT APPEAR THAT NOT MISTER
JONES IS AVAILABLE. WHY DON'T I
TRY TO CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU
MISTER OPERATOR AFTER A
DISCUSSION HERE. AT THIS POINT
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE ON THE LINE WE HAVE
MISTER BRITT- MOLAR WOULD
SPEND. ARE YOU THERE MR MILLER.
YES I'M HERE GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME'S
BRETT DOLLARS SENIOR PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER AT SPEND HERE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB THREE SEVENTY ONE. TO BE
CLEAR FROM THE START WE DO NOT
DISPUTE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AND
ARE HAPPY TO ADD HE CONTACT
INFORMATION IN BRAILLE ON ALL
OF OUR COMBINED FIFTY THOUSAND
ELECTRIC SCOOTERS. IT'S A GOOD
IDEA AND CERTAINLY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. IN CALIFORNIA I
ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT ALL
SHARED SCOOTER AND E. BIKE
PROVIDERS ALREADY HAVE
COMMERCIAL GENERAL LIABILITY
INSURANCE COVERING PEDESTRIAN
IN ACCIDENTS WHERE WE AT THE
BIKE HONORED ARE NEGLIGENT.
HOWEVER WHAT AB THREE SEVENTY
ONE AND ASKING FOR IN TERMS OF
INSURANCE WILL UNEQUIVOCALLY
AND MICHAEL ABILITY IN THE
STATE FOR BOTH SHARED COOTER
THANK YOU BYE. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT NOT REQUIRED IN ANY
OTHER STATE OR COUNTRY BY
MAKING MICRO MOBILITY SHARE
COMPANY PROFILE BOTH FOR THE
NEGLIGENCE OF THEIR USERS.
MEANING WE WOULD BE LIABLE FOR
OUR WRITERS BEHAVIOR. NO OTHER
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE MODEL
POLITICS APPROACH BECAUSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RIGHTLY HELD
RESPONSIBLE AND LIABLE FOR
THEIR OWN ACTIONS. AB THREE
SEVENTY ONE WHICH CHANGE THAT
IN THIS WAY AB THREE SEVENTY
ONE UNFAIRLY SINGLED OUT SHARED-MOBILITY INDUSTRY WELL PRIVATE
CITIZEN TO BUY THEIR OWN BIKES
SCOOTERS AND MOPEDS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE SAME INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS. ALSO AS NOTED IN
THE COMMITTEE REPORT THE ONLY
INSURER FOR MICHAEL BILITY
OPERATORS APOLLO HAD ALREADY
MADE CLEAR IN WRITING THAT NO
INSURANCE PRODUCT CONTEMPLATED
HERE EXIT. APPALL AND FURTHER
STATED THAT WE WOULD BE
RENDERED ON INSURANCE THIS BILL
WERE TO PASS. IF ENACTED SUCH
COVERAGE WOULD LIKELY BE VERY
COST PROHIBITIVE THE POLICY
LIMIT PROPOSED IN THIS BILL FOR
BODILY INJURY OF A PEDESTRIAN
R. SIXTY SEVEN TIMES HIGHER
THAN WHAT IS REQUIRED FOR
CARPET CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY
I'M REFERRING TO A ONE MILLION
DOLLAR MINIMUM FOR SCOOTERS AND
BIKES IN THIS BILL COMPARED TO
A FIFTY THOUSAND MINIMUM
LIABILITY COVER FOR CARS. CARS
THE COURT BECAUSE TECHNICALLY
MORE DAMAGED WE REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED DESPITE THE
CANADIAN INVENTION TO DOES NOT
ADDRESS OUR LIABILITY CONCERNS.
AND BECAUSE THE BILL CONTINUE
TO TREAT IT DIFFERENTLY ANY
OTHER. GOOD IN OUR CON. LASTLY
ARE UP TO THE HERE COMPARE TO
TWO. FOR USER IN FACT REALLY UP
TO WORK USER WITH THAT CHECK.
AND TRY TO THOSE WERE WE
CONTINUE TO BE TREAT
DIFFERENTLY LIKE ALL OTHER
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY
CAN BE. WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL A MONTH IT IS LIMITED
TO THE PREPARATION WHICH AGAIN
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO PARTNER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUT. MR OFF RAIDER WHICH YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
INDIVIDUALS CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SO FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND AGAIN
WANT TO STRESS THAT- THIS RIGHT
NOW THIS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE SIGNALED AT
LEAST ONE PERSON THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. WE'LL GET A CHECK ON
LINE THIRTY SIX WERE UNSURE AS
TO WHETHER THEY WERE CALLING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION MY THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T
MIND. I'M SORRY I JUST WANTED
TO ADD MY ORGANIZATION I'M
SORRY. I SPOKE PREVIOUSLY CAN I
DO THAT AT THIS TIME OR NOT. GO
AHEAD PLEASE SIR TURKEL AS
BRING IS ALL RIGHT OKAY. I GOT
I'M SORRY. MY ORGANIZATION IT'S
ACB CAPITAL CHAPTER- SHE C. B.
IT'S A LOCAL SACRAMENTO
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR ROBERT ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL CALLERS SO IN THE
FUTURE WE DO. ALLOW YOU THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE GOT
MORNING MISTER CHAIR HI GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ANGIE MINETTI. HERE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
FOR LINE AND BIRD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. I DON'T
LIKE MOVE OUT I'M DOCTOR JONES
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
IN SUPPORT. THAT'S MY BROTHER
HOW YES ABSOLUTELY. DR JONES
OUT YES- PLEASE GO AHEAD I
THINK- GO AHEAD I KNOW I KNOW
THAT YOU WERE MUTED THE EARLIER
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD- ONE OF MY
APOLOGIES FOR ALL OF THE-
INSTRUCTIONS THAT THE PROCESS.
BUT I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ON BEHALF OF MY BROTHER. I
DON'T REGINALD JONES SAWYER
THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL
BECAUSE IT WE HAVE BEEN
DISABLED COMMUNITY WE HAVE. TO
BARRIERS THAT COME WITH IN OUR
LIVES AND THEIR ARCHITECTURAL
BARRIERS AND THEY ARE
ATTITUDINAL BARRIERS AND THE
BARRIER- THIS BILL. PRESENT THE
ARCHITECTURAL BARRIER WHERE IF
A PERSON IS CROSSING THE
STREET. AND THEY'RE GOING FROM
ONE THOUSAND TO THE OTHER. THE
SCHOOL THAT'S LEFT IN THE WAY.
OF ARCHITECTURAL BARRIER WHICH
IF THEY GO AROUND THE FOOD THEY
BECOME DISORIENTED AND LOSE
THEIR STATE AND PLATE. AND THEY
DO NOT KNOW HOW TO GET TO THE
OTHER SIDE SO THIS BILL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
IF. THEY'RE ALSO INJURED IN
THEIR CROSSING THE STREET AND
TRIPPING OVER THIS PARTICULAR.
EQUIPMENT OR VEHICLE AND THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT BE PASSED
BECAUSE WE NEED TO KNOW. WHAT
COMPANY THIS. VEHICLE BELONGS
TO THE LIBERAL WOULD BE DONE
HELP FOR US. SO WE CAN HELP
WHAT INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
CALL. FOR LIVE A CHARGE.
AGAINST THE PERSON WHO OWNS
THIS PARTICULAR VEHICLE- I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BECAUSE AGAIN. IT WILL CREATE A-
ADDITION TO ARCHITECTURE
BARRIERS DEBATE PEOPLE. ALL THE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JONES WE'RE TESTING. OF MR
OPERATOR YOU TO SEE IF THERE AT
THIS. COLORS EITHER IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
YES MISTER TRICK. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL THIS IS THE FINAL CALL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
KNOW WHEN THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR OPERATOR THAT BRINGS US
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY. AT THIS
POINT. NO FOR QUESTIONS- VICE
CHAIR KILEY COLLETT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- IT I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM SPEND JUST TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND HOW CURRENT LAW
WORKS SO- IF YOU ARE A
PEDESTRIAN WHO IS INJURED- BY A
USER OF ONE OF YOUR DEVICES-
THROUGH THAT USERS NEGLIGENCE
AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY ASSETS
OR THEIR JUDGMENT PROOF. I IS
IT THE CASE THAT THE INJURED
PARTY HAS NO RECOURSE TO YOUR
COMPANY AT THAT POINT. YEAH
CAN'T DO YOUR QUESTION YEAH. A
PEDESTRIAN IS INJURED BY THE
ACTIONS OF A USER THEY HAVE-
RECOURSE AVAILABLE TO- TAKE
ACTION AGAINST THAT USER THE
ISSUE HERE IS WHO IS LIABLE THE
COMPANY OR THE USER. RIGHT SO
INTENSE AND CURRENTLY WHAT'S
THE USER AND THERE'S NO
LIABILITY ON THE PART OF THE
COMPANY FOR THE NEGLIGENCE OF
THE USER OR THERE'S NO RECOURSE
TO AT THE ASSETS OF THE COMPANY.
IF YES. THE COMPANY OF
NEGLIGENT AND HAS DONE
SOMETHING AND TO INTO THE
PEDESTRIAN BY ACCIDENT THEN OF
COURSE WE ARE LIABLE BUT WHEN A
USER. YOU KNOW RECKLESSLY
ENDANGERS OR INJURES A
PEDESTRIAN THAT USER IS
RESPONSIBLE AND LIABLE RIGHT SO
THIS SEEMS TO BE DIFFERENT IN
THE CONTEXT OF SAY AUTOMOBILES
WERE IF YOU'RE A PEDESTRIAN A
TENER YOUR DRIVER WHO GETS HIT
THEN- THE PARTY WHO. INJURED
YOU IS REQUIRED TO HAVE
INSURANCE YOU HAVE SOME
ASSURANCE THAT YOU WILL GET
RECOVERY BUT UNDER CURRENT LAW
WITH RESPECT TO MOBILITY
DEVICES THERE ISN'T THAT
INSURANCE IS THAT RIGHT. RIGHT
SO IT SEEMS LIKE MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX HERE
MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER RILEY COOK KILEY DOES
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE GONNA SET UP
THAT I THINK THAT MAKES SENSE I
MEAN I MIGHT SORT OF JUST
INTUITIVELY THINK THAT MAYBE IF.
THE CONDUCT OF THE USER IS A
RECKLESS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BUT- YOU KNOW. THERE MIGHT BE A
MIDDLE GROUND HERE BUT I DO SEE
THAT. THE PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIX AND I THINK THE
SOLUTION- MAKES SENSE. I MEAN I
THINK THAT. THERE MIGHT BE-
ALSO ROOM TO SAY YOU KNOW THAT
THAT- THE USER- CAN BE LIABLE
IF. I MEAN UNDER CURRENT ZONING
UNDER CURRENT LAW IS THEIR
INABILITY THERE IS AN ABILITY
TO. UNDER YOUR BILL YOU CAN
STILL RECOVER FROM THE USER IF
THEY- IN TERMS OF WITH
LIABILITY BE JOINED SEVERAL RUN
AUTOMATICALLY GO TO THE
COMPANY. SO THIS IS TO ALLOW.
DO YOU HAVE INSURANCE OF THAT.
THE USER WILL BE COVERED AND
THEN THEY CAN ALSO HELP MAKE
SURE THAT RECOVERY OF MEDICAL
EXPENSES AND THINGS THAT
NATURE- RECOVERABLE BY PERSON
WHO'S INJURED- SO THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO OF WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS SAYING IF THEY'RE
THERE IS NO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO CRAFT WHAT THAT
INSURANCE LOOK LIKE. LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING IT MIGHT BE A
MIDDLE GROUND WHICH WE CAN GET
TO YEAH- BUT THERE WERE NO
EARTHQUAKE INSURANCE AT ONE
TIME THERE WAS NO FLOOD
INSURANCE SO THIS IS ALMOST
LIKE PREEMPTIVE LET'S FIGURE
OUT A WAY WE CAN PROTECT. NOT
ONLY THE PEDESTRIAN THAT ONLY
TWO USER BUT ALSO THE COMPANY
SO THAT EVERYBODY WILL BE WHO
WILL HAVE SOME KIND OF COVERAGE
ON THIS OKAY I YEAH I THINK I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I
DON'T LIKE THE IDEA THAT
THERE'S NO RECOURSE FOR A
PEDESTRIAN IN THE SITUATION I
MENTIONED I'M I'M NOT SURE I
ALSO LIKE IT IF. THE USER IS
SORT OF OFF THE HOOK NO MATTER
HOW BAD THEIR CONDUCT IS A
MATTER HOW YOU KNOW WELL
POSITIONED THEY ARE TO EIGHT IN
THE IN THE RECOVERY SO I HOPE
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK IN THAT
DIRECTION THAT UP I WILL IN
FACT THERE ARE THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF EXPRESSED.
EXACT SAME THING AS YOU'VE
EXPRESSED THIS KIND OF. IT IS.
COM OR QUESTIONS. MISTER
BENNETT. THE AT THAT YET THANK
YOU- YOU YOU AND I HAVE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK A LOT
ABOUT THIS AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR OPENNESS TO A
CONVERSATION- I WANT TO MAKE
SURE IS THERE'S PROPER-
PROTECTION FOR. THE RESIDENTS
AND CITIZENS THAT- OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE OUT THEY'RE
WALKING EXETER AND MAY BE HIT
BY OR TRIP OVER OF THESE CALLS-
AND THIS BILL. IS A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO ATTEMPT THAT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
PROPER SENSE OF RESPONSIBILITY
BY BOTH THE END USER AND THE
COMPANY- IN AND MAKING SURE
THAT- BOTH OF THEM TAKE THEIR
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES IN TERMS
OF PROTECTING- RESIDENTS OUT
THERE SERIOUSLY THIS LAST MILE.
TRANSPORTATION OPTION IS GOING
TO EVOLVE IN CALIFORNIA- AS WE
SEE TECHNOLOGY CHANGING CENTER
AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO YOUR EXPRESSED
NAY- EARLIER TO WORK- WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
MORE OF THE SECOND HALF OF MY
EQUATION WHICH IS MAKING SURE
THAT THE END USER. DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE OFF THE HOOK FOR
LIABILITY AT ALL- AND SO I
DON'T HAVE THE SOLUTIONS RIGHT
NOW APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
EXAMPLES- HAVING THE COMPANIES
OFFER- A LIABILITY THAT THE-
END USERS COULD PAY A SMALL FEE
FOR AND THEREFORE HAVE
THEMSELVES COVERED FOR
LIABILITY MAYBE IT'S ON A-
MONTHLY BASIS ARE PART OF THEIR
SUBSCRIPTION NEXT SATURDAY-
SUCK SOMETHING WHERE. THE
COMPANY SHOULD BE ABLE TO JUST
SAY HEY WE RENTED IT AND
WHETHER YOU HAVE INSURANCE OR
NOT WHETHER YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF ANY
LIABILITY OR NOT WE WERE NOT
INTERESTED- THAT'S NOT ENOUGH
RESPONSIBILITY AND PART OF THE
COMPANY I WANT THE COMPANY. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'VE TRIED TO
EMPHASIZED HOW MUCH AND YOU HAS.
FOR THIS ALSO AND SO- I AM.
WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS TO MOVE
IT FORWARD OUT OF COMMITTEE-
WITH- WITH YOU OR ARE YOU IT
WITH YOUR COMMITMENT THAT-
YOU'RE WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK RECOGNIZING THEIR- NEEDS
TO BE MORE EVOLUTION TO MAKE
SURE THE END USER ALSO FEELS AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY. NOT JUST A
COMPANY HERE. DEFINITELY I WILL
I MEAN THIS IS AN UNUSUAL
SITUATION FROM HER NORMALLY
WHEN YOU COME BEFORE COMMITTEE.
THEY WANT YOU TO DO YOUR THINGS
THIS IS A- THIS IS UNUSUAL YOUR
YOU WANT ME TO MAKE MY BILL
TOUGHER INSTRUCTORS THIS IS.
WHAT THIS IS DIFFERENT AND MORE
SPECIFIC AND MORE. OF THE SAME
BABY BOOM BALANCE BALANCING OUT
TO LIVE THAN USUAL SO IT YES
THE BALANCING OUT THE LAURIE IS
NOW TRYING TO HARM TO COMPANIES
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S CUP SO THAT THE END
USER DOESN'T DOESN'T JUST FEEL
LIKE UP IT'S ALL ON THE COMPANY
AND THEREFORE. IT DOESN'T
MATTER HOW RESPONSIBLE I THINK.
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- NEXT LET'S
GO TO MOST. BY MR GABRIEL
FOLLOWED BY MY CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU. WITH GALLAGHER THANK
YOU MISS MISS CHAIR- AND THINK
YOU TO- MY COLLEAGUE FROM SOUTH
LA FOR BRINGING UP THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL I THINK THAT THE
BRAILLE. A PART OF THE BILL IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE WORKING OUT- AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHER MEMBERS
THE OTHER PART OF THE BILL I
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT NOW- FOR THE COMPANIES TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOME KIND OF.
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN ARE OUT FOR
THE END USER- I HAVE ALMOST
BEEN RUN OVER BY FOLKS IN- THE
RED BIKES AS WELL AS THE
SCOOTERS HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
MIDTOWN WITH FOLKS THAT ARE
HAVE BEEN. CLEARLY UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF CLEARLY
INEBRIATED. WHO SHOULD NOT BE
ON THESE MOTORIZED. VEHICLES
AND- WELL I DID SEE SOMEONE
ACTUALLY GET RUN OVER JUST ON
FIFTEENTH IN L. ACROSS IN THE
STREET BECAUSE PEOPLE THAT WERE
DRINKING AND USING- THE
SCOOTERS- WE'RE BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE- SO THERE IS I
THINK AN OPPORTUNITY FOR AN
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN TO THIS IF
YOU'RE ON THE STREET. YOU
YOURSELF IF YOU ARE DRINKING
AND USING THESE- THE SCOOTERS
OF THE RENT BIKES BOB CAN CAUSE
HARM TO YOURSELF AND CLEARLY TO
A DRIVER IN A CAR THAT MAY NOT
TO YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE BEING
CARELESS. YOU MAY CAUSE HARM TO
SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF I WAS
SIMPLY WALKING MY DOG AND THEY
DIDN'T SEE ME AND WERE KIND OF
LIKE ALL OVER THE PLACE AND-
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATIONS ABOUT
HURTING OTHER PEOPLE SO THERE
IS A SENSE OF RESPONSIBILITY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GET ON ONE
OF THESE. PROSECUTORS TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUR ACTIONS
AND NO YOU SHOULD NOT BE
DRINKING WHILE ALSO- OF WRITING
THESE MACHINES SO I THINK I
HOPE THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COMPANIES
TO DO SOME KIND OF EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN BEING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
OR- SOMETHING THAT GETS TO
HAPPEN. SO THAT THERE'S A
RESPONSIBILITY ON TE END USER
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO WAS ALMOST
HURT TWICE. BYE BYE FOLKS SO
USING THESE MUCH- I THINK IT'S
AN- STEP SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NUMBER MR GABRIEL. YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN
APPRECIATION FOR YOU FOR THIS
BILL I THINK JUST TO ADDRESS
SOME OF WHAT. OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM- FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO FROM SANTA BARBARA
BROUGHT UP A COUPLE OF THINGS
MY UNDERSTAND IS THAT THIS
DOESN'T REMOVE. THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR A PLAINTIFF TO GO AFTER THE
END USER FOR NEGLIGENT CONDUCT
SO THEY CAN THEIR STELLAR
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE RIDING
THE SCOOTERS TO DO THE RIGHT
THINGS I'M MORE TO THE POINT
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT
UNDERWRITE THE POLICY FOR THE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
THEM TO DO THINGS TO GIVE THE
WRITERS THE RIGHT INCENTIVES TO
DO THE RIGHT THING TO BE SAFER
IN WRITING THEM TO NOT LEAVE
THEM IN THE WAY. OF DISABLED
PEOPLE OR OTHERS IN COLLEGE
ENTRY SO SOME OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I THINK THE
PRIVATE MARKET IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO FIX WHEN WE PASS YOUR
BILL THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
ARE GOING TO REQUIRE THE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
THEY'RE GOING TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR PRODUCTS ARE
WORK ARE USED IN A SAFER WAY
THAT DOESN'T INJURE PEOPLE SO
TO ME THIS IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY INSURANCE WORKS.
IT'S THE PERFECT CASE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR INSURANCE AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY THANK. YOU VERY MUCH A
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. YEAH I HAD
MORE OF QUESTION. ON THE USER
LIABILITY PIECE BECAUSE I
DON'T. I'VE READ THE ANALYSIS
AND- AND I'VE BEEN LISTENING TO
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT IT. AND I'M
A LITTLE ON. UNCLEAR ABOUT IT.
I'M SORRY TO ASK A REALLY
TECHNICAL QUESTION BUT HERE. IT
OCCURS TO ME THAT THAT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INCENTIVES ARE PROPERLY ALIGNED
BECAUSE- THE USER OF THESE.
DEVICES RIGHT- COULD BE DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE COULD BE.
LEAVING THEM LIKE. A JERK IN
THE MIDDLE OF. THE SIDEWALK
WERE YOU KNOW VISUALLY IMPAIRED
PEOPLE HAVE TO WALK. I MEAN YOU
KNOW THESE THINGS ARE.
PROLIFERATING AT LEAST IN
SACRAMENTO WHEN I'M UP HERE
THEY'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE
RIGHT- AND I GET THE POINT
ABOUT. WANTING THERE TO BE
INSURANCE. I UNDERSTAND THAT-
IT WAS SO I GUESS. WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DRILL DOWN ON IS.
UNDER ON HOW WOULD THIS BILL
CHANGED WHAT IS CURRENT LAW ON
USER. LIABILITY FOR. NEGLIGENT
OR RECKLESS CONDUCT. IN EITHER
USING THE DEVICE OR LEAVING IT
IN A PLACE THAT SHOULDN'T BE
LEFT ONE AND HOW WITH THE BILL.
CHANGE THE CURRENT LAW SO
TECHNICALLY THERE IS NONE. WHAT
IS THE BILL WILL DO AS- OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE SAID STATED. WILL
PUSH US TO EITHER HAVE THE-
PRIVATE SECTOR INSURANCE
COMPANY. CORRECT A PRODUCT THAT
DOESN'T EXIST RIGHT NOW. AND
THEN WITH. LOOKING FROM THE
INPUT I'M GETTING FROM HERE. WE
CAN DEMOCRATS SOMETHING. USE
YOUR- LIKE IF LIKE YOUR
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE TO COVER
IT IF YOU. JUST LIKE WHEN YOU
RENT A CAR. YOU CAN DO THAT.
BUT WE NEED SOMETHING SPECIFIC
JUST LIKE WHEN YOU. RENT A CAR
YOU ALSO CAN SIGN OFF.
LIABILITY BY SAYING I HAVE MY
OWN. YOU KNOW AUTO INSURANCE SO
I DON'T NEED TO BUY YOURS. SO
WE'RE LOOKING INTO- AS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT SAID.
THERE'S A VARIETY OF WAYS WE
CAN. WE CAN PARSES OUT WE JUST
NEED TO. FIGURE IT OUT AND
HOPEFULLY DISCLOSES YOU TO
DISH. WILL BE ABLE TO. TO COME
UP WITH SOMETHING BY THEM
WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY. OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO THAT SO THAT. THE
CURRENT LOG AND POSES NO
LIABILITY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THE BILL IS TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION COULD CORRECT
AND LAND IN A PLACE WHERE
THERE'S- SHARED LIABILITY
POTENTIALLY BETWEEN- THE
MANUFACTURER DISTRIBUTOR OF
THE- THE- VEHICLE OR DEVICE
SORT OF ACTS CALLED. AND THE
USER RATING MEANS- MAKING SURE
WHOEVER GETS INJURED. THERE'S
SOME KIND OF COVERAGE HERE OKAY
BECAUSE I THINK MR MY COLLEAGUE
MY NEIGHBOR TO THE SOUTH MISTER
BENNETT MAKES A GOOD POINT I
MEAN YOU DON'T WANT TO REMOVE.
USER LIABILITY ENTIRELY I GUESS
THERE ISN'T ANY TO BEGIN WITH
SO THAT'S NOT GREAT. WHICH IS
PROBABLY PART OF THE REASON.
YOU SEE. PEOPLE DRINKING AND
DRIVING THESE DEVICES LIKE
CRAZY AT NIGHT AND YOU SEE THEM
LEFT ALL OVER THE PLACE IN THE
WAY OF EVERYBODY THAT'S
WALKING. DURING THE DAY. SO I.
SEE THE DIRECTION YOU'RE MOVING
I THINK I'M PROBABLY GONNA
STAND CO CHANGES FOR NOW BUT-
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS. THANK
YOU WHAT'S GOING ON MR
GALLAGHER FOLLOWED BY MISSED
WICKS FOLLOWED BY MR WHEN.
GALLAGHER I THINK THE OTHER I
WAS GAY MAKE IT ON THE IN AND
DID WOULD ALSO BE. AND MAYBE
MAYBE ONE OF THE WITNESSES
MAYBE SPEAK TO OTHER BABY
SUBROGATION. AVAILABLE FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANY IF IT IN FACT
THE USER WAS THE ONE NEGLIGENT-
THE OTHER QUESTION HAS SO. YOUR
BILL ALSO PROVIDES THE DAY
ATTACHED SIGNAGE TO EACH DEVICE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF TRACKING AND
REPORTING. WHAT'S NOT REALLY
CLEAR IS LIKE SO WHAT WOULD
THAT YOU TRACKING YOU RECORD
THE INFORMATION WHAT ARE WE
USING IT FOR. SO IT IS REALLY
FOR THE VISUALLY IMPAIRED AFTER
SOME TYPE OF BRAILLE OR TACTILE
THEATERS IT'S IN ENGLISH BUT
IT'S THE REYES BRAILLE SO THAT
IF THEY DO HAVE AN ACCIDENT.
THEY CAN BEEN. READ ON THE- ON
ON THE DEVICE- YOU CAN CONTACT
SO YOU CAN- ASSUME LIABILITY NO
I GET THAT PART OF IT THIS IS
YOUR ADDICT AFFIRMATIVELY
ASKING TO BE TRACKED AND
REPORTED BY RIGHT THE M. S. P.
THOUGH. RIGHT SO WHAT WHAT MEAN
I GUESS- THE- AND THEN ALSO
IT'S NOT JUST THE NAME BUT IT'S
ALSO AN ALPHANUMERIC ID IS TO
YOU CAN DO BOTH. THE SAY DO
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS ARE EITHER
OR- AT WORK I'M NOT SURE WE CAN
HAVE- WHICH IS NICE AND WHAT IS
FUNNY ALL THE A AND I GUESS I
MEAN THAT WAS ENOUGH I MEAN. I
SHOULD HAVE 2% IN THE
CALIFORNIA. YEAH RIGHT MAYBE I
CAN ANSWER IT WILL BE MISSED.
MR JEFF TOM TOM. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION. AND
MAYBE TO CLARIFY- TOP OF THE-
YEAH MISTER KARGER WHICH YOU
READ WE ASK A QUESTION MAYBE
JUST TO CLARIFY LIKE OBVIOUS I
AGREE WITH THE PART ABOUT
HAVING THAT ON THERE SO THAT A
BLIND PERSON COULD IDENTIFY.
WHICH COMPANY OWNS THIS- YOUR
DEVICE THAT IS INJURED THEM- I
JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GONNA DO WITH AN ALPHANUMERIC
ID- I JUST WANT TO KNOW THE
NAME SO THAT I CAN THEN PROCEED
WITH. THE CLAIM THAT I NEED TO
MAKE. I THINK IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT TO- HAVE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE I DON'T
THINK IT'S- THERE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE- PHONE VISION
IMPAIRED PERSON. YOU KNOW
TRACKING THE END USER THAT'S
REALLY- SOMETHING THAT THE
COMPANY. YOU KNOW HAS THE- YOU.
KNOW WHETHER WHETHER THEY
DESIRE TO DO THAT OR NOT IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW THEIR
INDEMNIFICATION. ON BUT I
REALLY THINK IT'S JUST TO GET
AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE. INTO THE HANDS OF THE
VISION IMPAIRED PERSON IN ORDER
TO CALL THE SCOOTER OPERATOR.
OKAY. IS ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THAT'S ALL I HAVE MISSED WEEKS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU- MISTER JONES SAWYER- I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
THINK YOU'VE- JUMPED INTO AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSES- AND THERE'S A LOT OF
GRAY AREA AND RIGHT BUT I
APPRECIATE YOU DIVING RIGHT IN
HEAD FIRST- AND I DO THINK WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT LIABILITY
ISSUES- AND THAT THE COMPANIES
TO BE TO TAKE. SOME
RESPONSIBILITY HERE. ONE OF
HOWEVER ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WAS- POINTS THAT WAS
RAISED- TO ME BY THE OPPOSITION
WAS- THAT THIS TYPE OF
INSURANCE PRODUCT DOESN'T EXIST
CURRENTLY AND THAT THAT COULD
IMPACT THE COMPANY'S I JUST WAS
CURIOUS WHAT YOUR RESPONSE WAS
TO THAT- OF. IT I THINK I SAID
EARLIER AT ONE TIME THERE WAS
NO FLOOD INSURANCE NOTE
EARTHQUAKE INSURANCE- HAVE
ACTORS DURING THOSE SHIRTS FOR
ENSURING ATHLETES AT ONE TIME-
RIGHT NOW THEY NEED TO GET
SOME- SOME DATA. SO THEY CAN
KIND OF MEASURE HOW MUCH THIS
WILL COST- I THINK WORKING WITH
THE- CALIFORNIA BLIND
ASSOCIATION- WEEK DOES HE AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THERE
HAVE BEEN ACCIDENTS AND WE CAN
GET THAT DATA TO BE ABLE TO GET
BACK TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES. SO THEY CAN FILL OUT
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT ALGORITHM
IS SOLUTION COME UP WITH A
PRODUCT AND OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE
TO PRICE IT ACCORDING TO THE
NUMBER OF INCIDENTS OVER A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME AND
ENERGY THAT THAT'S HELPFUL AND
YOU'VE DO YOU THINK THAT-
THERE'S ROOM FOR. AND ON THIS
MOVING. WITH OPPOSITE OR- SO I
BELIEVE IF WE'RE GOING FROM THE
POINT OF TRYING TO MAKE SURE-
WE PROTECT. PEOPLE WHO GT
INJURED- WE CAN GET WE CAN GET
THERE YEAH WE JUST WORKING
TOWARD THAT AND NOT. TALKING
ABOUT OTHER THINGS THEN I THINK
WE CAN QUICKLY GET TO THAT BUT
IF WHERE WE'RE IF WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT COST FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THE
REASON THE DISABILITY.
COMMUNITY WANTED- KIRK AT. THE
GOVERNMENT SAYS TOO MUCH IT'LL
BANKRUPT THE GOVERNMENT WELL WE
NOW HAVE CURB CUTS BECAUSE
PEOPLE IN WHEELCHAIRS NEEDED.
AND SO- IT'S ABOUT. WANTING TO
MAKE SURE IT GETS DONE WE COULD
FIND A WAY OKAY AND I'M I'M
CAUSING THE BILL AND I'M
SUPPORTING IT TODAY I AM AND I
AM HOPEFUL THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO.
DEFINITELY APPRECIATED THANKS
RG MISTER JONES SAWYER. MISTER
WHEN. THANK GOD FINAL. ALL AND
CERTAINLY- WORK WALDRON YEAH
BLAMES IT ALL AND SINCE THAT
ALL. REUTERS YEAH- THIS IS VERY.
SIMILAR TO THE- SITUATED TO THE
A BILL THAT WE'VE ON A OF YEARS
AGO AND WHICH WAS SIDE
INSURANCE FOR- FOR COMPANIES
THAT HAD GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS
AND WE ENDED UP IT IT ENDED UP
NOT PASSING BECAUSE THAT
PRODUCT DOESN'T EXIST YET DUE
TO THE ACTUARIAL IS AREN'T
THERE THE PRODUCT DOESN'T EXIST
IN A WAY THAT WILL REALLY-
CHANGE BEHAVIOR SO FIRST FOR ME
TO BE CONSISTENT I'M I'M JUST
GONNA ABSTAINED TODAY BUT I
WANT TO SEE WAT THE BILL LOOKS
LIKE WHEN IT GETS. TO THE FLOOR
BECAUSE- I DON'T THINK THAT AS
A LEGISLATURE WE CAN FORCE
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
THIS TYPE OF INSURANCE- EVEN IF
THAT'S OUR- WHOLE. SO I'VE I'VE
I HOPE THAT AS THIS GOES
THROUGH THE INSURANCE-
COMMITTEE HAD RABAL TO COME UP
WITH SOLUTIONS REALLY TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THE SIDEWALK AND ARE DEALING
WITH- THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE
BEHAVIORS SO- HOPE TO VOTE FOR
IT ON FOURTH. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I WANT TO THANK YOU-
MISTER JONES SAWYER FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS- ON THIS BILL-
WE'VE HAD A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND- I ONLY SAY THAT
UP I AM SYMPATHETIC TO THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE-
INDUSTRY. BUT YET I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
THE PEDESTRIAN ALSO WHO MAY BE
INJURED WITHOUT RECOURSE SO I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL IS A
GREAT START- I YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY. HAS TO ADAPT I THINK
WE MAY HAVE TO KIND OF TWEAKED
A LITTLE BIT- YOU KNOW- AND
TAKEN AS A WHOLE YOU KNOW I AM
A VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA.
SO I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TRY TO SORT OUT SOME
OF THE- THE WILL OF THE
DIFFICULTIES ALONG THE WAY. AND
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
AND IT'S A- SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
SO AT THIS POINT- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM-
THAT THE OPPOSITION FIVE STATE
THEY CAME IN. KIND OF RECENTLY
TO TALK TO IS ABOUT THE
CONCERNS E HAVEN'T FULLY
FLESHED OUT EVERYTHING THAT DAY
THEY TALKED ABOUT. BUT WORK
WORK ENERGETICALLY WILLING TO
MAKE SURE THIS GETS DONE
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT. IS
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US. THAT WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THIS
DONE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER
YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR THE- YEAH
THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL PERMIT
THE COMPANIES TO SEEK
INDEMNITY. FROM THE END USER.
OF FOR THE THEIR PROPORTIONAL
SHARE OF THE LIABILITY HAS BEEN
MENTIONED SUCKS SO WITHOUT
DOUBT MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
DOUBLE. THE MOTION AS DO PASSED
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE PROCESSED AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CHAFF HI
SHALL I KILEY. BAUER-KAHAN RK
HAND AYE BENNETT AYE BENNETT
AYE CORREA. CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING GABRIEL.
APRIL I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I
IRWIN NOTHING- WE'RE NOT VOTING
LEE. HI LEAI WICKS WICKS HI.
HAS THAT HAS THE COUNT IS SEVEN
TO ZERO AND THAT BILLS OUT THE
BILL IS OUT AND LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR Q. THAT JOB BRINGS UP TO
THE NEXT ITEM I KNOW THAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO GO IN FINAL ORDER
BUT I AM WILLING TO AND I'M
GOING TO SKIP OVER MY BILLS- SO
THAT UP MY COLLEAGUES COULD GO
IN FRONT OF ME SO- WITH THAT I
THINK THE NEXT STEP. A BILL IS
GOING TO BE ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT THAT'S
MISS IRWIN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
TO BILLS YES AND YEAH AND-
FIVE- THIS WICKS HAS TWO BILLS
TO PRESENT SO WHAT WOULD IT BE
OKAY IF WE LISTEN TO A FIFTY
NINE FIRST ABSOLUTELY. SURE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. CALIFORNIANS HAVE
MADE IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
THEY HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THEIR PRIVACY AND ALLOWING BIG
GOVERNMENTS TO DO REAL TIME
TRACKING OF THEIR LOCATION NOT
ONLY CONFIRMS THEIR FEARS BUT
IT ALSO RUNS COUNTER TO LAWS
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT TO AB
EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH I'M A
JOINT AUTHORS WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AB EIGHT FIFTY
NINE AND FORCES LIMITS ON STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY
ABILITY TO COMPEL MOBILITY DATA
FROM COMPANIES AFFIRMING THE
MOBILITY DEVICE INFORMATION IS
COVERED UNDER. THE CURRENT
PROVISIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
PRIVACY ACT AS IT RELATES TO
CALIFORNIA. BERMAN COLLECTION
OF LOCATION INFORMATION.
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL OPINION I REQUESTED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PERMITTING
OPERATIONS THAT COMPEL TRIP
DATA FOR MOBILITY DEVICES ARE
GOVERNED BY KELEFA REQUIRING
EITHER THE USER'S CONSENT OR A
COURT ORDER TO BE COMPLIANT
WITH THE LAW. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE INCORRECTLY AND DANGEROUSLY
DISPUTING THIS INTERPRETATION
ARGUING ARGUING THAT KELEFA
ONLY APPLIES TO POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND COLLECTING THIS
LOCATION WITHOUT USERS CONSENT
OR A COURT ORDER AND I ALSO
HAVE TO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ANALYSIS BY- YOUR STAFF- ON
PAGE TEN IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE C. P. S. IT SAYS
THE CQC HAS EXCLUSIVE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER TNCS.
THE CQC HAS ALREADY IMPOSED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ON
SIMILAR TRIP DATA WHICH CAN BE
SHARED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
USE THAT DATA. SHARED BY THE C.
B. CPUC THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
STATUTORY ABILITY TO COMPEL THE
DATA FROM TNCS DIRECTLY. THIS
BILL SIMPLY SEEKS TO CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW WHILE PROVIDING A
PATH FORWARD FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WANT TO USE.
PRIVACY PROTECTED FORMS OF DATA
LIKE AGGREGATE COUNTY
IDENTIFIED DATA FOR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND I'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BILL'S
LABOR OPPOSITION AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO FINDING A SOLUTION
AS WE MOVE INTO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. BUT
WE NEED TO STRESS THAT WHILE WE
WILL SEEK TO IDENTIFY AND MEET
LABOUR'S NEEDS TO PROTECT
WORKERS THE BILL MUST CONTINUE
TO PROTECT OUR CONSTITUENTS
PRIVACY RIGHTS AS WELL. AS A
LEAD TO LEGISLATURE WE MUST
TAKE A STAND ON AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS PRIVACY WE MUST
MAKE IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
IN CALIFORNIA RENTING A SCOOTER
OR GETTING A RIDE FROM AN APP
DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU HAVE TO
WAIVE YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS. NOR DOES IT MEAN THAT
THE GOVERNMENT HAS UNFETTERED
RIGHT TO TRACK YOUR MOVEMENT.
AND MICHAEL MOVOTO WE- ONE
OFFERED THEIR TECH TEAM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AFTER PRESENTING THE BILL
TODAY I'M PROUD TO BE A JOINT
AUTHOR ON AB EIGHT FIVE NINE I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS. LOCATION DATA IS
INTRINSICALLY SENSITIVE WITH
THE POTENTIAL TO REVEAL OUR
CONSTITUENTS DEEPLY PRIVATE
INFORMATION SUCH AS THEIR HOME
WORK. PLEASE PLACE OF WORSHIP
MEDICAL PROVIDERS ADDRESSES AND
MORE. THIS DATA MUST BE
PROTECTED. WELL TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND KEEPING OUR
SIDEWALKS CLEAR ARE IMPORTANT
FUNCTIONS OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE CANNOT IGNORE
IMPORTANT RESTRICTIONS ON
GOVERNMENT SEARCHES. AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE WOULD GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES DATA
COLLECTION AUTHORITY THAT THEY
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE. BY
PERMITTING THESE ENTITIES TO
ACQUIRE DE IDENTIFIED AND
AGGREGATED MICRO MATILDE DATA
DEVICE DATA. THE BILL WILL
STRIKE AN IMPORTANT BALANCE
BETWEEN LOCAL PLANNING NEEDS
AND CALIFORNIA IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY AND
STATUTORILY PROTECTED RIGHTS TO
PRIVACY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATE NUMBER
IRWIN AND EVERY STAKEHOLDER AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD. AND WE
FIND MORE COMMON GROUND AND WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO LET'S GO TO OUR SUPPORT
WINDOWS SO WE THINK WE HAVE
DILLON HOFFMAN WITH THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION BY
TELEPHONE. MIZRAAB GREATER- IS
MISTER HOFFMAN ON THE LINE. HI
MISTER CARE I'M HERE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE MISSED OFTEN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE ARE
KEEPERS PRETTY PRETTY STONE
HOFFMAN DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR INTERNET
SENSATION WERE PROUD TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE NINE- WHICH
WOULD BE A MEANINGFUL STEP TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS REAL TIME
LOCATION DATA- AS THE AUTHOR'S
BOOK STATED DISINFORMATION IS
INCREDIBLY PERSONAL- AND
PROTECTING IT AS THOSE
ESSENTIAL- WE THINK THAT THAT
SMART CITY PLANNING DOES NOT
HAVE TO COME AT THE EXPNSE OF
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND WE'RE
DEDICATED AT AT OUR COMPANIES
ARE DEDICATED TO WORKING WITH
CITIES AND MOBILITY OPERATORS.
TO DEVELOP SMART PROTECTIVE AND
DATA RICH SOLUTIONS IN THIS
SPACE- FOR THESE REASONS WERE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB EIGHT FIVE
NINE AND AVAILABLE. FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THAT IS. THE WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM- MISTER
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE- OPEN
UP THE LINE PHONE FOR- PEOPLE
COMING IN TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
THIS IS AB. EIGHT FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS
TIME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WILL NOW GO TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT. PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKYOU-
GOOD MORNING SHARE AND MEMBERS
THIS IS TRACY ROSENBERG CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OPEN PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIVE NINE. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. TO CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE HAD SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR OPERATOR LET LET'S NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION A BELIEF WE
HAVE US A LEADER RENTALS WITH
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION BY A TELEPHONE.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES I AM A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE LEADER REYNOLDS
GENERAL MANAGER FOR LA DOTD IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE NINE. TO MANAGE THE
FORTY THOUSAND DOCKLESS DEVICES
OPERATING IN LOS ANGELES WE
REQUIRE BASIC INFORMATION FROM
FOR PROFIT COMPANIES WITHOUT
THE DATA WE COULD NOT RESPOND
TO BLOCK SIDEWALKS ENSURE
EQUITABLE ACCESS OR VERIFY
SAFETY OUR SYSTEM IS NOT BUILT
TO RECEIVE PERSONAL INFORMATION
FROM RIDERS BUT WE PROTECT IT
AS IF IT DID. WE STORE DATA AND
AGGREGATE WE DO NOT RECEIVE
REAL TIME TRIP DATA WE BLOCK
THIS DATA FROM PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE AND NEVER SHARE WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT ABSENT A
SUBPOENA AFTER ALMOST THREE
YEARS OF RUNNING OUR PROGRAM
SPECULATION ABOUT COMPROMISED
DATA HAS PROVEN FALSE BUT
COMPANIES HAVE PROVIDED
INCOMPLETE FLAWED AND
MANIPULATED DATA. CONSUMER
PRIVACY IS ESSENTIAL BUT THIS
BILL WILL FORCE US TO REGULATE
BLINDFOLDED AS STATED BY THE U.
S. DISTRICT COURT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CHAOS AND
SUCCESSFUL DIGITALLY MANAGE
MODE IS MEANINGFUL REGULATION
AND ROBUST DATA AB EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE NINE WOULD STIFLE
INNOVATION AND PREMATURELY
BLOCK CITIES FROM SUCCESSFUL
DEPLOYMENT OF FUTURE MOST LIKE
EIGHTIES AND AROUND. THE CITY
OF LA. STRONGLY OPPOSES THIS
BILL. I YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WEEK-
VITAL. WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AFL-CIO BY TELEPHONE.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE MISTER
MARTINEZ. YES SIR CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES SO PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SOUGHT EDUARDO MARTINEZ
ABOUT HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION RESPECTFUL BUT
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE. WE BELIEVE AB
FIFTEEN I WOULD EFFECTIVELY
PRIVATIZED THE REGULATION OF
LABOR STANDARDS OF
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES DELIVERY NETWORK
COMPANIES AND MICROBIAL DEVICES
TO THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES. A
CLASSIC EXAMPLE OF THE FOX
GUARDING THE HENHOUSE NEED MORE
CREATURES GIVEN THESE COMPANIES
HAVE A LONG TRACK RECORD OF
UNDERMINING REPORT POLICY GOAL
ESTABLISHED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. UNDER THE GUISE OF
PROTECTING CONSUMER PRIVACY AB
EIGHT FIVE NINE WOULD ALLOW
THESE BILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES
THE ABILITY TO AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY BY RENDERING THE
DATA THEY PROVIDE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEARLY USELESS. IF
THE AUTHOR IN HER COALITION ARE
TRULY CONCERNED ABOUT DATA
PRIVACY OUR FOCUS SHOULD BE ON
A STATUS IN PROTOCOL STANDARDS
AND IF NEEDED PENALTIES ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR FAILURE
TO PROTECT CONSUMER DATA.
INSTEAD EIGHTY FIVE NINE WOULD
TIE THE HANDS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO EFFECTIVELY
REGULATE THESE COMPANIES IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS WHAT IS AT
THIS POINT I THEORETICAL
PROBLEM AROUND DATA SECURITY IN
THE. WE ASK FOR YOUR NOTEBOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF SIR. A
THIS TIME THE TURN TO A PHONE
LINE FOR. OPPOSITION HI MISTER.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES. THIS
IS AGAIN. AB EIGHT FIFTY NINE
WHO WERE ON OPPOSITION. IN THE
FUTURE FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WELL FIRST GO TO
LINE. FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO WE
ABOUT BECAUSE WHAT MANDATE
STATION ON THE BILL THANKS.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BIND.
FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING SHANE
DAWSON ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
FIFTY ONE. SHARE MEMBERS
TERAFLOPS ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANKS
PLEASE. IT'S AVAILABLE BY.
SIXTY TWO. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS HAVE A CARBON WRESTLING
NOT IN OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND PIERCY ACTUALLY TECHNICALLY
DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL YET WE'RE STILL ANALYZING
HOWEVER THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT WE DO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK IN THIS AREA- AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD BUT THERE'S A VERY REAL
NOT HYPOTHETICAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THE RICHNESS OF DATA HERE WE
REMAIN DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE REST OF RE IDENTIFICATION
WHENEVER INDIVIDUALIZED
INFORMATION IS BEING COLLECTED
AND SHARED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YEAH NEXT PLEASE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE. FIFTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SOVIET AT THE
LEAST SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
BY. FIFTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CENTER
PERERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE LINE
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID HOW
THINK YOU GO TO TAKE A QUICK
LOOK AT YOUR PC ON BEHALF OF
OUR THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL HAS WRITTEN
THE BILL WOULD SEVERELY LIMIT.
THE AUTONOMY AT SIX. I THANK
ALL A- THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE. EIGHT
I WANTED. HELLO TURN NUMBERS
CALENDARING COUNTY ON BEHALF
BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA CITY WE
ARE OPPOSED AB EIGHT FIVE NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
AND PARDON ME- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN YOU MAY HAVE QUEUED
UP WISHING TO SPEAK RIGHT NOW
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE. FIFTY FOUR. MORNING MY
NAME IS TERRY JOHNSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIRPORT COUNCIL WE
ARE SPEAKING AND OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE BY.
SIXTY ONE. WHERE NAY BAYARDO
SEIU CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WOULD
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER
BENNETT FILED BY MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. F. NOT TO GO TO
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHORS OF
ONE WHAT IS YOUR CONFIDENCE
LEVEL THAT THE CITY'S CAN
RECEIVE THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED THAT IS THE OPERATIONAL
INFORMATION WITHOUT RECEIVING
THE PERSONAL DATA- INFORMATION
OF THE ACTUAL USER OF THE- OF
THE OF THE OF THE EQUIPMENT AND
PARTICULARLY AS- THIS WHOLE
AREA OF FALSE- IN TERMS OF LAST
MILE AS I MENTIONED IN MY
PREVIOUS COMMENTS EARLIER
TODAY- SO WHAT'S YOUR
CONFIDENCE LEVEL WHICH ACCOUNT
IS LEVEL THAT THE BILL CAN
ACCURATELY REFLECT- THAT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN. CITIES AND
OTHERS WHO NEED TO
TRANSPORTATION INFORMATION BUT-
THEY DON'T NEED THE
IDENTIFICATION CAN HELP ME WITH
THAT PLEASE SO WE HAVE NOT
HEARD A VERY GOOD ARTICULATION
OF LIFE INDIVIDUAL TRIP DATA IS
NEEDED EXCEPT FOR POTENTIALLY
CONVENIENCE LATER ON WE ARE
READY ALLOWING OPERATIONAL DATA
AND DE IDENTIFIED DATA. SO AND
IN ALL THE STATE AGAIN OF WE
CAN HAVE ALL THE ARGUMENTS FROM
THESE CITIES ON OF WHY THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS DATA BUT
IT IS ACTUALLY NOT ALLOWED BY
KELEFA. SO IT'S IT IS A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY SHOULD NOT BE
COLLECTING REAL TIME LOCATION
DATA THAT REAL TIME LOCATION
DATA IS ALMOST AS SENSITIVE AS
MEDICAL DATA BECAUSE YOU GET A
COUPLE OF POINTS AND YOU HAVE
THE CITIES THAT KNOW WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE AND YOU BASICALLY
ARE ABLE TO TRACK SOMEBODY. TO
THEIR HOME AND EVERY OTHER
STUFF ALONG THE WAY IT'S
ACTUALLY OF FRIGHTENING IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT IT WAS A NEW
YORK TIMES ARTICLE THAT SHOWED
HOW WITH THIS DATA YOU COULD
TRACK PEOPLE EVERYWHERE
THROUGHOUT. THE CITY SO- I THAT
CAN WERE WITH A AND MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE- INFORMATION THEY
NEED. WITHOUT GOING AGAINST
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE VOTED FOR
A FEW YEARS AGO. WHICH WAS
SKALICA SO YOU YOU YOU YOU
BELIEVE THERE IS A TECHNICAL
SOLUTION THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO GET. WHERE THE EQUIPMENT IS
GOING WITHOUT NECESSARILY
GETTING THE INFORMATION ON WHO
THE OPERATOR IS OF THAT QUICK.
THE DAY UP WITHOUT THE REAL
TIME- WITHOUT THE REAL TIME
DATA AND THEN OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE
HEARD SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION
FROM FROM THE FROM THE- LABOR
TODAY- AND- THE- BUT I THINK
THERE'S A RECOGNITION THAT-
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED- TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL IT WOULD BE.
CONTINGENT UPON YOU WORKING THE
WORKING THESE ISSUES OUT ITH
LABOR- BEFORE THIS MOVES- AFTER
AFTER THIS COMMITTEE WHAT WHAT
YOUR LEVEL OF COMMITMENT TO
WORKING THIS OUT WITH LABOR
AND- THE SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION
WE HEARD HERE TODAY. AND BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND I
KNOW THAT WE CAN'T- WE CAN'T
MOVE THIS FORWARD OF THE BEYOND
THIS COMMITTEE WITHOUT A
WORKING SOMETHING OUT WITH
LABOR- WE WITH. WE THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM. BUT I WILL STATE
THAT THERE ARE OTHER EFFECTIVE
MECHANISMS THAT ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO- FOR WAGE
ENFORCEMENT WITHOUT HAVING
GOVERNMENT- COLLECT ALL THIS
DATA AND- THAT'S BASICALLY A
COURT ORDER OR SUBPOENA OUR OR
OR- COMPLAINTS THAT COULD BE
AND GIVEN IN TO THE- CITY
ATTORNEY. YEAH WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO BE SUPPORTING-
THE INDUSTRY AND HIDING LABOR
INFORMATION THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HIDE LABOR ABUSES
AND I THINK THAT'S THE- THAT'S
THE- ISSUE THAT LABOUR'S SPRING
UP HERE SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS CONTINGENT UPON THAT YOUR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO TO DO
THAT TODAY THANK YOU. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THAT NO I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT BILL AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND IT
STRENGTHENS TWO REALLY
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES TO ME AS
WE MOVE INTO THE ELECTRONIC
DIGITAL AGE WHERE WE ARE
CERTAINLY CAPABLE OF BEING
SURVEILLED BY THE DEVICES WE
HAVE ON A SORT DEVICES WE USE-
EVEN IF WE HOPE THEY'RE NOT
BEING. SURVEILLED YOUR ONE IS
THAT THE DATA SHOULD BE DE
IDENTIFIED AS A GENERAL
PRINCIPLE AND TO. I THINK THIS
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAW- IT
TOO IS IF THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS
TO GET. INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR
LOCATION IT SHOULD GET A
WARRANT. I MEAN THESE ARE NOT
OUR THINGS IN MY FORMER LIFE AS
A PROSECUTOR- I'VE WROTE PLENTY
WARRANTS. IF YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
REASON YOU GET A JUDGE TO FIND
THAT. YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE A
HOMICIDE OR SOMETHING YOU NEED
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE SOMEBODY
WENT ON A PARTICULAR NIGHT
THEIR SUSPECT IT. IT'S A FAIRLY
SIMPLE PROCESS TO DO THAT BUT
IT'S A FAIRLY IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE REQUIRE THAT THAT BE
DONE- YOU KNOW UNDER FOURTH
AMENDMENT CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES. I GUESS MY
QUESTIONS FOR THE OPPOSITION
BECAUSE I LISTEN TO ALL THE
OPPOSITION AND I GET THE LABOR
PEACE ON YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE- THAT. THE LABOR
STANDARDS ARE BEING FORCED AND
I HEAR YOUR RESPONSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ONE THAT THERE ARE
EXISTING MECHANISMS FOR DOING
THAT. J. THINK IT'S A FAIR
RESPONSE- HERE THE CITY OF LA
AND THEY'RE LIKE WELL WE'RE
ALREADY DOING ALL THESE THINGS
THAT THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
BUT WERE OPPOSED TO SITE. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY I. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR ANY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT. WOULD NEED REAL
TIME LOCATION DATA. SO IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION I
GUESS. IN THE AIRWAVES HERE
WHATEVER. THEY CAN. ANSWER THAT
BECAUSE I DID OT HEAR THAT.
ARGUMENT MADE FROM ANYBODY
THAT'S A THOUSAND. WHAT THE
OPPOSITION- LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THAT QUESTION ANYBODY FROM THE
OPPOSITION SIDE. YEAH THIS IS
THE LEADER REYNOLDS- FROM LA
DOT I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND. IF
YOU CAN HEAR ME GO AHEAD YES WE
HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE. SURE
GREAT SO I WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE HEARD
REPEATED A COUPLE TIMES HERE
WHICH IS- WE DO NOT GET ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO IS ON ANY
OF THESE DEVICES. THE
INFORMATION COMES TO US IN A
RANDOMLY ASSIGNED NUMBER AND WE
ONLY KNOW THIS COMPANY HAD A
DEVICE AT THIS LOCATION I ALSO
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WE DON'T
IF THE USER. STOPS THE TRIP- OR
START THE TRIP WE DO NOT GET
THAT DATA IN REAL TIME EITHER
THERE'S A LACK ON THAT DATA
BEFORE REBOOT WE RECEIVE IT
HOWEVER IF A COMPANY- DROPPED A
BUNCH OF SCOOTERS ON A CORNER.
WE DO GET THAT INFORMATION SO
THE COMPANY CREATES AN EVENT WE
GET THAT INFORMATION
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE WE HAVE
VERY SPECIFIC RULES ABOUT HOW
MANY DEVICES EACH INDIVIDUAL
COMPANY CAN HAVE ON EACH
INDIVIDUAL CORNER. IN VERY
CROWDED PLACES LIKE KOREATOWN
IN VENICE- WHERE WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WALKING AND BIKING
AND OTHERWISE USING THE
SIDEWALK. SO FOR US- THE MAIN
SORT OF STICKING POINT HERE IS
THE AT THE AGGREGATION
REQUIREMENTS SO FOR US TO
RECEIVE AGGREGATED DATA FROM A
COMPANY MEANS THAT A COMPANY
CAN MANIPULATE IT BEFORE WE
RECEIVE IT. AND WE ARE
RECEIVING THIS DATA IN ORDER TO
CHARGE FEES AND TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR REGULATIONS
THAT ADDRESS EVERYTHING FROM
RACIAL EQUITY TO OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. SO FOR YOU KNOW OUR LONG
TRACK RECORD OF EXPERIENCE AS
REGULATORS IS THAT COMPANIES
HAVE A BUSINESS REASON TO
MANIPULATE. DATA IN ORDER TO
REDUCE THE FEES THEY PAY OR TO
INCREASE NUMBER THE OF THEIR
FLEET THEY CAN HOW ON THE WAY.
SO THAT'S REALLY THE MAIN PIECE
OF THE MAIN PIECE OF THE BILL
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC FOR US-
BECAUSE I NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE INVESTIGATORS GO OUT AND
DO SPOT CHECKS MEANING. THEY
START ARRIVING AND DERIDE AND
WE SEE IF THAT DATA IS COMING
INTO OUR SYSTEM IN A VERIFIABLE
WAY SO THAT WE CAN TRUST ALL OF
THE DATA THAT WE'RE RECEIVING.
FROM COMPANIES AND AS WE LOOK
INTO THE FUTURE AND THINK ABOUT
A DRONE DELIVERIES AND THINK
ABOUT THAT AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
AND THINK ABOUT. REGULATION OF
OTHER FORMS OF A MOBILITY THAT
WE HAVEN'T EVEN IMAGINED YET-
HAVING VERIFIABLE DATA ABOUT
DEVICES NEVER EVER ABOUT USERS
IS CRITICAL FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO ALLOW A FEW SOLUTIONS TO
COMMENT TO CITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER LEGAL HAD. I WANT
TO THANK OUR AUTHORS FOR ANY
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
BRING THIS BILL FOR IT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT THE BALANCE BETWEEN
DATA TRANSPARENCY IN PROTECTING
THE PRIVACY AND SAFEGUARDING
THAT OF OUR OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. I'M OFF TO MAKE
THIS A BRIEF BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
CULTURAL COMMITTEE NOW BUT YOU
KNOW I THINK. WITH THAT BEING
SAID. WE LIVE IN AN ERA RIGHT
NOW WHERE THAT IMMENSE. DATA
RIGHT NOW HAS SUCH GREAT USES
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO. PROPERLY PLAN OUR
STREETS AND ALSO MAKE A PROP
TWENTY TWO THERE IS OBVIOUSLY A
LOT OF CONCERN TO MAKE SURE THE
P. DRIVERS AND THE PEOPLE
UTILIZING THESE. TECHNOLOGIES
ARE BEING WELL PROTECTED SO- I
DEFINITELY RESPECT THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING AND I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE DOING BUT FOR THE
TIME BEING WITH ALL THE
CONCERNS I CAN'T BE SUPPORTING
RIGHT NOW. BUT I DO THINK IT'S
A WORTHY YET. OR THE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA. IS THERE ARE. NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- I WANT TO THANK BOTH
OF YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED WORK
ON THIS AREA AT YOUR LOCATION
IS ONE AREA THAT. I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON BOTH
OF YOU AND- SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT AND- I DO
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY TWO NEW OPPOSITION-
THE BILL. WENT THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE- LAST YEAR AND I
THINK THAT IT DID RECEIVE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN. SO THEN
I THINK THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO. CONFINED TO A
LITTLE BIT GOING FORWARD SO I
AM VERY COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING
IT- TODAY- AND ALSO. ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I THINK- I THINK
YOU HAVE FOUGHT. TRYING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE I THINK
THAT. IT'S YOU'RE ALMOST THERE
SO. TO JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
SO. SO WITH THAT- I DON'T LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO CLOSE. I THINK
I'LL KNOW THE- THERE'S MOTION
YET. LIKE DR MOTION FOR THE
BILL. ON THE- VERY GOOD THANK
YOU AND PLEASE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY OF A
MISTER SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AT THIS IS AB EIGHT FIFTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAP HI SHALL I
KILEY. KILEY I POWER QUE HAN.
BENNETT BENNETT I ACRAEA.
CARILLO NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER IRWIN FIVE- WHEN I
LEE. WICKS HI WICKS I. YOUR
BILL HAS SIX VOTES AND IT IS
OUT CONGRATULATIONS I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE LOST ONE OF THE BILL-
THE AGENDA TODAY THAT IS-
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE THIS
QUICK CHANGE. LIMITED TIME
FRAME OF FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT IS A
BILL THAT WILL UPDATE OUR STATE
LAWS ON CHARITABLE GIVING- TO
ACCOUNT FOR NEW ONLINE METHODS
OF DONATING WHILE PROVIDING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO BOTH
DONORS AND CHARITIES THIS BILL
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING WORK
PRODUCT FOR NEARLY FOUR YEARS.
IN MY OFFICE UPDATE THE
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THE NEW
REALITY OF ONLINE CHARITABLE
SOLICITATION AND STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS- LED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BEGAN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS COMMITTEE HAS
PASSED VERSIONS OF THIS BILL
TWICE AND LAST YEAR A NEARLY
IDENTICAL IDENTICAL VERSION
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY. OVER THE
LAST YEAR WITH SO MANY PROBLEMS
FACING OUR STATE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE TURNED TO THE
INTERNET TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
LOCAL CHARITIES THERE ARE
VARIOUS WAYS TO GIVE ONLINE
INCLUDING DIRECTLY TO CHARITY
AND INDIRECTLY TO VARIOUS
CHARITIES THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORMS. THAT LISTS ALL
CHARITIES- REGISTERED WITH THE
IRS FOR EIGHTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PLATFORMS PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY CHARITY
TO REACH FAR BEYOND THEIR
TRADITIONAL DONOR BASE WHILE
PROVIDING KEY OVERSIGHT
CAPABILITIES FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY. ANTHONY LIU FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I MISS LOU ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE- THE AG'S
OFFICE HAVE BEEN ADVISING AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE FAMILY
WINNER WHEN OFFICE DATING BACK
TO THE BEGINNING OF LAST YEAR.
WHEN WE WERE THE SPONSOR OF
LAUGHTER IT BILL. I'M A COMPANY
ON THE LINE BY BRIAN ARMSTRONG
OPEN AG'S OFFICE IS AVAILABLE
TO EMPLOYERS TECHNICAL
QUESTION. TODAY IN SHORT EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED OVERSIGHT OF
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING ON
INTERNET PLATFORMS OUR OFFICE
IS A GOLD ARE TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIA DONORS. AND
DECEPTIVE OR MISLEADING.
CHARITABLE SOLICITATIONS. AT
THANK ABOUT WOMAN FOR HER
COMMITMENT THE FISHING. A GREEN
THAT THE FOR THE RIGHT TO A
CURRENT LAW AND IT. A BAY FREE.
TO ENABLE THE EIGHT OP ACT FIVE
PROPS SUPERVISION OVER THEY
EVERITT. AREA OF ONLINE SHARED
WITH THE WITH THE TASTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP
LET'S GO ADDITION SUPPORTERS MR
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES- FOR PEOPLE
TO CALL IN. TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AGAIN THIS IS AB. FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. AND UP JUST A
REMINDER THAT PHONE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE PEOPLE OF
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE FIFTY. EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF
THE NONPROFIT ALLIANCE WE HAVE
A SUPPORT DEMENTED CONDITION.
AND IF I COULD THINK. AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. FIVE ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE MINOR
ANYMORE PATTERSON IS THERE SHE
IS ON BEHALF OF A PAL IN
SUPPORT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS THAT YOU
KNOW FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS HERE
AND APPRECIATE HER YOU KNOW
COMING TO THE PLACE OF THE
DOLLARS AND NOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND NEXT PLACE. THANKS.
SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR CHRIS BOLLINGER MAP A
CLASSY- AND WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M. THIRTY THIS IS HEALTHY THE
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT WE ARE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED WE WANT TO
SEE TWO LOOPHOLES CLOSED THAT
CURRENTLY ALLOW PLATFORMS TO
SHARE MISINFORMATION ABOUT
NONPROFIT AND TO DELAY DONATION
DISTRIBUTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS PLEASE. FIVE SIXTY
NINE. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS FRED NOTE WHERE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. JUST YOU NINE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. HELLO THIS
IS JEFFREY LEE **** ON BEHALF
OF GO FUND ME- SUPPORTING THE
BILL IN APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
OF THE AG AND THE AUTHOR OF
THIS AREA THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE OUTSIDE SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. WHAT
ABOUT THE TELECONFERENCE ROOM.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY FROM THAT
ROOM. SEEING NONE THAT'S GOOD
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
CAMERON DIMITRIOU DEMETRIOU
WITH TECHCONNECT UP BY
TELEPHONE. ARE YOU ON THE LINE
MISTER DIMITRIOU. M. CHAIR. GO
AHEAD PLEASE GOOD MORNING
SHERRY MEMBERS ONLY. WE TO
CORRECT THAT WE DON'T HAVE AN
OPPOSED WHICH IS A TWEENER I'M
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN FINANCIAL.
BACKDROP I CAN'T EVENTS THAT BY
EVER TO TEXT AND YOUR GLASS THE
PROMOTE THE GROWTH INNOVATION
ECONOMY. REPRESENT OVER EIGHTY
HAVE COMPANIES AND POINT FIVE
MILLION CUSTOMERS TECHNICALLY
CAN YOU TALK WITH US ON FORTY
EIGHT BASED ON THE LATEST AND
TAKING ON MARCH TWENTY. WE WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION ALL THE WORK THE
OPERATOR STAFF ISSUE OF THE
PAST NUMBER OF YEARS OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL IS AND HAS
ALWAYS BEEN FROM CHARITABLE
GIVING PROCESS EASY SAFE
ACCEPTABLE AND TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE. WE BELIEVE YOU SLICE
LEMONS TO MAKE THE USE OF
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE INFORMATION
FROM IRAQ SIGNED. DOCUMENTATION
FILED BY THE AG WILL ASSIST TO
BETTER INFORM DONORS THE
IDENTITY OF WHAT CHARITY VERY
CHEMICAL. SHOW ME A MOMENTOUS
ACTUALLY CAL YOU NEED GETTING
MY WHERE DO. ARE GIVEN BY. A
PLATFORM CHARITY GUEST IS SHARE.
AT THE DIRECTION A CAN IS. HOW
DO WE STILL HAVE A- SIGNIFICANT
HM LED TO ANIMAL FIGURE RIGHT
OUT OF JAIL. IT. FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY. I THANK YOU WHICH
WAY TO CREATE A SECRET COMING
RIGHT THERE JUST. WE CONTINUE
MAINTAIN THE BAT OUR NOT
LIMITED TO SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SHOULD BE SO. AND WE BELIEVE
EVERYTHING THAT'S BECAUSE
CONTINUES TO ABOUT EIGHT TO
PROMULGATE. REGULATION THAT
THAT PROGRAM CRACKERS FOR
BOETTCHER- WE YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THIS ISSUE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOOK FORWARD CONTINUE TO
WORK MEMBERS FUND. THANK YOU
FOR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUTLETS NOW
GO TO IT IS. A IN ALL. TO THE
BILL. AB FORTY OF MISTRUST
WRITER OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE.
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN. PLEASE PRAY ONE THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. GOING TO GO TO- LINE.
SIXTY SIX. HI DON HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION
LARA LINE MY COMMENTS- WITH
THAT- WE ARE MOVING TO NEUTRAL
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
ALTERNATES. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THAT SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MISTER OPERATOR LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES GO AHEAD
MISS ABOUT HIM- WHEN WOULD YOU
MIND ADDRESSING B. COMMENTS.
BECAUSE OPPOSITION OF ADD
ACCOUNT NON PROFITS RELATED TO
MISINFORMATION ABOUT. AND USING
THEIR LOGOS AND TRADEMARKS TO
SEND OUT MISINFORMATION. AND
WHETHER YOU'LL BE ADDRESSING
THAT AND THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT DELAYS IN DISTRIBUTING
DONATIONS. OF THOSE ARE AT THE
I WILL TELL YOU OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS THIS HAS BEEN A
EXTREMELY ROBUST- STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND WE'VE ADDRESSED
DOZENS OF THOSE CONCERNS AND-
THAT IS. THAT'S ONE THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO- TO WORK ON THE
WILL THERE'S GOING TO BE MORE
WORK BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT THAT THESE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE HAPPY WITH THE
FINAL PRODUCT THAT AS YOU KNOW-
WE NEED TO REGULATE ONLINE
GIVING A MANY OF US HAVE HEARD
HORROR STORIES ABOUT IT SO.
WE'RE REALLY HOPING THAT THIS
IS THE YEAR THAT WE- THAT WOULD
CROSS THE FINISH LINE AND IF WE
DO NOT HAVE CAL NONPROFITS ON
BOARD THEN WE WILL NOT BE DOING
THAT. THANK YOU ANSWER ON FREE
WORK ON THIS IT IS IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE- I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY ALSO OF I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AS- THE
OTHER PROJECT THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT FOR THE LAST TWO AT
LEAST TWO YEARS AT THE HEIGHT
WE CAN RECALL SO- PLEASE KEEP
UP THE GOOD WORK AND ALSO THE
ONE I THINK THE G. SO I WORK AS
WELL. AND SO IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE UP PLEASE DO SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
THOUGHT. I NEED A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. IT'S BEEN MOVED IN
TO HAVE SECOND. BOB IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED UP MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THIS ONE. THIS IS AB FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAP
HI CHAO I KILEY. KILEY NO POWER
QUE HAN OUR QUE HAN I'VE BEEN
IT'S- BEEN IT I CARILLO. I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO IRWIN I'VE IRWIN I
FULLY. WICKS YOU HAVE SIX BOTH
SO FAR THE BILL ITSELF AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I SEE MR LEVINE HERE
IN THE ROOM- INVITE HIM TO COME
UP AND PRESENT HIS BILLS I
THINK HE HAS TO BILL SO. EIGHT
FOURTEEN EIGHT TWENTY FIVE SO
AT YOUR PLEASURE MISS LEVINE
WHICHEVER YOU LIKE TO GO FIRST
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I'LL TAKE AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN. FIRST IN- THE IGLOO
WE CALL ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. I
THINK I BROUGHT THE WRONG
JACKET. GOING TO HAVE A SECOND
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN WOULD PROHIBIT
EMPLOYEES OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY FROM ENGAGING. IN
CONTACT TRACING IN PLACE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ON DATA
COLLECTED FOR CONTACT TRACING
PURPOSES SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
PROHIBITS DATA COLLECTED
RECEIVE HER PREPARED FOR
CONTACT TRACING PURPOSES FROM
BEING USED MAINTAINED OR
DISCLOSED FOR ANY PURPOSE OTHER
PURPOSES THAN FCILITATING
CONTACT TRACING EFFORTS. AS WE
HAVE LEARNED OVER THE PAST YEAR
ONE OF THE STRATEGIES DEPLOYED
TO LIMIT THE TRANSMISSION OF
KOBE NINETEEN IS THE USE OF
CONTACT TRACING WHICH
IDENTIFIES COVE IN NINETEEN
POSITIVE INDIVIDUALS. AND THOSE
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH FOR ADVISED TO
SELF QUARANTINE LIMITING THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS SUCCESSFUL
CONTACT TRACING REQUIRES THE
SHARING OF SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL
INFORMATION INCLUDING A
PERSON'S NAME ADDRESS PHONE
NUMBER AND OTHER PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING DATA. IN MAY OF
LAST YEAR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
LAUNCHED CONNECTED CALIFORNIA A
STATEWIDE CONFERENCE OF CONTACT
TRACING PROGRAM AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. IN DECEMBER
THE STATE LAUNCHED CALIFORNIA
NOTIFY AN APPLICATION THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CAN DOWNLOAD ON
THEIR PHONE THAT WILL NOTIFY
USERS OF ANOTHER APPLICATION
USER THEY'VE BEEN IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH HAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COCAINE NINETEEN.
WELL THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
REQUIRED TO SUCCESSFULLY STOP
THE SPREAD OF THE CORONA VIRUS
AND FUTURE PANDEMICS THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STATE OF POTENTIALLY BEING
USED. FOR NON HEALTHCARE
RELATED PURPOSES INCLUDING
ADVERTISING AND BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE LESS LIKELY. TO
WILLINGLY INTERACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT REGARDLESS OF THE
CONTEXT YOU TO DISTRUST AND
FEAR AND HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CODE NINETEEN. CONTACT TRACING
IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE FUNCTION
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
UTILIZING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
CONTACT TRACE WILL CREATE
DISTRUST IN CONTACT RAISING
EFFORTS AND HINDER OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS. AB EIGHT FOURTEEN
WILL PROTECT THE DATA PRIVACY.
OF CALIFORNIANS AND BUILD
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
CONTACT TRACING PROGRAM. NEEDED
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM FURTHER SPREAD OF
CODE NINETEEN. AND INTENTIONAL
FUTURE PANDEMICS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BEFORE WE GO TO A WITNESSES
SUCH AS A REMINDER TO PHONE
NUMBER BEING. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. YOU'RE FREE TO CALL TO
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF THE BUSINESS THIS
BILL. I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES- CAN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TO SPEAK OUT FIRST IS
BECKER. OF BECKER- KRAMER
MOULDER WITH ACLU BY FALL. MS
KRAMER BUILT ON MORE. ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I AM BACK AT
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN THE
COURT AB EIGHT FOURTEEN OF THE
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
ENSURING THAT APPROPRIATE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS SENSITIVE
INFORMATION COLLECTED AS PART
OF PELLET CONTACT YOU CAN
AFFECT. EXISTING DATA PRIVACY
LAWS DO NOTADEQUATELY PROTECT
US FROM THE MANY WAYS THAT DATA
CAN BE NEXT YEAR. THE LACK OF
PRIVACY PROTECTION JEOPARDIZES
PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORTS IF PEOPLE
DO NOT BELIEVE THE INFORMATION
THEY SHARE WITH CONTACT RECORDS
WILL BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AND
USED ONLY TO ATTRACT THE
PANDEMIC. THEY'RE LESS LIKELY
TO PROVIDE COMPLETE INFORMATION
TO CONTACT YOU ABOUT WHERE THEY
HAVE BEEN AND WHO THEY'VE BEEN
INTERACTING WITH. MY INSURING
APPROPRIATE PRIVACY PROTECTION
AB EIGHT FOURTEEN NOT ONLY
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS PRIVACY
BUT ALSO FOR OTHERS PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS FOR THE REASONS WE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT HAVE SARAH DA ARE WITH THE
K. IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. MR
DAR ARE YOU ON THE LINE MORNING.
I AM GOOD MORNING SHARON
NUMBERS MY NAME AS FAR ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY ABOUT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT AT THE
APP REPORT TIRELESSLY TO
COUNTER THE CHILLING EFFECT
DELIBERATELY BROUGHT ABOUT
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND ENCOURAGE IMMIGRANTS TO
ENROLL IN HEALTH CARE AND OTHER
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
ACCESS CODE NINETEEN TESTING
TREATMENT AND VACCINATION.
CONCERNS AROUND DATA PRIVACY
ARE ONE OF THE PRIMARY REASONS
CITED BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
THEIR HESITATION TO ENGAGE WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH INITIATIVES LIKE
CONTRACT TRACING WELL ADVOCATES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ALIKE ARE MAKING EVERY EFFORT
TO CURB THIS HESITANCY IT ONLY
MAKES OUR COLLECTIVE JOB HARDER
WHEN WE CANNOT GUARANTEE
STATUTORY PROTECTIONS OF
PEOPLE'S INFORMATION PRIVACY.
ESPECIALLY FROM BEING SHARED
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
STATUTORY PROTECTION DO EXIST
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICAID AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA PREVENTING
ANY DATA SHARING WITH NOT ONLY
ONE IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT BUT
WITH ANY PARTY FOR ANY PURPOSE
THAT IS NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM
THESE PROTECTIONS IN STATUTE
OFFER A POWERFUL REASSURANCE TO
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY BE
CONCERNED OR HAS. TO ENROLL AND
SIMILARLY STRONG PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS ARE NEEDED FOR
CONTACT TRACING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF IMMIGRANTS
AND ALL COMMUNITIES ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION POTENTIALLY BEING
USED AGAINST THEM SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS SAW MR
OPERATOR PLEASE. OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR PEOPLE TO CALL IN.
THIS IS A- FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN SO. OF THIS BILL. WHICH
EIGHT CHARACTER AT. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
I'M GOING TO GO TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT. YES GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TRACY ROSENBERG CALLING ON
BEHALF OF OAKLAND PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT OF AB H. ONE FOUR THANK
YOU NEXT. BY. SEVENTY ONE.
MISTER TURN MEMBERS A LEECH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AT THE PARK
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
I'M FORTY ONE. CORRECT NAMES
ARE MEMBERS LED THE WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M. FORTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS WHO SHALL DEAL ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. FIND.
SIXTY FIVE. BOBIC MARVIN BEYOND
FROM COMMON SENSE MEDIA AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. FIND. SIXTY
TWO. AT THE PROGRAM WITH PRC IN
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND TRANSPORT THANK
YOU. EXPLODE YOUR CHAIR NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT I BELIEVE THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES OF FIRST- MISTER SHOW
UP MOHAMMED DELLWOOD CAL TEMPER
MISTER MOHAMMED ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. I AM. PLEASED TO. THANK
YOU. YOUR ARM CURRENT MEMBERS
MANAGE WHAT MUHAMMAD CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
MUST MANDATE OUR THRESHOLD
ISSUES RELATED TO DEFINITIONS
AND DRAFTING AB EIGHT FOURTEEN
STATES THE DATA COLLECTED
RECEIVED A PREPARE FOR PERSON
CONTACT TRACING SHALL NOT BE
USED MAINTAINED OR DISCLOSED
FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSE OTHER
THAN FACILITATING CONTACT
TRACING OUTBREAKS SO HAS
DRAFTED THIS WOULD PROHIBIT THE
USE OF DATA THAT WAS NOT SOLELY
COLLECTED RECEIVE HER PREPARED
FOR THIS PURPOSE. FOR EXAMPLE
SIGN IN SHEETS ARE NOT
COLLECTED FOR PURPOSES THE
CONTACT RATING THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED RECEIVED A REPAIR
PERSON CONTACT TRACING OF THEIR
HELPFUL IF THEY ARE USED TO
SUPPORT CONTACT RAISING EFFORTS
HOWEVER AB FOURTEEN WOULD END
UP PROHIBITING THE USE OF THOSE
SIGN IN SHEETS EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT COLLECTIVELY FOR
EXCLUSIVELY USED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. THE CONTACT TRACING
A SECOND AB FOURTEEN REQUIRES
THAT ALL DATA COLLECTED
RECEIVED COMPARED FOR
CONTRACTORS MUST BE DELETED
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS BUT DOES NOT
PROVIDE EXPLICIT EXCEPTIONS FOR
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS EXISTING
LAW INCLUDING CAL OSHA GUIDANCE
RELATED CODE NINETEEN IN
ADDITION TO POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
WITH EXISTING LAW THE BILL
DATED TWO WEEKS REQUIREMENTS
MAKE QUARTER OTHERWISE USEFUL
INFORMATION FROM BEING USED FOR
CONTACT TRACING. FINALLY WE
ALSO TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
INCLUSION OF A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WITH AN AWARD OF
ATTORNEYS FEES BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WILL PASS OVER
MY COLLEAGUES- AND I APPRECIATE
YOU THE TIME WAS HERE TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE
WE HAVE JAMIE. HUFF ON THE LINE.
THIS OFFER YOUNG LINE. YEAH I
YES- I AM PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET
UP. THANK YOU I DO HAVE MR
CHAIRMAN OR MY NAME IS JAMIE
WHAT THE CIVIL AND ACCOUNT SHE
AND I THINK RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION UNLESS THE MANY TO
AB A COURT. WRITTEN OUT WELL WE
APPRECIATE DOCTORS TO ENSURE
THE HANDLE THE PERSON DAY.
AFTER LUNCH IN THE NATION AND
WE ACTUALLY CREATE A DETERRENCE
TO COLLECTING THE SECRETARY DAY
AFTER OUR SPECIFIC CONCERNS
CENTERS ON THE LIABILITY CREEK
IN THE BILL THE BILL EXPOSES
BUSINESSES TO POTENTIAL
EXCESSIVE AND UNNECESSARY
LAWSUIT INCLUDING RECOVERY OF
PLAINTIFF ATTORNEY FEES. WHICH
IS AN OVERLY PUNITIVE APPROACH
TO TAKE ON BUSINESS OF
ATTEMPTING TO TRACK DATA FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH REASONS AND WHO
WERE NOT IN DISAGREEMENT THAT
PERSONAL DATA SHOULD BE HANDLED
RESPONSIBLY AND COMPLAINTS OF
CURRENT LAW. I THINK THAT IS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC POLICY THIS
BILL OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE IN ITS
APPROACH ON HOW THEY DID IT
HANDLED WHICH WILL LEAD TO MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ADDITIONAL
LAWSUIT DURING A TIME WHEN OUR
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS CAN
LEAST AFFORD TO BEAR THE COST
OF INCREASED LITIGATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU. LET'S
GO TO ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
AMISH. DROP RETURN PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES. FOR THOSE
OPPOSITE TO THE BILL. THE
MYSTERY CARE AGAIN WHO I AND
GENTLEMEN EUROPE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ONE ZERO PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WELL FIRST GO TO LINE
SIXTY SECS. SHINNICK TO OFTEN
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE MOTION AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
SEVEN EIGHT. ADRIN WE HAVEN'T
TECHNICALLY LIKE CAROLINA
COMMENTS WITH OF CALCHAMBER AND
SEE JACK IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE
FORTY. JERRY MEMBERS THEN I
THINK ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
PAYROLL REPORTING CONSORTIUM WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FURTHER
READING REASON PREVIOUSLY
STATED BY CALCHAMBER THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WOULD
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
VERY GOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR OPERATIVE LET'S BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTION-
CHAIR KILEY PLANT. I'M I WANT
US WITH THIS PROVISION- THAT-
THAT BARS LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
PARTICIPATING IN CONTRACTORS IN
BECAUSE- OVER THE LAST YEAR YOU
KNOW WE HAVE. DEPUTIZE MANY
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS- TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
ENFORCE MASS MANDATES- CURFEWS.
AND SEEN VIDEOS OF SUPER
SPREADER PARTIES. AT BEING
BROKEN UP AND- A LOT OF FOLKS
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE BEEN
RESISTANT TO THIS IDEA SAYING
THAT'S NOT REALLY. WHAT WE'RE
HERE FOR- THE NOW WE HAVE A
BILL THAT FOR ONE PARTICULAR%
FACET OF PUBLIC HEALTH CONTACT
TRACING- IN NOT THAT THEY CAN'T
EVEN. YOUR CITY CAN'T EVEN DO
THAT IF THEY'RE SO INCLINED SO
WHERE DO WE DRAW THE LINE IS
TO. WATER LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
HEALTH RELATED USES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL ON ONE
ARM. TO PHILOSOPHICAL. A AND- I
THINK WE CAN DEBATE IT FOR. A
LONG TIME TO COME I THINK WE'VE
SEEN. COUNTY BY COUNTY
SHERIFF'S EXPRESSING THEIR
INTEREST IN USING DISCRETION
ABOUT ENFORCING ANY NUMBER OF
LAWS. RELATED TO COVER
NINETEEN. OR ANYTHING ELSE
REGARDING WHAT IS A PRIORITY
FOR THAT COMMUNITY BECAUSE THY
ONLY HAVE SO MUCH BANDWIDTH OF
SO MUCH MANPOWER. SO YOU KNOW
WE HEAR THIS YOU KNOW. OUTSIDE
OF THE PANDEMIC AS WELL- LAW
ENFORCEMENT. PRIORITIZING HOW
THEY DO ENFORCEMENT MORE
BROADLY. I THINK IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE MORE
SPECIFICALLY AND WHY IT'S
ADDRESS IN THIS BILL- IT'S
REALLY ABOUT. BUILDING TRUST.
IN THE CONTACT RACING PROCESS
WANT MORE PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. AND THIS DOES THAT.
IT HEALTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS MR GAVE UP
I HAD. YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO
THE OPERATE ME VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE SPIRIT AND INTENT
OF THE BILL I THINK IT'S- IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT EFFORT. I
GUESS THE ONE QUESTION I HAVE
FOR YOU MAYBE I JUST MISS
UNDERSTANDING PART OF IT IS- IN
TERMS OF ALLOWING SOME OF THE
DATA TO BE CAPPED FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSES IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU EXPLORE
TOPPED WITH. PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE RESEARCHERS ARE
OTHERS ABOUT BECAUSE I CAN
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND. THE
INITIATIVE TO WANT TO BUILD
CONFIDENCE IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND FROM THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE
IMMIGRATION FOURTH RESPECT I'M
A 1000% SUPPORTIVE OF THAT. I'M
JUST WONDERING IF THERE'S ANY
WAY TO MAYBE TWEAK IT A LITTLE
BIT SO THAT PUBLIC HEALTH FOLKS
AND RESEARCHERS CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT DATA. YOU
KEEP IT OVER TIME BECAUSE THERE
MAY BE THINGS THAT HAPPEN THAT
WE CAN'T ANTICIPATE RIGHT NOW
THAT EIGHT MONTHS FROM NOW.
THAT DATA WOULD BE
EXTRAORDINARILY VALUABLE FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE YEAH
AND WE'RE ENGAGE WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC AGENCIES ON
ON HOW TO DO THAT AS WE MOVE
INTO THE PROCESS AND WHILE I.
YOU KNOW MAKE THAT COMMENT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE STAFF OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE SINCE LAST YEAR- THIS
THIS ISN'T A SIMPLE ONE TO
ADDRESS SO- THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE. YEAH NO THAT'S
GREAT AND I HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN YOU THAT YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE ALL THIS I
THINK WE'VE JUST SEEN EXAMPLES
OF OTHER COUNTRIES AND-
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE WORLD
TO HAVE ROBUST RESERVOIRS OF
DATA ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND ABLE
TO USE THAT TO PROTECT THEIR-
THEIR- THEIR POPULATIONS I
THINK THIS WOULD BE- YOU KNOW
TO IT TO WALK THAT LINE OR WE
CAN DO BOTH OF THOSE THINGS AT
THE SAME TIME I THINK WOULD BE
GREAT. GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. MR GALLAGHER GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH I THINK LIKE.
OTHERS IS. I MEAN. I AM. AGREED
KIND OF THE PREMISE IN THE BILL-
OF WANTING TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
ONLY THE OTHER DAY IS ONLY
BEING USED FOR THAT PURPOSE-
WHAT ABOUT LIKE DATA THAT YOU
MAY WANT TO RETAIN- YOU KNOW
FOR CONDUCTING FURTHER. PUBLIC
HEALTH RELATED CONTACT TRACING
AND IN THAT CASE IT MIGHT BE
LIKE NUMBER RIGHT INTO TO GET
IN TOUCH WITH THE INDIVIDUAL.
IS THAT. SO I WAS LIKE THIS
WOULD BE SAYING NO YOU CAN'T
RETAIN ANY OF THAT IN PERSON SO
THEY HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME TO USE AS A CONTACT RACINE
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE TO
DO IMMEDIATELY- AND TO GET THAT
INFORMATION- SO. THAT'S WITH
THE IMMEDIACY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH BUT YOU
KNOW HOW THIS YOU KNOW A YEAR
LATER- MAYBE A LITTLE BIT LESS
IMPORTANT FOR TRYING TO STOP
COMMUNICABLE. INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. RIGHT OBVIOUSLY YOU
ONLY NEED IT FOR THE THAT
IMMEDIATE PURPOSE SO AFTER THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME SIXTY DAYS. JUST
GET RID OF ALL THE INFORMATION.
YEAH THAT THE CONCEPT YEAH
UNLESS IT'S IN THE POSSESSION-
TO IT TO MR GABRIEL'S POINT OF
THE STATE OR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. WHICH WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE IF THERE'S SOME
LONGER TERM HEALTH RELATED
ISSUE AND I MEAN THAT DOES SEEM
TO MAKE SENSE TO ME- THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION I THINK
IS ANOTHER CONCERN IS. YEAH I
MEAN IS THAT GOING TO LEAD TO
YOU KNOW FOR THE LAWSUITS YOU
KNOW THE MAY PEOPLE DISABLE I
DON'T WANT THE LIABILITY IF
YOU'VE BEEN HAVING ANYTHING TO
DO WITH THIS SO MAYBE IT
DISCOURAGES CONTACT TRACING.
YEAH I DON'T I DON'T. I DON'T-
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERN IT'S
NOT THE FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD
IT- THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
IS REALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING THINGS
PROPERLY NOT TO. NOT TO GET A
WINDFALL RIGHT SO THERE'S ONLY
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF NO ONE'S
GETTING DAMAGES OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. YOU WANT TO STOP THE
BAD BEHAVIOR- AND THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE ONLY PURPOSE THAT WE
HAVE THERE OTHERWISE THERE'S NO
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM- IS IT
CLEAR THERE'D ONLY BE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. SO NO
MONETARY DAMAGES RIGHT YOU KNOW
SOMEONE CAN BRING AN ACTION FOR
MONETARY DAMAGES OVER THIS
THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY THAT'S ALL
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE THANK YOU.
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
WORK AT THE U. POINTED OUT YOU
AND I KIND OF STARTED. ON THIS
TOPIC YOU KNOW ABOUT A YEAR AGO
SO AND- SO I I'M I'M GLAD
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO PUSH AT
THE FORT AND- I UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OP OPPOSITION AS WELL. SOME OF
THEM COULD BE FIXED EASILY
RELATIVELY SPEAKING I THINK YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THE CALLOW
YOUR SITUATION- COULD BE
EASILY- I GUESS FIXED- IF WE
HAD RECEIVED THE OPPOSITION
EARLIER THAN ON WHO COULD
AFFECT HIM TOO SO. SO WITH THAT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
AS WELL- SO I WHICH IS I THINK
IT WAS A MOTION. I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE WAS A SECOND THERE WAS
A MOTION AS A SECOND. AND SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DEBATE- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AB EIGHT ONE FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CHECK OUT
OUR- CHAO I KILEY. KILEY NO
BARRICADE AND- POWER QUE HAN
AYE BENNETT. BENNETT I CARILLO.
I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE AYE
GABRIEL L. I. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I- WENT- WHEN I LEE
WICKS. YOU HAVE PAID VOTE SAID
THE BILL IS OUT THERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU HAVE A BELIEF A
SECOND BILL AB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE I DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE WILL REQUIRE
CALIFORNIANS TO BE NOTIFIED IF
THERE HAS BEEN A BREACH OF
THEIR PERSONAL GENETIC DATA BY
INCLUDING GENETIC DATA IN THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
DATA BREACH NOTIFICATION LAW.
FOR BOTH BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES GENETIC INFORMATION IS
OUR MOST PERSONAL INFORMATION
IT IS INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
MAKES US WHO WE ARE THIS
SENSITIVE INFORMATION IT IN THE
WRONG HANDS RISKS FAR MORE THAN
IMPACTING OUR CREDIT SCORE IT
COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR
HEALTH PRIVACY MAKE US
SUSCEPTIBLE TO GENETIC GENETIC
DISCRIMINATION AND SUBJECT US
TO A NEW GENERATION OF IDENTITY
THEFT AT THE HANDS OF GENETIC
DATA THIEVES AS LOS ANGELES
TIMES REPORTED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN DNA TESTING SERVICE
VITA VITA JEAN INK LEFT
THOUSANDS OF CLIENTS GENETIC
RECORDS EXPOSED ONLINE FOR
YEARS. AT THE TIME OF THE
ARTICLES RELEASED THE COMPANY
HAD NOT NOTIFIED CLIENTS ABOUT
THE EXPOSURE OF THEIR
INFORMATION ONE CUSTOMER SAID
SHE FIRST HEARD OF HER DNA
FIRST HEARD HER DNA WAS LEFT ON
SECURED WHEN BLOOMBERG NEWS
CONTACTED HER FOR STORY SOME OF
THE DOCUMENTS INCLUDED CLIENTS
CONTACT INFORMATION SUCH AS
SOME OF WORK SOME WORK EMAIL
ADDRESSES MAKE IT EASIER TO
CONFIRM PEOPLE'S IDENTITIES A
GENETIC PRIVACY EXPERT AT
VANDERBILT UNIVERSITY NOTED
THAT THE STATE EXPOSURE WAS
EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT AND THAT
RAISE A HOST OF PRIVACY ISSUES
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS. LAST LATE
LAST YEAR G. E. D. MATCH. WAS
HACKED REASON A HOST OF
CONCERNS ABOUT REACHES OF THE
GENETIC DATA IN THISCASE
HACKERS CHANGE THE SETTINGS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE OPTED NOT TO
SHARE THEIR GENETIC INFORMATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO ALLOW
THEIR INFORMATION TO BE SHARED.
WITH SO MUCH PERSONAL DATA AT
RISK CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO
MORE. TO PROTECT CONNECTICUT
DATA FROM A DATA BREACH AND BE
INFORMED ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
THEIR GENETIC INFORMATION.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT FIND
OUT THEIR GENETIC DATA WAS
BREACHED FROM A REPORTER. JUST
AS A COMPANY OR GOVERNMENT
AGENCY MUST DISCLOSE TO AN
INDIVIDUAL IF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR OTHER
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION HAS
BEEN BREACHED. AB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE AM CHORES THAT
CALIFORNIANS WILL RECEIVE.
TIMELY NOTIFICATION IF THERE IS
A BREACH OF THEIR MOST PERSONAL
INFORMATION THEIR GENETIC DATA.
OUR SUCCESS FOR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES-
FIRST MAUREEN MAHONEY WITH
CONSUMER REPORTS SO ARE YOU ON
THE LINE IS MAHONEY. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT
CONSUMER REPORTS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB EIGHT TO
FIVE WHICH WOULD ENSURE THE
CONSUMER SENSE THE GENETIC DATA
IS COVERED BY THE STATE'S DATA
BREACH NOTIFICATION. AND
SECURITY STATUTES. COLLECTION
OF GENETIC DATA IS WIDESPREAD
ABOUT ONE IN FIVE U. S.
CONSUMERS HAS TAKEN A DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TEST MANY OF
THEM LIKELY STEMS OF THEIR
DATA. IS COVERED BY STRONG
SECURITY PROTECTIONS GENETIC
DATA CLEARLY WARRANT SUCH
PROTECTION PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE PLETHORA OF DATA
BREACHES IN RECENT YEARS
INCLUDING A JET MATCH IN JULY
OF LAST YEAR. THE STATE ALSO
REVEALED INFORMATION ABOUT
BLOOD RELATIVES WHO MAY NOT
EVEN BE AWARE THAT THE CONSUMER
SURE THE GENOME WITH THE DOCTOR
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING
COMPANY. WHICH MAKES A
PARTICULAR DESERVING OF
PROTECTION FROM HACKERS. ASIDE
FROM THE INHERENT PRIVACY
INTEREST IN KEEPING THIS
INFORMATION SECURE. IF THE
STATE TO BECOME PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE DUE TO DATA BREACH
INFORMATION ABOUT POTENTIAL
HEALTH ISSUES COULD POTENTIALLY
BE ACCESS BY OTHERS AND USE
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST CONSUMERS.
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MERCHANT NEXT WE HAVE
SELENA TAKKAR WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER
CAR ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES
THANK YOU MISTER. BIRTH TO BE
AN ATTACKER WITH THE CONSUMER
JOURNEY THE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT TO
FIVE. BY TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION PRODUCES NEW AND
EXCITING TOOLS FOR CONSUMERS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES NEW
OPPORTUNITIES ON NINETEEN.
CONSUMERS CARE ABOUT THE CAR
AND THAT THE HARM THAT OCCURS
WHEN A PERSONAL DATA BREACH
YOUR STOLEN. IDENTITY THEFT
FINANCIAL CRIME EVEN FEAR FOR
THEIR OWN PHYSICAL SAFETY ARE
TOP CONCERNS THEIR DATA IT'S NO
LONGER SPEAKS. TO HARM ISRAEL.
AND TO DEDICATE IT CANNOT BE
ALTERED OR CHANGED. ONE PICK
OUR- EIGHT. RIGHT THANK OUT
THAT. I THINK JULY IS VERY OUT
ON EIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUT LET'S GO TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS SOB MR OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
NEW ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS. ZERO. AND TO
REPEAT AGAIN ASSEMBLY SIGNALED
THAT THEY MAY WISH TO SPEAK
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO THANK YOU.
WELL NOW HERE FROM LINE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AM BLACKWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE ANCESTRY AND
TWENTY THREE MEET IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WE GREAT GENETIC DATA
IN COMBINATION WITH THE
PERSON'S NAME SHOULD BE SUBJECT
TO STATE DATA BREACH
NOTIFICATION MARK THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. SURE NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION TO BELIEVE WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES OUT TO SPEAK
ON. THE TOPIC OF THE FIRST
SCHWAB MOHAMMED WOULD
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
ARE YOU ON THE LINE MISTER
MOHAMMED. CUNNINGHAM PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAKES WHAT
MUHAMMAD CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS AMEND
IT AND WE DO SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORED EFFORTS
TO REFINE THE BILL TO PROVIDE A
MORE ACCURATE DEFINITION OF
GENETIC DATA AND THE AUTHORS
ONGOING WORK WITH US ON THIS
BILL AB TWO EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY AYE GENETIC DATA TO
BREACH NOTIFICATION PROVISIONS
OF EXISTING LAW HOWEVER AS
DRAFTED A POTENTIALLY SCOPES IN
A LOT OF OTHER INFORMATION
DERIVED FROM A BIOLOGICAL
SAMPLE INCLUDING HEALTH DATA
AND BIOMETRIC DATA INTO THE
DEFINITION OF GENETIC DATA.
THIS IS AN ISSUE BECAUSE HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL DATA ARE
SEPARATELY DEFINED IN THE CODE
SECTION THUS CREATING A
DEFINITION FOR A NEW TERM THAT
INCLUDES DATABASE SEPARATELY
DEFINED IN THE LAW WOULD CAUSE
CONFUSION WITH REGARDS
INTERPRETATION ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE AND ALSO HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CREATE CONFLICTS
AND STATUTE AGAIN WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
TO WORK WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR BUT FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED CREATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THE NEXT
SPEAKERS. CAMERON DIMITRIOU.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. MISTER
DIMITRIOU. MISTER OP READER CAN
YOU CHECK TO SEE IF I MISTER
CAMERON DIMITRY IS ON THE LINE
HE'S WITH TECHNET. MISTER CHAIR
I AM SHOWING THAT HE IS
CONNECTED TO THE CALL. SORRY
YOU YOU MAY- ON MUTE YOUR PHONE
LINE TO SPEAK NOW. MR DIMITRI.
AND AGAIN MISTER CHAIR I CAN
CONFIRM THEIR LINE IS CONNECTED
TO THE CALL IT DOES NOT APPEAR
THAT THEY ARE PRESENT. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. WE WILL NOW GO TO.
MOMENT PLACE. SURE WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THEY'LL
BE WITH US MOMENTARILY. THANK
YOU.
CHRIS ROCK MADE WHICH YOU
PLEASE SAID DOUBLE CHECK POINT.
YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN I DO
APOLOGIZE WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE SOME
HAD TO. INVESTIGATE THIS
FURTHER.
CAN WE COME BACK TO
THE CALLER MISTER ROBERTS. YES
MISTER GERALD NOTIFY YOU AS
SOON AS THE- WHATEVER ISSUE IS
RESOLVED SURE LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- WHICH I
DON'T SEE ANY SO LET'S GO BACK
TO A PHONE LINE. ONE MORE TIME
ONE LAST TIME. THANK YOU MR WE
ARE GOING TO ATTEMPT TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUE. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ONCE AGAIN WISH TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN PLACE.
I BELIEVE WE'VEWE'VE WAITED WE
MAY HAVE MISTER CAMEROON JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE FIND SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME
I APOLOGIZE FOR WHAT HAS BEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PERFECT MY
NAME IS CAME TO MEET HIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ACT THAT
TECHNET RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES AB
EIGHT TO FIVE BUT APPRECIATES
THE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
DOCTORS OFFICE TO ENSURE AN
ACCURATE DEFINITION OF GENETIC
DATA WE BELIEVE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
OUR CONCERN BUT WE ARE STILL
SEEKING ADDITIONAL CLARITY THE
CURRENT DEFINITION COULD SCOPE
AND HEALTH AND BIOMETRIC DATA.
AND SLASH WEBPAGES MENTIONED.
BY CREATING THAT DEFINITION.
FOR A NEW TERM CLOSE TO DATA IS
SEPARATE DEFINED IN THE LOCK.
IT WOULD CAUSE CONFUSION WITH
REGARDS INTERPRETATION FORSMAN
AND COMPLIANCE. ADDITIONALLY WE
ALSO REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL SCOPING AN
APPROPRIATE. CONTACT TRACING
TESTING THAT THERE ARE SOME
KOBE TEST THAT ANALYZED RNA-
SIGNED WITH THE VIRUS AND VIRUS
IMMUNITY. AB EIGHTEEN FIVE
DEFINITION OF GENETIC DATA
INCLUDE THE RESULTS OF A TEST
RIDE FROM GENETIC MATERIAL. I
G. A. CULVER NINETEEN ANTIBODY
TEST THIS DEFINITION COULD
CREATE SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY
FOR BUSINESSES TO CONDUCT
CONTACT TRACING. LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR VETOED SB NINE EIGHTY.
SENATOR AMBER WITH CONSERVATIVE
AN OVERLY BROAD GENETIC DATA
DEFINITION THAT CAN BE PAYING
KOBE TESTING. MEDICINE THE
RECENT CAL OSHA EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS REQUIRES MOST
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES TO
PROVIDE COVER TESTING
EMPLOYEES. CONSEQUENTLY AB
EIGHT TO FIVE CAN CREATE
SIGNIFICANT STATUTORY DAMAGES
WITH NO PROOF OF ENTRY FOR
DISCLOSURE TEST RESULTS
DERIVED. FROM GENETIC
INFORMATION. YOU CAN PLEASE
TELL PEOPLE THE RESULT TO THEIR
COVER TAX WHICH THEY CAN AND
CAN'T DO. COMPANIES CAN BE SUED
FOR EACH OF THESE DISCLOSURES
WITH NO PROOF OF INJURY WITH
SIGNIFICANT STATUTORY DAMAGES
IF I COULD. ASK YOU TO REVEREND
IS REASONABLE. HAS TWENTY THREE
WE HAVE A OPPOSE POSITION THIS
BILL. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ADOPTED OFFICE CONCERNS THANK
YOU FOR COMING CONFEDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- MISTER
OPERATOR IS IT TRUE THAT THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL NO MORE
CALLS. COMING IN. ON THIS BILL.
A TEACHER THAT IS CORRECT THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE HAD SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. SO I NOTICED
THAT- WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS WHO HAVE JOINED US
AGAIN ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THIS
AUTHOR. ON THE BILL. CNN I.
THINK WE NEED A MOTION. YOU
DIDN'T OUT OF GREAT SO WE GOT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I LOST
TRACK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ANOTHER- MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS AB EIGHT
TO FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAO HI CHAO
AYE AYE KILEY KILEY I'VE OUR
QUE HAN ARE QUE HAND AYE
BENNETT. COREA COREA I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER IRWIN- WHEN
I LEE. WICKS YOU HAVE SIX VOTES
THE BILLS I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR- ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THAT BRINGS US
TO THE NEXT BILL I BELIEVE. IT
IS ITEM SIXTEEN WE'D HAVE PETRI
MISTER. PETER NORRIS AB ONE TEN
WELCOME WELCOME TO OUR
COMMUNITY. IS THAT A SIGNAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND BEFORE I BEGIN I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT AT THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
WOULD STRIKE AT THE COUNTY'S
COMPONENTS IN THE SPELL WHEN IT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON NOT THAT
AMENDMENT AND ON THE BILL MORE
BROADLY. AT MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB ONE TEN WHICH REQUIRES
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO CROSS
CHECK INCARCERATION RECORDS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION IN ORDER TO
PREVENT PAIN FRAUDULENT
BENEFITS. OVER THE PAST YEAR WE
ALONG WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE WATCHED WITH SHOCK AND
OUTRAGE THE MYRIAD WAYS IN
WHICH CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT HAS
FAILED TO CALIFORNIA THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ASKED WONDER
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND CAUSED
HEARTACHE FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS UNFORTUNATELY ONE
OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES
OF THE DEPARTMENT'S FAILINGS
CAME IN THE FOM OF THE
FRAUDULENT PAYMENT OF HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CLAIMS TO. INCARCERATED INMATES
A RECENT STATE AUDIT REPORT
NOTED THAT EDT LEFT ITSELF
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO YOU I
FRAUD ASSOCIATED WITH
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AT
WHICH IT ESTIMATES NOW TO HAVE
REACHED OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BY THE
DEPARTMENT LEFT ITSELF
VULNERABLE BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
HAVE A SYSTEM TO REGULARLY
CROSS MATCH YOU AYE CLAIMS WITH
INFORMATION. FROM CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AB ONE TEN ADDRESSES
THIS CRITICAL GAP AND WILL
ENSURE THAT EDT CROSS CHECKS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
AGAINST INCARCERATION DATA I
THIS IS A SIMPLE COMMONSENSE
STEPS TO PREVENT FRAUD AND-
WITH THAT I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE FOR TESTIMONY THE
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
FROM ORANGE COUNTY LESLIE YOUNG.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
LESLIE YOUNG ORANGE COUNTY
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
CHARGE OF MAJOR FRAUD ON BEHALF
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY TODD
SPITZER I STRONGLY URGE IN
IDAHO TO ON EIGHTY ONE TEN. IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SPENCER DIRECTED THE
MAJORITY OF OUR FRAUD UNITS
RESOURCES. BE USED TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE
FRAUDULENT APPLICATIONS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS BY
INMATES IN CALIFORNIA PRISONS.
OUR OFFICE UNCOVERED OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS IN FRAUDULENT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PAID TO
THE INMATES COCONSPIRATORS IN
ORANGE COUNTY ALONE. WE FILED
MULTIPLE FELONY CHARGES AGAINST
EIGHT INDIVIDUALS. IN YOUR TEAM
BUT DESPITE NUMEROUS BANKS
SEARCH WARRANTS AND OTHER
INVESTIGATIVE EFFORTS. TO
FRAUDULENTLY DIVERTED FUNDS HAD
VANISHED ALTHOUGH WE ANTICIPATE
OBTAINING RESTITUTION ORDERS ON
BEHALF OF THE NEEDY. THE
REALITY IS THAT MOST IF NOT ALL
OF THAT MONEY WILL NEVER BE
RETURNED TO TAXPAYERS. DURING
OUR EXTENSIVE INVESTIGATION WE
LEARNED THAT THESE EIGHT
SUSPECTS ARE THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG OF A RAMPANT STATEWIDE
FRAUDULENT UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
SCHEME INVOLVING STATE PRISONER
APPLICANT. HAD A MECHANISM BEEN
IN PLACE TO BLOCK THIS MONEY
FROM DISTRIBUTION TO INELIGIBLE
PRISON INMATES I'M TOLD
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN BENEFITS
WOULD HAVE BEEN SAFEGUARDED.
AND THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES DEVOTED
ELSEWHERE. AB ONE TEN IS A
COMMONSENSE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL IN MINIMIZING THE
LOSS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
FRAUD. UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
MUST BE AVAILABLE TO HELP OUT
OF WORK CALIFORNIANS. NOT TO
ENRICH INCARCERATED CRIMINALS
AND THEIR ASSOCIATES WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND STRONGLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON AB ONE TEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY LET'S GO TO
A PHONE LINE TO MR OPERATOR
WHICH PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR. SUPPORTERS. OF THIS BILL
AB ONE TEN. PLAY IDENTIFY YOUR
A US YOUR NAME AND WE'LL GET
PLEASE. THE FAMILY IN GERMAN ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S COULD
OPPOSITION UP DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SPEAKING.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALSO
LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE
FOR THOSE WHO LIKE TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION MR FRAZIER. AND NOW
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE. I WILL GO OVER TO LINE
FOURTEEN LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS BECCA KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE CAN
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO A COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE. YES GO
AHEAD MISS CARILLO GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL UP TO US I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ISSUES
RELATED TO EDT AND WE HAVE HAD
MANY CONVERSATIONS ON HOW WE
CAN RESOLVE THIS ISSUE
ESPECIALLY RELATED TO A BUDGET
TO FOR OVERSIGHT ON EDT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOW COME TO AN
AGREEMENT IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
WILL BE COLLABORATING DATA
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND EIGHTY D. THERE WAS A-
QUESTION OF THE LEGALITY OF IT.
AND WHILE THE DEPARTMENT IS NOW
CURRENTLY- PROCESSING THAT DATA
TOGETHER IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVEN'T CODIFIED IN LAW SO THAT
NO MATTER WHO IS AT THE TABLE
AT THE TIME WHO THE DIRECTOR IS
WHO WE ARE WHO'S IN OUR SEATS
WHOSE- RUNNING THE DEPARTMENT
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CONTINUES TO BE A PROCESS
VERSUS WHAT WE'VE SEEN HERE-
BECAUSE OF COVERT NINETEEN THE
LOSS OF ALL THOSE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS COULD HAVE
GONE TOWARDS EDUCATION THEY
COULD HAVE GONE TOWARDS
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY COULD HAVE
GONE TOWARD. ADDITIONAL RELIEF
FOR SO MANY HURTING OF
CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM- AT ASSIST DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES THAT SIMPLY DON'T
SPEAK TO EACH OTHER AND THAT
WHAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
DEFINITELY SHOWN US IS THAT WE
NEED TO CRITICALLY INVEST IN
BEAN TECHNOLOGICAL ASPECT OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS TO ONE ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE MORE UP TO DATE
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THAT EDT FACES AND
THAT IT'S WORKING WITH THAT-
AND ANTIQUATED SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T MEET THE CURRENT NEEDS-
AND IT'S CURRENTLY ON A VERY
FRAGILE FRAGILE LYING AND SO I
KNOW THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING TOWARDS-
IN THE FUTURE- BUT RIGHT NOW
WHAT WE CAN DO IS ENSURE THAT
AS MORE RELIEF COME TOWARDS.
TOWARDS CALIFORNIANS THAT
AGENCIES ARE SPEAKING TO EACH
OTHER TO AVOID ANY ADDITIONAL
FRAUD I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON YOUR BILL I THINK
IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ENSURING THAT WE ARE CREATING
PAUL. C. THAT I. MAKE THIS. NET
THAT CALIFORNIANS- REALLY
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE THINKING
ABOUT. EDT IS A IS A SAFETY NET
THAT SHOULD FUNCTION SHOULD
WORK. AND THE NOTION THAT THAT
THIS TYPE OF FRAUD OCCURRED
SIMPLY BECAUSE TO AGENCIES
DON'T COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER. AND DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AS WE TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN HELP PEOPLE. IS
ACTUALLY KIND OF MIND BOGGLING.
SO THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND CHAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND YOUR COMMITMENT
TO ADDRESSING. THE ISSUES THAT
EDT MORE BROADLY. LIKE YOU SAID
IT IT HAS BEEN MIND BOGGLING I
THINK WE'VE ALL FOUND OURSELVES
AS- AS RESIDENTS AS TAXPAYERS
AND IS LEGISLATORS. ARRANGED
FOR GOOD REASON AND- APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
THAT WE ADDRESS THOSE FEELINGS
AND THAT THIS. DOES NOT HAPPEN
AGAIN. MISTER BENNETT GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU- I WON'T
REPEAT ALL OF THE- THE- FOR
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WERE SAID
ABOUT THE POSITIVES OF THIS
BILL AT THIS POINT IN TIME. I
DO APPRECIATED IT BECAUSE IT
DOES MAKE SO MUCH COMMONSENSE
WE HAVE THIS INFORMATION I'D
JUST. AS THE AUTHOR- HAS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND JUST IF
YOU COULD EXPRESS THE YOUR
CONFIDENCE LEVEL AND COMMITMENT
TO MAKING SURE THAT HAS THIS
INFORMATION TO SHARE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS ARE OUT
THERE. TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
NOT SURE BEYOND WHERE IT'S
NECESSARY- AND SO I I'M SURE
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THAT I JUST
WANT TO- TRY TO GET THAT ON THE
RECORD THAT THAT DID TAKE. THE
CONCERNS- THAT OF PEOPLE THAT
THIS MAY BE THE OVERLY BROAD.
OR ONCE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SENSITIVE TO. YES WELL THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
YES ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT. AS WE ARE
SHARING DATA BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE SURE OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS FUNCTION THAT WE DO SO
IN A WAY THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
AND THAT PROTECTS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
MISSPOKEN PLEASE. M. I WANT TO
READ. THAT COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES. WHO
DISCUSSED THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING I THINK THAT
IT CANNOT BE. UNDER ESTIMATED
WHAT GOOD WE COULD HAVE DONE
WITH THIS MONEY THAT HAS BEEN
TAKEN AWAY FROM CALIFORNIANS
AND FROM THE TAXPAYERS AND WE
SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM
TO ENSURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN IN THIS SMALL CHANGES
THAT YOU'RE MAKING THAT WE WAS
IDENTIFIED AS ONE OF THE MAJOR
REASONS WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
FRAUDSTERS- IS A- HUGE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND I
THINK THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
KEENLY PAYING ATTENTION TO US
KEEPING THAT DATA SECURE AND
THAT IS OUR OBLIGATION ASK THE
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE THIS DATA
AND KEEP IT SECURE AT EVERY
TURN. THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SHARE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA STATE DEPARTMENTS
WERE NECESSARY BUT MR WHEN HAD
TWO BILLS TODAY FOCUSED ON
EXACTLY THAT MAKING SURE THAT
DATA IS SECURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT. BEYOND JUST
YOUR BILL WE NEED TO OWN AND-MAKE SURE WE CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARDS SELF I AM EXCITED TO
SUPPORT EACH DAY AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD AS A CO AUTHOR BOOK
THANK YOU FOR THAT SUPPORT AND-
YES. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I'LL ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TACKLING.
OF THIS ISSUE UP. AND ET DE
DEFINITELY HAS BEEN AND YOU
KNOW IN IN THE- LIMELIGHT. FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS SO. I
THINK IT WILL BE A PART OF THE
GROUP TO TACKLE THAT ISSUE SO
WITHOUT THE WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
AT YES I WILL JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED DOWN. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
AB ONE TAP ON THAT BEFORE YOU
CALL. YES TWO PEOPLE OF THAT
WHICH IS. CHURCHES COOPER JUST
BECAUSE- I GREAT THANK YOU OOPS.
RIGHT GOING ONCE GOING RIGHT
NOW SCOTT IT'S- WHEN THANK YOU
MISTER PLAY CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS AB ONE TEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. OUR HIGH CHAO I
KILEY KILEY AYE POWER QUE HAN.
FAR QUE HAN I'VE BEEN IT.
SENATE HI CORREA CORREA I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER IRWIN. LATE
WICKS YOU HAVE SIX VOTES OF THE
BILLS OUT THERE CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
LET'S NOW GO TO ITEM EIGHTEEN
AB FIFTY SIX- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS IS HERE WELCOME. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS WERE
JUST GONNA CONTINUE ON THIS
EDT- RIDE HERE I ADDRESSING
BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY BILL- HE
SIX BUT FIRST LET ME START BY
SAYING I'LL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOUR STAFF IS
DONE ON THIS BILL- ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE THE FIRST OF THE SECOND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I LET ME JUST
TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY DOES. IT'S A- REALLY A
CULMINATION OF A LOT OF THE
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE DONE THE
LETTERS THAT WE'VE WRITTEN- I
KNOW YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT SOME
OF THE- ISSUES- IN THE PREVIOUS
BILL SO I DON'T WANT TO.
BELABOR THAT POINT BUT THIS
BILL WILL. WILL REQUIRE EDT TO
SUBMIT A CORRECTIVE PLAN TO
STOP MAILING FULL SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS TO INDIVIDUALS
REQUIRE EDT TO PROVIDE IT.
IDENTITY THEFT MONITORING
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS. IT
WILL ALSO REQUIRE EDT TO REPORT
ON ITS WEBSITE EVERY SIX MONTHS
INFORMATION ON THE AMOUNT OF
OVERPAYMENTS REPAID BENEFITS.
IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE-
PERFORMANCE OF A RISK
ASSESSMENT OF ITS DEFERRED
WORKLOADS CREATE A PLAN THAT
PRIORITIZES. ITS DEFERRED
WORKLOADS AND HIRE AND TRAIN
STAFF NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT
THAT PLAN THERE'S-
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE- DIFFERENT
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT THAT
THIS WOULD REQUIRE EDT. TO
FULFILL AS WELL. WHAT THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS- SO
AT THIS TIME LET'S. TURN TO OUR
PHONE LINES- MR ROBERT- PLEASE.
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR PEOPLE
CALLING. TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HAMLEYS IN GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER SPEAKER.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
DON'T BELIEVE YOU HAVE-
OPPOSITION- EITHER SO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE DROP ME TO WHICH
ALSO OPEN UP THE LINE. FOR
OPPOSITION ANY CALLERS SO
WHATSOEVER TO. OPPOSES BILL AND
NOW. AND NOW AT THIS TIME IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THE N. ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK
YOU MUCH- LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY QUESTIONS
COMMONS. MISS KOREA GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL-
TO THE TABLE I THINK WE HAVE
ALL BEEN IN VARIOUS DIFFERENT
HEARINGS REGARDING THE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT- ISSUES RELATED TO
EDT. ANDI ALSO JUST WANT TO
SAY LIKE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS THAT
ARE TRYING TO DO THE BEST THEY
CAN AMID COLD IT TO PROCESS EDT
CLAIMS I THINK ALL OF OUR STAFF
ESPECIALLY OUR STAFF IN THE
DISTRICT HAS BECOME ADDITIONAL
EXTENDED STAFF TO EDT AS WE TRY
TO PROCESS CLAIMS AND HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE- INCREDIBLY
HURTING RIGHT NOW- THE AUDIT
REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN
RELEASED- RECENTLY AS WELL AS
THE AUDIT REPORTS THAT HAVE
BEEN RELEASED IN THE PAST. HAVE
REALLY SHOWN US THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY WITH EDT IN
TERMS OF HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
WE ARE CREATING AN AGENCY IN A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR PEOPLE AS
A SAFETY NET- I HAVE A WAS
TALKING TO SOME FOLKS WHO SAID
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU NEED TO
REPAIR YOUR ROOF. YOU DON'T
REPAIR YOUR ROOF WHEN IT'S
RAINING. HI TO REPAIR YOUR ROOF
WHEN. IT'S A SUNNY DAY OUT AND
YOU SHOULD TRY TO FIND. PLACES
THAT THAT NEEDREPAIR BUT WHILE
IT'S RAINING AND YOUR LIVING
ROOM IS. LEAKING WATER YOU TRY
TO PATCH THINGS UP SO THAT AT
LEAST YOU TRY TO. PROTECT WHAT
YOU CURRENTLY HAVE AND WE FIND
OURSELVES IN A SITUATION WHERE.
WE KNOW THAT THE SYSTEMS WITHIN
EIGHTY D. ARTWORK. WE KNOW THAT
THE SYSTEMS NEED TO BE UPDATED
WE KNOW THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE
ANTIQUATED. IN THE MEANTIME
WELL WE GET TO A BETTER PLACE.
AFTER COBIT AND COVERT RECOVERY
EFFORTS. WE CAN FIND THAT
BALANCE AND ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
THE ENTIRE PROCESS AND SEEM
LIKE WHAT WORKS WHAT DOESN'T
HOW DO WE IMPROVE IT. WE SHOULD
NOT BE IN THE SITUATION AGAIN
WE SHOULD HEED. THE ADVICE OF
THE AUDIT AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CREATING. THE MECHANISMS
THAT WILL CREATE A RESPONSIBLE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ULTIMATELY. TRY
TO FIX THE SAFETY NET THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT. SO I APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. THANK YOU NINTH PRECIADO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND THE
SUB COMMITTEE AS WELL AS WE
HELD SOME OF THOSE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS AND- AND LIKE YOU SAID
THE AUDIT ACTUALLY- CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT. DURING THE
LAST RAINSTORM THEY DID IT THEY
JUST PASSED IT BUT THEY DIDN'T
FIX IT. AND SO THIS AUDIT IN
THIS BILL NOW WILL PUT THE
STRENGTH OF THAT ONLY THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT PUT IT IN
STATUTES SO THAT WE ENSURE THAT
HE- DOES DO THAT SO THAT WE ARE
FIXING THAT ROOF. OKAY AND CRAP
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS FOR THIS
BILL I THINK- IT'S INCREDIBLE
WE NEED A BILL TO TELL THEM.
SOME OF THESE THINGS LIKE DOWN
SEND OUT PEOPLE'S ALSO
STREAMING. NUMBERS IN THE MAIL
BUT WE ARE WHERE WE ARE SO I
APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT- AND
I THINK THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
EXAMPLE OF YOU AS CHAIR OF. THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE USING THE POWER ARE
CREDIBLE AUDITOR'S OFFICE TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW CAN WE ADDRESS
THIS WHAT ARE THE STEPS WE
SHOULD TAKE AND THEN TAKING
ACTION I. SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR
THAT I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FIRST UP ALTHOUGH I
WOULD ECHO. MY COLLEAGUE THAT
WHEN WE MAKE IT THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL
BE SOON. THAT WE DO THE WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE SET UP TO
SUCCEED FOR CALIFORNIANS. ONE
OF OUR PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITIES
IS TO TAKE CARE OF CALIFORNIANS
WHEN THEY NEED US MOST AND WE
HAVE FAILED THEM THIS LAST
YEAR. WHEN IT CAME TO GETTING
THE UNEMPLOYMENT THEY HAD PAID
INTO. THEIR MONEY THAT THEY
DESERVED AND WE WERE NOT GIVING
IT TO THEM AND WE KNOW PEOPLE
LAS ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
BECAUSE OF IT. AND WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT
I THINK THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
OVERSTAFFED AND I WOULD HAVE TO
BE. ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
ABSOLUTELY. WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
YOU. AND IF THERE ARE. NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT OOPS. NO
ADDITIONAL MORE. K. GOT IT. NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC- AND I KNOW THAT- YOU BE
WORKING WITH SEVERAL. MEMBERS
ON THIS VERY ISSUE AND- SO-
GOING FORWARD I ASKED. T. YOU
KNOW THAT DO YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM. AND TRY TO
REALLY. PLUG ALL THE HOLES ON
THE NEW PERSON. SO WITH THAT-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
THINK. I'M ONLY ASKED FOR AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
TIME. VERY GOOD. MR SECRETARY A
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A FIFTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. CHAP HI
CHECK OUT I KILEY. KILEY AYE
PARA QUE HAN. OUR QUE HAN AYE
BENNETT. BENNETT I CARILLO.
WELL I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I. GABRIEL GALLAGHER- WHEN LATE
WICKS YOU HAVE SIX VOTES OUT OF
THE BILL IS OUT CAN LEAD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH RIGHT
I THINK- YES SHE YES YOU WILL.
I CAN PRESENT MY BILL YEAH SURE
THE- CAN YOU. WELL IT'S JUST
THE TEMPERATURE. YEAH SO. SO
I'VE UNDER THAT- ASSEMBLY WEEKS
PRESENT IT AT A DIFFERENT
COMEDIAN- SO I THINK SHE'S THE
ONLY. OTHER AUTHOR- AT THIS
TIME I AM GOING TO TAKE THE
PRIVILEGE OF PRESENTING- MY
BILLS AND ALL LIKE TO GET HAND
OVER THE GAVEL TO THE VICE
CHAIR KILEY LET ME GET MY STUFF-
YEAH ARE YOU HOW THE FIRST. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE YOU KNOW WITH THIS
IS. SO YOU GOT TOGETHER THE
NEED TO. THIS PART OF THE JOB
YOU KNOW I DO INTEND WHICH IS
PRESENTLY. OKAY AS WE HAVEN'T.
WE'LL NOW HEAR A AB THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN WOULD SET
FOR OF CRITERIA FOR THE
PROCUREMENT OF HIGH RISK
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS BY
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES IN ORDER TO
MINIMIZE THE RISK OF ADVERSE
AND DISCRIMINATORY IMPACTS
RESULTING FROM THEIR DESIGN.
AND APPLICATION. THE USE OF
AUGUR THEM DRIVEN AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEMS OR SIMPLY ADS
CAN ASSIST WITH CREDIT
DECISIONS EMPLOYMENT SCREENING
INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY MARKETING
AND DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT
SERVICES JUST TO NAME A FEW. IN
FACT WITHIN THE POTENTIAL TO
IMPROVE OPERATIONS AND MEET THE
NEEDS OF CITIZENS IN NEW WAYS
IS THE REASON WHY GOVERNMENTS
ARE INCREASINGLY SEEKING TO
CAPTURE THE OPPORTUNITIES
OFFERED BY THE SYSTEMS. HOWEVER
POORLY DESIGNED A DS'S CAN ALSO
CREATE UNFAIR BIASED AND
INACCURATE RESULTS CAUSING
DISPROPORTIONATE HARM TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WHILE ALSO UNDERMINING
TRUST IN PUBLIC SECTOR.
THEREFORE WHEN IT COMES TO
ACQUISITION OF THE SYSTEMS BY
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WE MUST
EXAMINE THE STATE'S PROCUREMENT
POLICIES. AS INDICATED BY
RECENT STUDIES GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES NEED TO CONSIDER
IMPORTANT POLICY CHOICES
INHERENT IN MACHINE LEARNING.
INSTEAD OF TREATING PURCHASES
AS NORMAL GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING DECISIONS WHICH
SOLELY FOCUS ON PRICE FAIRNESS
IN THE BIDDING PROCESS
INNOVATION AND COMPETITION. AS
OPPOSED TO GOALS VALUES RISK
AND UNCERTAINTY ON FUTURE
AGENCY DISCRETION. OTHERWISE
GOVERNMENTS COULD FAIL IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MEET PUBLIC
EXPECTATIONS OF OVERSIGHT OF
AGREEMENT TAKE. DECISION MAKING
AND MAY INNER CAN EMERGE ONLY
CREATE NEW RISKS OR HARMS. LET
ME SHARE SOME EXAMPLES WHERE
PUBLIC SECTOR OUGHT I GREW THEM
SYSTEMS HEALTH CAUSE HARM TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IN
MICHIGAN AND UNEMPLOYMENT AUGUR
THEM WRONGFULLY ACCUSED FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE OF FRAUD.
FORCING MANY OF THEM TO PAY
HEAVY FINES DECLARE BANKRUPTCY
OR HAVE THEIR HOMES FORECLOSED
UPON. IN ARKANSAS MEDICAID
RECIPIENTS LOST ACCESS TO HOME
CARE NURSING VISITS AND MEDICAL
TREATMENTS BECAUSE OF ERRORS
IN. AN IN AN INADEQUACY IN
ACCURACIES IN AN ALGORITHM. IN
DETROIT A MARKET ANALYSIS ORDER
THEM USED TO DIRECT PUBLIC
HOUSING SUBSIDIES AND TAX
BREAKS IN HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
REDIRECTED CRITICAL FUNDING
AWAY FROM DETROIT'S POOREST AND
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS. ADDITIONALLY THE
ACCELERATED INTEREST OF
INCORPORATING ADS TECHNOLOGY
ESPECIALLY AS A MEANS TO
ADDRESSED AND RECOVER FROM THE
CULVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
PROVIDES A NUMBER OF COMPELLING
SITUATIONS WHERE IT IS LIKELY
TO BE USE. FOR EXAMPLE
ALLOCATION OF VACCINES. SO IT
IS IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
EXPLAIN IT ABILITY OF THE
SYSTEMS. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE A PROSPECTIVE
CONTRACTOR. TO SUBMIT AN
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEM
IMPACT ASSESSMENT OR SIMPLY A.
I. A. TO EVALUATE THE PRIVACY
AND SECURITY RISKS TO PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND RISKS THAT MAY
RESULT IN AN ACT OF INADEQUATE
DOUBT. AND ALSO UNFAIR BIASED
OR DISCRIMINATORY DECISION
IMPACTING INDIVIDUALS. IT WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THE STATE AGENCY
TO PRODUCE AN ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT WHICH INCLUDES A
DETAILED MITIGATION PLAN FOR
IDENTIFYING AND MINIMIZING THE
POTENTIAL FOR ANY A DISPARATE
UP IMPACTS AND THE CD T. WHICH
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
WOULD MAKE BOTH THE ASSESSMENT.
AND THE REPORT AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC ONLINE THAT WAS NOTED BY
THE WORLD ECONOMIC FORUM
GOVERNMENTS DO NOT HAVE THE
LATITUDE OF USING. INSCRUTABLE
BLACK BOX ALGORITHMS THAT
INCREASINGLY CHARACTERIZED AGRI
THEM'S DEPLOYED IN THE
MARKETPLACE. GOVERNMENT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THE SYSTEMS DID NOT CREATE NEW
HARMS ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY POSE
A SIGNIFICANT RISK THE LEGAL
RIGHTS. HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF INDIVIDUALS OR OTHERWISE
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO RESULT
IN. INACCURATE UNFAIR BIASED OR
DISCRIMINATORY DECISIONS
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU I OUR FIRST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT IS DOCTOR SERRA ARE
JORDAN- WITH THE FUTURE OF
PRIVACY FORUM. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES I CAN YES THANK YOU. RIGHT
I'M NOT A THIRD PARTY FROM THE
FUTURE PRIVATELY FORUMS AT THE
END OF THE NONPROFIT DEDICATED
TO OUR MISSION TO ADVANCE
PRINCIPLE DATA PRACTICES IN
SUPPORT OF EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE UP LOADED
WITH THE MOST WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TO THE PORTAL BUT I WILL
BRIEFLY AT. THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY THIRTEEN
ARE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT ON
THE PREVIOUS FIRST AT FIRST WE
COMMEND THE FATHERS FOR
CRAFTING AN AMENDED DEFINITION
OF AUTOMATED DECISION MAKING
THAT ACCOUNT FOR THE WIDE RANGE
OF TECHNICAL COMPLEXITY AN
AUTOMATED. SECOND THE
GOVERNMENT CONTACT STAGE IS THE
APPROPRIATE STAGE FOR THE
INTRODUCTION OF ALGORITHMIC
IMPACT ASSESSMENT A. I. A.'S.
WELL HI RICK APPLICATIONS OF
AUTOMATED DECISION MAKING. THIS
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. TO
EVALUATE TECHNOLOGY BEFORE IT
IS IMPLEMENTED USING
TRANSPARENT AND ACTIONABLE
ASSESSMENT CRITERIA. AT PF IS
AVAILABLE AND DO THE AFFECT TO
BE A REPORTS OF FOR FURTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AT ARE A SECOND WITH THIS IS-
VINCENT LAY WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
VINCENT. THE MONEY TO DO WHAT
MY JOB IS TO ENSURE THAT
TECHNOLOGY WORKS TO CLOSE THE
RACIAL WEALTH GAP AND BUILD
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. THE USE
OF A. I. IN GOVERNMENT IS
CLEARLY ACCELERATING. YEAH ONLY
30% OF AMERICANS ARE CONFIDENT
THE GOVERNMENT IT'S UP TO THE
TASK OF MANAGING A- THEY'RE
PICKING UP ON SOMETHING
MENTIONED HERE TODAY. BUT THE
DISTINCT LACK OF OVERSIGHT AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN THE
GOVERNMENT. ESPECIALLY OVER THE
SYSTEMS. IF HE DOESN'T ACT. YOU
CAN TAKE WHAT HAPPENED AT
MICHIGAN. AT THE CHAIR STATED
OVER FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WRONGLY ACCUSED OF UNEMPLOYMENT
FRAUD- BY SYSTEMATIC COST
MICHIGAN FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO PURCHASE. WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER. CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT. THE HEAD OF THE AGENCY
WAS FIRED MILLION TO RETURN TO
THE FACT THAT. IT WAS NO PROPER
PROCESS TO APPEAL THOSE
DECISIONS AND DO IT ALL
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THIS THE
AGENCY IN CHARGE OF
ADMINISTERING THE ALGORITHM. AT
LITTLE OR NO IDEA OF HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS AND WHAT EXACTLY
WENT WRONG. IMPACT ASSESSMENT
WOULD HELP PREVENT THIS
OUTCOME. IT WOULD HELP THOSE IN
CHARGE UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
MILLION DOLLARS SYSTEM WORKED.
I WOULD HAVE TOLD THE AGENCY
WHETHER THE DEVELOPER HAD DONE
ANY TESTS RENDON ACTRESS YOU ON
THIS. I WOULD TOLD CUSTOMERS
IMPACTED HOW THEY COULD APPEAL
THOSE DECISIONS. THEY SHOWS WHY
WE NEED AB THIRTEEN AND
ALGORITHMIC ACCOUNTABILITY. I
WON AND I NOTING THAT. AB
THIRTY IS VERY MUCH LIKE TENTS
READING LIGHT TOUCH REGULATION
OF ADS THAT ONLY APPLIES TO THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT
PROCUREMENT. AND INSTANCES
WHERE RISK TO CALIFORNIANS IS
HIGH. ENOUGH THAT DEVELOPERS
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW HOW THEIR
SYSTEM WORKS IT THINK THROUGH.
WHETHER THEY'RE A I CAN HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES HOW TO
MINIMIZE THOSE RISKS AND A
DOCUMENT THAT PROCESS. SIMPLY
PUT. THE THING THAT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING ANYWAYS. AND FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK ME ABOUT. THANK YOU. OF THE
COULD PLEASE OPEN PHONE LINE
FOR- MEMBER OF THE- WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY I SUPPORT. ABSOLUTELY
IN LADEN JOHN ON THE PHONE LINE
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME IT LOOKS
LIKE WE'VE OF THREE IN OUR
QUEUE. HOW WILL FIRST GO TO
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
THIS IS TRACY ROSENBERG CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND PRIVACY.
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE NINETY NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ADVOCATE AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
HANNAH HOW I WOULD TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION- AND THAT IS CHAU
MUHAMMAD WITH CALCHAMBER. THANK
YOU ARE NOT SURE MEMBERS MANAGE
WHAT MUHAMMAD THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IS DRAFTED I AB THIRTEEN ALLOWS
LOCAL AGENCIES TO REQUEST
DETAILED IMPACT ASSESSMENTS
FROM BUSINESS ANOTHER
PREREQUISITE TO APPLYING FOR
CERTAIN CONTRACTS. IT IMPACT
ASSESSMENTS REALLY AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEMS OR ADAS BUT IN
ITS CURRENT FORM AB THIRTEEN
THERE'S BEEN OVER BROADENS
DEFINITIONS AND APPLICATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE THE DEFINITION OF
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEM OR
ATS IS DEFINED AS ANY
COMPUTATIONAL PROCESS THAT
ISSUES THE SCORE CLASSIFICATION
RECOMMENDATION RATHER SIMPLE
FIND OUT BUT THAT IS USED TO
SUPPORT HUMAN DECISION MAKING
AND MATERIAL IMPACTS PERSONS.
THE TECHNICIAN WAS BROAD ENOUGH
TO INCLUDE VIRTUALLY ALL FORMS
OF COMPUTING EVEN SIMPLE
PROGRAMS THAT THAT FOLKS USE
EVERY DAY SIMILARLY THE
DEFINITION OF HIGH RISK
APPLICATION IS NOT ACTUALLY
COMBINED HIGH RISK APPLICATION
BUT INCLUDES ALMOST ANY USED TO
THE IDEA THANK TENSELY RESULT
IN INACCURATE UNFAIR BIASED OR
DISCRIMINATORY DISCRIMINATORY
DECISIONS. IMPACTING PERSONS
BUT IT CAN BE SAID THAT EVERY
COMPUTATIONAL SYSTEM IN THE
pRESULT IN AN ACCURACY THAT'S
MAKING DOESN'T OVER BROAD
STANDARD TO APPLY THE
DEFINITION OF HIGH RISK
APPLICATION ALSO INCLUDES AN
EIGHTY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF A-
QUOTE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. OF
INDIVIDUALS BUT AGAIN DOES NOT
DEFINE WHAT SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
IS NOT ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
IS OVERBROAD DEFINITION STRIKE
CONCERN FOR US IS AB THIRTEEN
DOES NOT PROVIDE EXPLICIT
PROTECTIONS FOR PROTECT
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION- WHEN
ELECTORAL PROPERTY MANY
BUSINESSES ARE CONCERNED A
LOCAL AGENCY COULD REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO REAL. PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION PROCESSES AND
TECHNOLOGIES AS A PREREQUISITE
FOR APPLYING FOR A CONTRACT
WITH THE AGENCY NOT ONLY IS
THIS A CONCERN FOR BUSINESSES
WHO ARE NATURALLY PROTECTIVE OF
SUCH INFORMATION BUT THERE'S
ALSO CONCERN THAT. OFFICE DATA
IN ONE PLACE MAY NOT ADEQUATELY
PROTECT SUCH INFORMATION FROM
BAD ACTORS FINALLY THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB THIRTEEN
ALLOW AGENCIES TO REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO CONDUCT. IMPACT
ASSESSMENT AS PREREQUISITES
NAME BADGE AND THESE ADDITIONAL
PROCESSES REQUIRED GET. CITING
THE POTENTIAL TO DRIVE UP THE
COST OF THAT PER CONTRACT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT CANNOT AFFORD
TO OR OTHERWISE DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO JUMP THROUGH THE
HURDLES IN ADVANCE OF A PLANNED
FOR CONTRACT WILL BE LEFT
UNABLE TO COMPETE FOR THE SAME.
ACCORDINGLY WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK ON THIS AND WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN IS DRAFTED WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU-
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. ABSOLUTELY JOHN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. JENNIFER
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. DOES LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN IN OUR QUEUE. WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS NAMELY
THE DRONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
AND ALSO THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES INTERFAX
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTEEN NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURKE THAT
NEED MORE WHILE I'M BEHALF AND
THE ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. ACTUALLY NUMBER EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER FROM THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO
LINE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
YOU HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KIMBERLY CHAIR BEHALF OF TACK
THAT I WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB. THIRTEEN NOW GO TO LINE
NINETY ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JOINT
BETTENCOURT REPRESENTING THE
SECURITIES INDUSTRY AND
FINANCIAL MARKETS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. NEXT WILL BE
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T OFTEN ON BEHALF
OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. I'M NOT
GONNA LIE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON NOT
ONLINE ON BEHALF OF TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THIRTY ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
ASSEMBLY WOMAN TARA OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER ASHER. I
AM SO I JUST LOOKED AT. I
RESHAPE WE'RE DOING HERE MISTER
CHAIR AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THESE DECISIONS SYSTEMS
ARE. AND HURRIEDLY AND HARLEY
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
PROBLEMATIC- WHEN IT COMES TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HISTORICALLY
HAVE SUFFERED. AB AND WE NEED
TO WORK TO CORRECT THAT
ESPECIALLY IN THE WORK WE DO AS
A STATE. SO I THINK THIS BILL
IS REALLY IMPORTANT I DO
HOWEVER SHARE THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION ABOUT THE
BREADTH OF THIS BILL- YOU KNOW
HIGH RISK APPLICATION SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
LIMITED UNTIL YOU READ THE
DEFINITION INCLUDES EVERYTHING
THAT AFFECTS THE LEGAL RIGHTS.
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. HAVE A
NATURAL PERSON WHICH I WOULD
ARGUE IS EVERYTHING WE DO IS A
STATE- I MEAN IF WE'RE NOT
DOING SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS
NATURAL PEOPLE THEN I DON'T
NOTICE WE DO EVERY DAY SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT THE HIGHER RISK
APPLICATION DEFINITION LIMITS
IT AND SO THEN I LOOK TO THE
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEM AND
IT DOES SEEM INCREDIBLY BROAD
IN MY CONVERSATIONS WITH.
COMMITTEE IT APPEARED AT THAT
THE ATTEMPT TO NARROW IT WAS
DONE THROUGH THIS- MODIFIER OF
OR OTHER SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT
WHICH NOT BEING A TAX EXPERT
TECH EXPERT AND TO BE HONEST AT
THIS MOMENT I MISSING OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE JAY OBERNOLTE
WHO I KNOW WOULD HAVE LOTS OF
THOUGHTS ON THIS BILL- BUT- YOU
KNOW. I READ THAT TO BE A
FOURTH OPTION SO COULD BE A
SCORE CLASS CATION RECOGNITION
OR OTHER SIMPLE FIND OUT PUT.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO MODIFY THE LIST
SO I THINK THERE ARE WAYS TO
CHANGES TO NARROW IT SO IT
ISN'T EVERY SINGLE COMPUTER
APPLICATION THAT WE USE IS A
STATE BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT. I MEAN CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG I DON'T THINK THAT IS
YOUR INTENT NOR DO I THINK
THAT'S NECESSARY I DO THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO GET A VERY
SPECIFIC PROBLEM HERE. AND THE
MORE WE CAN NARROW IT THE
BETTER IT WILL BE SO CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT AND- YOU KNOW LET
ME KNOW IF YOU'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THAT DEFINITION IN
HOPES OF NARROWING IT. THANK
YOU FOR VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
QUESTION MAYBE BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND. OF THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
AND WHEN WE INTRODUCED IT THE
OPPOSITION REYES VERY SIMILAR
CONCERNS OR IF NOT IDENTICL
CONCERNS. ALTHOUGH I THINK THE
MAIN MAIN. CONCERN WAS THAT THE
PRESS OF THE TO THE
DEFINITIONS. AND SO WE REACHED
OUT TO THE OPPOSITION AND TRY
TO KIND OF. FIND OUT OF THE
BEST PRACTICES AND YOU KNOW.
WHATEVER INPUT THEY MIGHT HOUSE
SO THAT WE COULD KINDA USED TO
NARROW THE- SCOPE OF THE BILL.
AFTER WAITING A YEAR OR SO- AND
RECEIVING NO INPUT FROM THEM.
WE TOOK IT UPON US OURSELVES
TO. START TO AYE WE STARTED
NARAL THE BILL SUBSTANTIALLY.
SO CURRENTLY- THE BILL ONLY
PERTAINS TO ATS IS. THAT AS YOU
POINTED OUT- APPLY TO HIGH RISK
APPLICATIONS- WHICH ARE FURTHER
DEFINED IN THE BILL ITSELF. AS
MEETING ONE OF THE THREE
CRITERIA AND I COULD SPELL. IT
ALL OUT IF YOU WANT. BUT THAT'S
ONE THING THAT WE HAVE DONE IN
ADDITION. THE LANGUAGE NOW
PROVIDES FOR- THE C. T. WHICH
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
TO ALSO. FURTHER PRESCRIBED
GUIDELINES AND TELL YOU KNOW
TOLD THE WHOLE WORLD. WHAT
OTHER APPLICATIONS ARE SUBJECT.
TO THIS THIS LAW. SO IT IS NT
REALLY. YOU KNOW TO OVERRIDE IT
IN THAT REGARD. AND I THINK THE
TERM HIGH RISK IS YOU KNOW
DEFINE. IN VERY MINUTE TERMS-
SO THERE'S NO CONFUSION. BUT I
THINK IF THE CONCERN IS WHETHER
OR NOT. THE DEFINITION WORKED
OUT YOU KNOW SWEEP UP THINGS
LIKE COMPUTERS OR OR OR-
CALCULATORS AND SPREADSHEETS. I
THINK WHAT WE CAN DO AND WHAT
WE WILL DO GOING FORWARD IS TO
PROBABLY. ALL AMENDED THE BILL
TO EXPLICITLY EXT EXCLUDE THOSE
SELL ITEMS FROM FROM THE BILL.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT INTENT RIGHT
YOU'RE RIGHT. WE'RE NOT WE
DON'T INTEND TO GO TO INCLUDE
EVERY SINGLE- CALCULATOR OUT
THERE I MEAN THAT MAKES NO
SENSE. AND I THINK THE WORK
THAT THE BUZZWORD THEIR DATE
THAT THE KEY WORD THERE IS A
MATERIAL I THINK. SO
CALCULATORS DO NOT MATERIALLY
AFFECT YOU KNOW HUMANIZE IT. SO
BUT I THINK IN ORDER TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
I THINK WILL WILLING TO DO THAT
AND I THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
YOURSELF. AND THE LANGUAGE THAT
WE ARE USING. IS TAKEN ACTUALLY
FROM A VERY SO. LET'S SAY THE
FOR THE FOR- THERE WAS A LOT OF
FEDERAL LEGISLATION- THAT- WE
KIND OF BORROWED SOME LANGUAGE
FROM. SO WE WILL BE HAPPY TO DO
THAT- JUST TO KIND OF CLEAR THE
AIR AND WE DON'T. INTEND TO
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE THOSE. BUT
UP I THINK THE ARE THE SPONSOR
HAS- YOU KNOW HAS SOME INSIGHTS
AND PERHAPS MORE EXPERTISE. IF
I COULD- TURN TO THE SPONSOR
FOR ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON
MISTER CHAIR- MR REALLY
QUICKLY- FROM. THREE NINE YES
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU- YES
COULD NOT. I SAVE YOU KNOW THE
SIMILAR. PRESIDENT AND BOTH THE
EUROPEAN UNION AD CANNOT AND
IN REQUIRE. IMPACT ASSESSMENTS
AND- I WOULD SAY THAT THAT THE
CANADA DEFINITION OF AN EIGHTY
YES. TECHNOLOGY REPLACES THE
JUDGMENT OF HUMAN DECISION
MAKERS SO IN COMPARISON TO
THAT- ARE- YOU KNOW LANGUAGE IS
MUCH MORE NARROWED- IN THE E.
U. IT'S JUST DATA PROCESS IT
MEANS. DATA OR SAT THAT'S NOT
FAIR- YOU KNOW IN IN THAT
CONTEXT. AB THIRTEEN IS
ACTUALLY VERY MORE VERY MUCH
MORE SPECIFIC AND- I WOULD
ACTUALLY ALSO DEFERRED A
DOCTORS ARE JORDAN WHO MIGHT
HAVE SOME MORE. AT EASE I HEAD
INTO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT AND HOW THAT
CAN HELP NARROW- THE
APPLICATION OF THIS DEFINITION.
I YES IS THE OTHER WITNESS
WANNA. PROCEED. WELL NOT NOT
HEARING- CHERUB SO I'LL JUST
THAT KIND OF SAY THAT THE
ANALYSIS FROM THE FROM THE
COMMITTEE COVERED THAT
SITUATION PRETTY WELL EIGHT
EIGHT SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT MEANS
THE DIMENSIONAL REDUCTION MEANS
TAKING A LOT OF DIFFERENT
VARIABLES- AND THEN COME COME
COLLAPSING BACK INTO ONE
PARTICULAR VARIABLE BUT IT'S
NOT SOMETHING A CALCULATOR DOES
AND YOU'RE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
ADDING THE SAME VARIABLE
YACHTING I NUMBER PLUS THE
NUMBER BUT THE NUMBER THAT'S
NOT A DIMENSIONAL REDUCTIONS.
THIS DEFINITION WAS TALK TO
WITH A LOT OF COMPUTER
SCIENTISTS AND DATA SCIENTISTS
TO TRY TO FIND A WAY TO THREAD
THAT NEEDLE AND- YOU KNOW AS
THE AUTHORS STATED WHERE WE'RE
WILLING TO WORK- WE JUST NEED
SOME HELP FROM- THE OPPOSITION
THAT THE HELP NARROW THAT. I
THINK YOU AND I AM NOT THE
OPPOSITION BUT- AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH OTHER SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT
AND I THINK THAT MY- CONCERN IS
ACTUALLY STATUTORY
INTERPRETATION WHICH IS. THAT I
DIDN'T READ THAT TO SAY THAT
THE OTHER SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT
MEANT THE SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT
APPLIED TO SCORE CLASSIFICATION
RECOMMENDATION. TO ME THAT WAS
A LIST AND OTHER SOME OF APPLE
WAS A FOURTH. ELEMENT AND SO I
THINK IF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THERE IS LIMITED. TO
EVERYTHING THAT PROVIDES A
SIMPLIFIED OUTPUT IT JUST NEEDS
TO BE RE DRAFTED TO CLARIFY
THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT MY
READING IS THAT. THE
LEGISLATION BUT I THINK IT DOES
HELP TO CLARIFY AND I THINK WE
CAN. IT'S NOT A COMPLICATED FIX.
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO DO THAT.
ABSOLUTELY. OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER JENNER I
APPRECIATE THE- THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE ABOUT THE
CLARIFICATION I APPRECIATE THAT
THE AUTHORS- IS WILLING TO WORK
TO TRY TO GET THAT
CLARIFICATION JUST IT IT IS A
COMPLICATED BILL FOR ARC FOR
NONTECHNICAL PEOPLE AND TERMS
OF- READING AND UNDERSTANDING
SO APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER. YEAH
SO WHAT I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT
ON THIS IS YOU KNOW THE ISSUE
OF- ZERO OF HAVING TO PROVIDE
YOUR ALGORITHM TO. TO
GOVERNMENTS AND MANY OTHER
PRIVATE INDUSTRIES THINKING
THAT THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
SUBJECT THEIR- YOU KNOW THEIR
TRADE SECRETS THERE- YOU KNOW
BUSINESS SECRETS TO PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE. HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THAT AND I MEAN DOES THE
BILL DO THAT OR THEY BE
REQUIRED TO KIND OF GIVE THEIR
PRIVATE ALGORITHM. AND THEY'RE
GONNA AND- CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE. NO WE WILL NOT- REQUIRED
THAT IN FACT THE RECENT SET OF
AMENDMENTS- MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT- WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR
TRADE SECRETS OR ANY
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION- SO
THEY ARE NOT. FOR EXAMPLE SEE
THE T. R. WHO SHOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED SHOULD NOT ACTUALLY A
PUBLISH ANY OF THE TRADE
SECRETS OR ANY CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION. OF THAT WOULD BE
DEEMED OF PROPRIETARY SO THAT'S
IN INDIA AGAIN AND SO. I WAS
NOT IN THE ORIGINAL VERSION BUT
IS IT'S IN THE CURRENT VERSION.
OKAY- AND THEN I MEAN. I GUESS
ONE OF THE ISSUES IS HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU GET AT. MAY
NECESSARILY THESE TYPES OF
SYSTEMS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO-
HOW MANY NINE KEY WORDS IN
THERE AND THEY'RE CREATED BY
HUMAN BEINGS SO THEY'RE ALL TO
MANY GONNA HAVE ISSUES WITH
THEM BUT THE IDEA BEING THAT
THEY KIND OF HELP CREATE
EFFICIENCIES- I MEAN CAN YOU
REALLY CREATE SOMETHING THAT'S
PERFECTLY. A PERFECTLY AN
OBJECTIVE SYSTEM- WELL YOU'RE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT- IS
GALLAGHER I THINK I WOULD I
TRYING TO CREATE A PERFECT
SYSTEM- YOU KNOW EVERYBODY IS
SOMEWHAT BIASED IN A WAY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO SHINE
SOME LIGHT ON THESE ALGORITHMS
ON THESE BLACK BOXES WHICH HAVE
BEEN COLLABORATED THROUGHOUT
THAT YOU KNOW THE VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES AND OF THE PROBLEM
IS YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THESE BLACK
BOXES DO WIN AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT KIND OF DATA GOES INTO THE
SYSTEM AND WHAT COMES OUT I
MEAN WEEK SOMETIMES WE KNOW
WHAT'S GOOD YOU KNOW WHAT COMES
OUT OF IT- YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
PEOPLE COULD USE UP. OUR FLIGHT
RISKS- AND LET'S SEE OF THE
PREVIOUS CRIMINAL HISTORY AND
THEY USE THAT INFORMATION AND
DAHLE YOU KNOW THE OUTCOME
COULD BE- BILL AMOUNT FOR
EXAMPLE SO BUT WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT BLACK BOXES WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE MECHANISM WHAT
THEOTHER THING IS THAT THAT
MAKES THAT DECISION FOR PEOPLE
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE INTENT OF
THE BILL SO FOR TOO LONG I
THINK WE'VE BEEN- ALLOWING- YOU
KNOW THE SYSTEMS TO PROLIFERATE
OUT THERE NOBODY KNOWS WHAT BUT
THEY ARE AND WHAT THEY DO IN
FACT. YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE I
THINK WITH THAT WE CITED THREE
EXAMPLES IN MY OPENING AND YOU
KNOW FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION- YOU KNOW- THAT WAS
USED- IN FACT A FRAUDULENT YOU
WRONGFULLY USED IN AND THEY
WERE ACCUSED OF COMMITTING
FRAUD AND ON APPEAL ONLY 8% OF
THOSE CASES ARE TURNED OUT TO
BE VALID SO THAT WE TALK ABOUT
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND UP PEOPLE'S
CASES WERE INVALID BECAUSE OF
THE USE OF WRONGFUL AUGUR THEM
AND NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THE
AUTHOR WITHIN LESS THAN YOU
KNOW EXCEPT FOR THE YOU HAVE
DEVELOPER OR THE PEOPLE USING
AND ALSO PEOPLE WHO CREATED IT.
SO WE YOU KNOW ALL WE WANT TO
DO NOW IS TO IS TO SHINE SOME
LIGHT ON THAT BLACK BOX ON
THOSE ALTERNATIVES THAT PEOPLE
USE THESE DAYS AND WE'RE
LIMITING IT TO THE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WHO USE THESE CELL
OPERATIVES OR THE CDSS SO IT'S
A VERY IN THE NARROW SCOPE IT
OUT IN MANY WAYS- WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING EVERY SINGLE BUSINESS
TO DO- SO WE'RE- LIKE A- YOU
KNOW WE ALSO. PROVIDING FOR CD
TO PAY- PRESCRIBE A LITTLE
MORE- GUIDELINES FOR PEOPLE TO
COMPLY WITH. SO THIS IS A VERY
NARAL- NARROWLY TAILOR-
SOLUTION. TO A PROBLEM THAT'S
BEEN OUT THERE NOBODY'S BEEN
LOOKING OUT OF. BUT I THINK
THAT THIS WITNESS ALSO
MENTIONED THAT A CANDIDATE IS
USING IT- THE YOU IS USING AT
THE YOU KNOW. THE PEOPLE IN
EUROPE ARE USING ITSELF. SO WE
HAVEN'T BEEN LOOKING AT THE
ISSUE- TOO CLOSELY NEW YORK
HOUSING IT OFF ALL PAST ACTS
COMPOSED OF A ATTACK OF TASK
FORCES TO LOOK INTO THE ISSUE.
IN THE STATE OF WASHINGTON IS
DOING SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW- SO. THIS IS NO I THINK YOU
KNOW WE YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA.
ALL WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS AT
THIS ISSUE HI COMING I MEAN I
COULD NOT SO- IT'S OUT THERE
ALREADY YOU KNOW ITS- BEEN
WORKING. YOU KNOW WITHOUT
BEHIND- SEE YOU. KNOW BEHIND A-
BEHIND THE SCENES OF. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS- FOR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE. SO THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR YOU KNOW CUT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THAT WE OF THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED A RESOLUTION
ENDORSING THE ASILOMAR
PRINCIPLES FOR THE SAFE AND
BENEFICIAL DEVELOPMENT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WHICH-
YOU KNOW WAS ITSELF- THE
PRODUCT OF. THE HUNDREDS OF
LEADING RESEARCHERS AND
ACADEMICS AND ETHICISTS- IN THE
FIELD BUT IN VARIOUS FIELDS-
AND THEN IT YOU KNOW THAT
RESOLUTION IS NOT UNANIMOUSLY
PASSING OUR OUR LEGISLATURE AND
WE'RE THE FIRST LEGISLATION THE
COUNTRY TO ENDORSE ONE OF THE
KEY PRINCIPLES- IN THERE IS THE
IDEA OF EXPLAIN ABILITY YOU
KNOW THAT- WHAT'S GOING ON
SHOULD BE AUDITABLE BY A
COMPETENT- HUMAN AUTHORITY AND
I UNDERSTAND. THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY BE THE PURPOSE OF
YOUR BILL IS TO GET AT. AT THAT
IDEA SO I GUESS I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR- THE- THE
OPPOSITION- IF YOU WILL AND DO
YOU AGREE THAT. I SHOULD ALSO
ADD BY THE WAY THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S A NOTHING OF A CONCERN
WHEN WE HAVE THE LIKES OF
FACEBOOK AND YOUTUBE. THEY'RE
USING ALGORITHMS TO SORT OF
SHAPE OUR PREFERENCES WHO HAS
THAT WE DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND- BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
THE GOVERNMENT DOING THAT- IT'S
A WHOLE NOTHER MATTER IT RAISES
I THINK- QUESTIONS OF
DEMOCRATIC LEGITIMACY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND SO THAT'S
WHY I'M I'M SYMPATHETIC TOWARDS
THAT THE GOAL OF THIS IS A
QUESTION OF THE OPPOSITION IS.
DO YOU DO YOU AGREE THAT THIS
IDEAOF EXPLAINED ABILITY IS.
AN IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE- WHEN IT
COMES TO GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING
AND GOVERNMENT SERVICES- AND IF
SO HOW COULD THIS BILL BE. MORE
NARROWLY CRAFTED TO ACHIEVE
THAT GOAL WITHOUT THAT SORT OF
CONCERNS. YOU'RE RAISING ABOUT
OVER BREATH. AND THIS IS FOR MR
MOHAMMED WITHOUT CALCHAMBER. IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE. I AM
ON THE LINE AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR QUESTION- YOU KNOW
WITH REGARD TO- AT YOU KNOW
ATTEMPTING TO CATER TO AMEND
THE BILL TO. PUT IT IN A PLACE
WHERE WHERE WE NEED MORE
WORKABLE- I THINK AT THIS POINT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO- YOU KNOW
SURGICALLY DEFINING TERMS LIKE
AUTOMATED DISPENSING SYSTEM AND
HIGH RISK APPLICATION- ON OUR
END- YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK IT
WOULD BE RATHER- IT WAS A
LITTLE TALK TO CRAFT-
DEFINITIONS OF COURSE- YOU KNOW
BURKE FOR LEGISLATION POLICY
THEY'RE PERFECT BUT- WE DO
THINK THERE ARE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO BE MADE
HOWEVER- I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE- WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON AND- AND I
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE JOHN. I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION
SUFFICIENTLY. I THINK IT DOES
AND I THINK THAT- MISTER CHAI
YOU CITED A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES
AND I THINK THE FEDERAL LAW
TRADE COMMISSION IS IT JUST
CAME OUT WITH SOME- GUIDELINES
AS WELL. IT SORT OF THAT. YOU
KNOW DEFINING WHAT CONSTITUTES
A AYE VERSUS A STANDARD SORT OF
COMPUTATION IS. IS TRICKY I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A NUMBER OF.
GUIDEPOSTS OUT THERE THAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT CAN BE LOOK TO-
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER THOUGHTS-
MISTER CHOW AND SORT OF HOW-
YOU ENVISION THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS. YEAH I FORESEE
US. DOING A LITTLE CLEAN UP ON
THE LANGUAGE ITSELF OFFERS ON
PLACE CITED EARLIER. THAT THAT
THEY WERE SORTS THAT WE COULD
TO- PLAY WITH A LITTLE BIT FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK- IT'S BEEN
POINTED OUT THAT- THE TERM
POTENTIAL COULD. INVITE
ADDITIONAL ISSUE SO WE'LL LOOK
AT AND- LOOK INTO THAT. AND
ALSO- PREVIOUSLY WE DISCUSSED
OBVIOUSLY THE- THE DEPRESSING
THIS OR THE BRASS- THE- OVER
BROUGHT DINOSAUR BREATH OF THE
WILD. AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO.
AMEND THE BILL TO EXCLUDE
THINGS LIKE SPREADSHEETS AND-
CALCULATORS AND THE LIKE-
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
IN THE WASHINGTON STATE'S
BUILT. UP SO WE COULD TO. DO
THAT AND- YOU KNOW AT THIS
POINT WE JUST LIKE TO INVITE-
THE OPPOSITION TO PROVIDE US
WITH THE INPUT I THINK YOU
KNOW. WE WE'VE BEEN READY AND
ABLE AND TRY TO WORK WITH THEM
ON ON THE ON A DESTINATION.
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY BUT WE
WANT TO YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
INTENT I THINK AS I AS I STATED
BEFORE. SO WE JUST WANT TO
SHINE SOME LIGHT ON THESE.
OTHER ITEMS. AND FROM A
GOVERNMENT. ENTITIES
PERSPECTIVE. THEY ALSO NEED TO
KNOW YOU KNOW WHEN THEY
EVALUATE THESE UP PROJECTS
SUBMITTED BY CONTRACTORS. THEY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT I MEAN IF YOU DON'T.
IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN
THESE BLACK THE BLACK BOXES OF
THESE ORGANISMS. HOW WOULD
THEY- PICK AND CHOOSE OF SOME
YOU KNOW- A PROJECT FOR
EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW I THINK OF
FOR TOO LONG WE'LL BE LOOKING
AT JUST THINGS LIKE THE COST.
AND OTHER THINGS INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT THE LONG TERM FOR IT
FOR EXAMPLE VALUE. STILL UP.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A COST WE ALL
TO. ALSO LOOK AT THINGS THAT.
WE WOULD HAVE- IN CURFEWS ON
THE COST IT WOULD HAVE A CO
HER. HEAD DOES SOMETHING GONE.
FOR EXAMPLE. IN IT'S A
GOVERNMENT- GETS THE- YOU KNOW.
WHAT KIND OF THE- YOU KNOW LIKE
TO MEXICO CASE I. YOU KNOW.
WHAT THE DAMAGE DONE IT I MEAN.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE COST. FOR
ALWAYS ANY ANY POTENTIAL. YOU
KNOW SO WE GOT A AT IT FROM
THAT. TO STUFF. SO- I THINK
THAT THE IDEA IS SIMPLE I MEAN
WE DON'T DID YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT TO. OPERATING ON ANY
SYSTEM THAT WOULD CREATE ANY-
DISCRIMINATORY OR BIASED. A
IMPACT ON ANYBODY IN FACT SO
THAT'S THE GOAL. ALL RIGHT WELL
I YEAH I AM. YOU KNOW SATISFIED
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK ON ON
THOSE ISSUES TO ASSURE THAT
THIS ISN'T GOING TO CREATE AN
IMPEDIMENT TO- THE USE OF YOU
KNOW VALUABLE TECHNOLOGY- IN IN
THE PUBLIC SPHERE AND WON'T
DISADVANTAGE- YOU KNOW CERTAIN
TYPES OF. OF COMPANIES IN THE
BIDDING PROCESS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT AND I KNOW WE'VE
WORKED VERY WELL IN THESE THESE
ISSUES TOGETHER BEFORE SO- WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IS AB
UNITED IT HATTIESBURG REACHES
OUT HI. I. HAVE HI THE FIVE
HOUR YEAH OKAY I RIGHT YEAH I.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM VOTING
GABRIEL AGAU. GALLAGHER
NONVOTING IRWIN IRWIN ACT LEE.
WICKS. AT THAT BILL HAS SIX
PLUS SO THAT IS HOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MEMBERS AND WE HAVE A
SECOND BILL FROM- MISTER
CHANNEL WHICH IS AB. FOURTEEN
NINETY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'LL KEEP A VERY
BRIEF- LAST YEAR THE VOTERS OF-
CALIFORNIA PASSED. PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR WHICH CREATED A
PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY WITH
FIVE MEMBERS TO BE APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD- THE LANGUAGE IN THE
PROPOSITIONS SUGGEST THAT
APPOINTEES TO THE BOARD SHOULD.
BE SOMEONE WITH EXPERTISE IN
PRIVACY TECHNOLOGY AND CONSUMER
RIGHTS. AND IN THE FOLLOWING
PARAGRAPH IT SAYS IT REQUIRES
BOARD MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUALIFICATIONS IN AREAS OF
PRIVACY AND TECHNOLOGY PERIOD-
SO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS THAT
IT INSERT THE THREE COURTS BACK
IN THE- IN IN THE IN THE IN THE
LAW AND WHICH IS NOW PART OF
CIVIL CODE. OF THE WORD THE
THREE WORDS ARE- CONSUMER
RIGHTS AND CONSUMER RIGHTS SO
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY TO THE
BILL- SO- THANKS. MOTIONS IN
TWO SECONDS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ARE YOU ON THAT. OUR FIRST
AYE WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF WOULD OF ONE
WITNESS- I GUESS ACTUALLY
SHOULD OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- IF
THERE ARE ANY. FOLKS ON THE
LINE. AND LATER JOHN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. GEN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR. THEN THAT WE HAVE-
CHAU MUHAMMAD IS OUR WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION FROM CALCHAMBER.
THANK YOU AGAIN HONORABLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- PARENTS ABOUT
MUHAMMAD CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN THE VERY VERY
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IS DRAFTED AND AS ALWAYS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO'S OFFICE
AND THE STAFF. ARE CONCERNED
WITH THIS BILL IS THAT THE TERM
CONSUMER RIGHTS COULD BE
INTERPRETED TO EXCLUDE
OTHERWISE QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
FROM APPLYING TO THE BOARD- AND
WHAT WE MEAN BY THAT IS THAT IF
THE TURN CONSUMER RIGHTS IS
INTERPRETED TO MEAN EXPERIENCE
WORKING SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF
OF CONSUMERS. OR FOR SPECIFIC
ORGANIZATIONS ARE OUR GROUPS
ARE POSITIONS MANY OTHERWISE
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES COULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM CONSIDERATION SO
NARROWING THE QUALIFICATIONS IN
THIS WAY COULD POTENTIALLY
HINDER A DIVERSE INCLUSIVE
BOARD OUT OF. DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDER OPINION- AND FOR
THAT REASON WE MUST THAT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AND AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS I
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ON ALL OUR
BILLS NATIONS THANK. THANK YOU
I THERE ANY OF THE PUBLIC ON
THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. GEN ONE ZERO
CURRENT OPPOSITION- WE WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE EDT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T HAVE TO GO ON
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF INTERNET
ASSOCIATION RESPECT LIPS THANKS.
ONE TENDER IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTINUE MR. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THIS
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HAVE A COUPLE. COUPLE
QUESTIONS THE MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT. THIS THE LANGUAGE
ABOUT EXPERIENCE IN CONSUMER
RIGHTS EXIST IN ONE PLACE BUT
NOT ANOTHER AND YOU'RE SEEKING
TO MAKE IT IT'S THAT IS WHAT DO
YOU KNOW WHETHER WHAT THAT WAS
INTENTIONAL- IS THIS WAS AN
OVERSIGHT. WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE RIGHT I THINK I THINK IT
REALLY MAKES SENSE TO ADD THAT
FROM BACK IN THERE OR ADDED TO.
THE LAW BECAUSE IT- IT MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE FOR CONSISTENCY
OF PURPOSE IS FOR ONE THING AND
NUMBER TWO I THINK HAVING THE
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
CONSUMER RIGHTS REALLY. REALLY
HELPS. INSTEAD OF HINDER OF THE
OF THE PROCESS. FOR MEMBERS YES
SO MY VIEW IS TO FOLLOW UP THE
QUESTIONS AND ONE WILL BE. WHAT
CONSTITUTES EXPERIENCE IN
CONSUMER RIGHTS. YEAH I THAT
ELSEWHERE TO FIND OR OR WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS THE CONTEMPLATION-
YEAH I THINK THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUMENT IS OUT YOU KNOW THAT
WE'RE REQUIRING CONSUMER
ADVOCACY WHICH IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE TRY TO DO. ALL WE
TRYING TO DO IS A SOMEBODY WITH
YOUR CONSUMER EXPERIENCE WHICH-COULD BE PICKED UP ANY ANY
ANYWHERE. FOR EXAMPLE I THINK-
HOUSE AN EXAMPLE HERE- LET'S
SEE ACADEMIC STUDY OF CONSUMER
RIGHTS ARE YOU KNOW OR
EXPERIENCE- HELPING INDUSTRIES
NAVIGATING THE COMPLEXITY OF
COME CONSUMER LAW. SO IT COULD
IT'S A VERY BROAD TERMINOLOGY
THAT COULD TELL QUALIFY UNDER
THE DEFINITION. SO WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT YOU KNOW LIMITING-
COULD NOT PRESCRIBING ANY ANY
PARTICULAR- ELEMENTS TO THAT
TERMINOLOGY. BECAUSE IT OCCURS
TO ME. THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR THAT
I'M ON THE FENCE ON IT BECAUSE
AND FLEW OVER THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I'M STUCK ON THAT
BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE- LIKE
THAT WOULD LIMITED MOSTLY TO
PROFESSORS AND LAWYERS. AM I
WRONG. I MEAN THAT'S- NO NO IN
FACT IT IDEA DIMENSIONS
ACADEMIC STUDIES SO THAT
DEFINITELY. WOULD INCLUDE
PROFESSORS I MEAN THAT. THAT'S
A STUDY OF CONSUMER LAW OF
COURSE THIS SORRY WHAT WHEN I'M
WHEN I'M TRYING TO SAY IS. I
THINK IF WE ADD THE TERM IF THE
BILL. BECOMES LAW. THE FURTHER.
IT'S A FURTHER ADDITIONAL
QUALIFIER EIGHT ADMIN AND IT.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
MOST LOGICAL INTERPRETATION OF
THE TERM YOU KNOW CONSUMER
RIGHTS WOULD BE PROFESSORS. AND
ATTORNEYS THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN CONSUMER. RIGHTS IN THE
SITE. IS THAT THE DIRECTION
YOU'RE SEEKING TO GO AND ART
AND ARE WE BEING OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE IN THAT IT IS IT
IS I THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S
FROM IS BROAD ENOUGH TO.
ENCOMPASS A LOT OF- EXPERIENCES
THAT COULD QUALIFY UNDER THAT
DEFINITION. SO OKAY AND SO LIKE
WHAT WHAT. I APOLOGIZE FOR
THINKING OUT LOUD I'M TRYING TO
WORK THROUGH THIS. LIKE IT
SHOULD BE WORKED AS AN
INSURANCE ADJUSTER. YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT WOULD THAT BE OR
SOMEBODY RAN A SMALL BUSINESS
FOR EXAMPLE AND THEY- HAD A
CREDIT DISPUTE WITH THE CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCY YOU KNOW I
MEAN ARE THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
WOULD THEY CONSTITUTE THIS TYPE
OF CONSUMER RIGHTS EXPERIENCE
POSSIBLE IF THE IF THE KIND OF
BUSINESS THAT THEY'RE- DEALING
WITH INVOLVING INVOLVED-
CONSUMERS. OKAY ALL RIGHT
APPRECIATE YEAH IT'S VERY BROAD
I MEAN WE'RE NOT TRYING TO KIND
OF LIMIT TO SCHOOL WITH THE
DEFINITION. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SINAN MISTER CHALLENGER TO
CLOSE- YEAH I AS WE ARE ABLE
THANK YOU. OF THE OTHER MOTION
SECOND MOTION IS DUE PASS. THIS
TO APPROPRIATIONS TO
APPROPRIATIONS UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE SAYS AB FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAP I CHAO I
KILEY. KILEY NOT VOTING
BARRICADE HAVE RK AND I'VE DONE
IT BENNETT I CARILLO. I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I IRWIN-
WHEN I LEVY. WICKS WICKS HI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS-
THE BUZZ EIGHT EIGHT BOOKS THE
BILL HAS THE VOTES ON THE BILLS
OUT. CAN YOU. THANK GOD FOR
SUITS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
DIFFERENCES TO OUTLAST BILL AND
THAT'S THE LAST ITEM ITEM
TWENTY AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE OF
THIS WEEK'S I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. DONE THE- I WILL SPEAK
QUICKLY- I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MOMENTS
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU CAN BE
STUFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS LAGUAGE AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE THE KIDS ACT
IS DESIGNED TO PROTECT CHILDREN
WHERE THEY CONSUME ONLINE
CONTENT THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED TO THEM THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER THE FEDERAL
CHILDREN'S TELEVISION ACT WHICH
REGULATES THE CONTENT THE KIDS
CONSUME ON TELEVISION RESTRICTS
THE AMOUNT OF ADVERTISING
CHILDREN'S PROGRAMMING. WELL AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE IS NOT AS
PRESCRIPTIVE ITS CURRENT
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THE BILL AS
IT IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
WILL PROVIDE SAFEGUARDS TO
PROTECT CHILDREN FROM
MANIPULATIVE DESIGN FEATURES
THAT PROVIDE INSTANT ACCESS TO
INAPPROPRIATE CONTENT OR
MARKETING WHILE THEY'RE ONLINE
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT PLATFORMS. PLATFORMS
PROVIDE PARENTS OR GUARDIANS
WITH THE ABILITY TO OPT INTO
DESIGN FEATURES SUCH AS AUTO
PLAY AN IN APP PURCHASES TO
ENSURE THAT THESE FEATURES ARE
NOT AUTOMATICALLY AVAILABLE FOR
CONTENT DIRECTED AT KIDS THIS
LAYER OF PROTECTION ALLOW
PARENTS TO CONTROL THEIR
CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO FEATURES
THAT WERE DESIGNED FOR ADULTS
AND THEREFORE DO NOT FACTOR IN
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF YOUNG MINDS
ABILITIES AND SENSIBILITIES
ADDITIONALLY AB FIFTEEN FORTY
FIVE WILL PROHIBIT CONTENT
DIRECTED TO KIDS TO PROMOTE
APPLE FIVE OR ENCOURAGE
CONSUMPTION OF CONTENT OR
ADVERTISING THAT INVOLVES
SEXUAL MATERIAL PHYSICAL OR
EMOTIONAL VIOLENCE INCLUDING
BULLYING. ADULT ACTIVITIES OR
OTHER CONSUMPTION OF ALCOHOL OR
TOBACCO FINALLY AS COMPANIES
CREATE NEW PLATFORMS AND DIRECT
ONLINE CONTENT TO KIDS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISH PROTECTIONS SIMILAR
TO WHAT CURRENTLY EXISTS FOR
CHILDREN'S TELEVISION PROGRAMS
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION AS THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY MOVES FORWARD TO
REDEFINE THE DEFINITIONS ARE
PARTICULAR AND I'VE SPOKEN TO A
NUMBER OF YOU ABOUT THAT AND
I'M VERY OPEN TO THINKING THAT
THROUGH AND TO CONTINUE TO
CONTINUING FURTHER AMENDMENTS-
WITH ME I HAVE- VIRTUALLY MY
WITNESS- JOSEPH JR MON A
DIRECTOR OF PLATFORM
ACCOUNTABILITY INSTEAD ADVOCACY
AT COMMON SENSE MEDIA. ON THE
LINES TESTIFIED. MISTER
DRUMMING BEGIN. Q. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GO AHEAD. BOB SO FOR THE RECORD
MY NAME IS JOSEPH TROHMAN AND-
I DO I WORK ON EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE ONLINE PLATFORMS FOR
COMMON SENSE MEDIA WE SUPPORT
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE- THE
REALITY IS WITH KIDS AND FAMILY
SCREEN TIME EXPLODING IN YOU
KNOW RESPONSE TO REMOTE
LEARNING THE PANDEMIC AND OTHER
LARGER TECH TRENDS THAT WE'RE
SEEING- PROMOTING ACCESS TO
RESPONSIBLE CHILD APPROPRIATE
ONLINE CONTENT THE POTENTIAL.
YOUNG KIDS RIGHT NOW ARE
AVERAGING ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
HOURS OF SCREEN TIME PER DAY
AND ONLINE VIDEOS FROM
STREAMING SERVICES DOMINATE
THAT PACIFIC- IN A RECENT
CENTER BY MEDIA USUALLY FOUND
THAT 44% OF PARENTS REPORT THAT
THEIR CHILDREN SPEND TOO MUCH
TIME WITH STREAMING MEDIA.
NEARLY HALF THE IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO GET KIDS TO STOP
USING- ONLINE PLATFORMS THE
REALITY IS THE TECH PLATFORMS
ARE ARE RIFE WITH WHAT WE CALL
WHAT ARE FORTUNATE PERSUASIVE
DESIGN WHICH STEERS USERS
TOWARD CERTAIN BEHAVIORS THAT
OFTENTIMES ARE NOT APPROPRIATE
FOR KIDS- WE HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THINGS LIKE AUTO PLAY- WHICH
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN CHILDREN ARE
INCREDIBLY SUSCEPTIBLE TO AND-
YOU CANNOT. GET OUT OF ON
PLATFORMS LIKE YOUTUBE KIDS
PRESENTLY AS WELL AS OTHER
TYPES OF MESSAGES THAT- PROVIDE
KIDS WITH THAT SCENT OF
ARTIFICIAL ACHIEVEMENT OR
PROPONENT AND I THINK THESE
DESIGN FEATURES COME ON TOP OF
LARGER CONCERNS ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF CONTENT AVAILABLE ON
VIDEO STREAMING PLATFORM- WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
ALGORITHMS I'M VIDEO STREAMING
PLATFORMS. AMPLE BUY EXTREMISM
AS WELL AS OTHER PROBLEMATIC
AND FRANKLY ADULT CONTENT- IT
IS ONE SOCIAL MEDIA SCHOLAR PUT
IT WE WE'RE JUST NEVER HARD
CORE ENOUGH FOR YOUTUBE'S
RECOMMENDATION ALGORITHM.
VIDEOS ABOUT JOGGING THE TWO
VIDEOS ABOUT RUNNING
ULTRAMARATHONS IN ON AND ON AND
ON- VIDEO STREAMING PLATFORMS
ARE DESIGNED TO PROMOTE
RECOMMEND AND DISSEMINATE
VIDEOS THAT ARE CONSTANTLY
UPPING THE STAKES AND THEY DO
SO IN WAYS THAT THE NUCLEAR
CHILDREN- AB. FIFTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE USEFUL FIRST STEP
TOWARD TRY TO CREATE A CRAP THE
TO SPACE FOR KIDS ONLINE-
WALKING. EAGER AND WELL. OF
SUGGESTED FOR IMPROVING FROM
AND WE ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE
MOVE THIS TO FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO THE SOME
SO MISTER OFF PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES. HAMLEYS IN GERMAN IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR VERY GOOD LET'S
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE DILLON HOFFMAN WITH THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION. MR
HOFFMAN ARE YOU ON THE LINE
PLEASE. S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON HOFFMAN O
BEHALF INTENET EXPECTATIONS
OUR MEMBERS ARE STILL REVIEWING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE NEW DIRECTION
AND CERTAINLY THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE TOO NARROW
THE BILL- WERE POSTED ON PRINT-
AT THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE A-
NEW FORMAL POSITION BUT ARE
EVALUATING NOT ALONG WITH THE
LANGUAGE- JERRY UNDERSTAND THE
INTENTION. BEHIND THIS DON'T
THINK IT'S A WERE THE ONES I
MEMBERSHIP OR KID FRIENDLY
CONTENT WORK HARD TO MAKE SURE
OUR PLATFORMS ARE SAFE FOR
KIDS. WE DO HOWEVER HAVE A FEW
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE OCT FIRST AB FIFTEEN
FORTY FIVE PURPORTS TO REGULATE
CONTENT AND CONTROLS FOR
ACCOUNTS CREATED FOR KIDS BY
THEIR PARENTS. HOWEVER AS
DRAFTED THIS BILL COULD PULL IN
CONTENT AND CONTROLS FOR ENTIRE
PLATFORM- FOR EXAMPLE A KID
FROM THE MOVIE LIKE FROZEN TO
FOR EXAMPLE CAN BE VIEWED BY A
CHILD ON. THE COUNT THAT'S
CURRENTLY DEFINED THAT YOU
CAN'T COULD BE CONSIDERED TO BE
DIRECTED TO CHILDREN- TWO
DRESSES WE SUGGEST TAILORING
THE BILL THE USER PROFILES
WHICH CAN BE CREATED BY PARENTS
FOR KIDS. RATHER THAN TWO
ACCOUNTS WHICH I THINK BETTER
MATCHES- THE BILL'S INTENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE SUBJECTIVE
CATEGORIES OF CONTENT THAT AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE PROHIBITS
ARE CRITICAL TO IMPLEMENT AND
SHOULD BE AMENDED- THE BILL
PROHIBITS CONTENT INCLUDE
SEXUAL ACTIVITIES PHYSICAL OR
EMOTIONAL VIOLENCE VIOLENCE OR
ADULT ACTIVITIES. ALL OF WHICH
ARE ARE INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
DEFINE AND THEREFORE CREATE
UNCERTAINTY FOR PLATFORMS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE LION KING INCLUDES
DEPICTIONS OF CARTOON VIOLENCE
HARRY POTTER SERIES HAVE
SEVERAL BELIEVE THE SMALLEST OF
THE COMPLIANCE- AND TANGLED
FOLLOWS. THE PUBLIC FROM
EMOTIONAL- ALL OF THESE AND
MORE COULD BE PROHIBITED BY
THIS BILL EVEN THOUGH MANY
PEOPLE AND PARENTS WOULD
CONSIDER THEM. AS YOU CORPORATE
COURSE I'M- UNDER AGE CAN'T.
FIND WE APPRECIATE YOUR- TO FOR
THE CLASS THE- AT THE
DEFINITION OF PLATFORM WELL I
AGAIN WE CONTINUE. ALL VERY
RELIEVED THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR
OF MR. AND LOOK FORWARD TO CAN
OUR COM- LOOK OUT THERE ON THE
PITCH THANK. THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR ADDITION. OF PEOPLE
IN UPPER TO THE- JUST YOUR NAY
AND I'LL GET. PLACE AND LEAVES
AND I. PLEASED ONE ZERO THIS.
AGAIN ONE ZERO YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITE. HEY LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE AT
THE MOMENT- WILL FIRST MOVED TO
LINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR OPINION CHAIRED
MEMBERS CAME IN A MAJOR MEDICAL
TECHNET LIKE CAROLINA COMMENTS
WITH THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION AND YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE LINE A ONE OH ONE-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
ACTUALLY THIS IS A- CALL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THIS IS
MIKE SKIPPER CALLING FROM
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. AND WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING
AFFORD. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT TO BE LINED NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DEPUTY CHAIR
MEMBERS SHORT MUHAMMAD FROM
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE INTERNET
SITUATION IN TECHNET NOT
POSSESSION THANK YOU. OKAY. AND
NEXT TO BE LINED ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM READY
WITH THEM JAM ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
NATIONAL ADVERTISERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT. AND
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THE
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR THE SPRING FACTOR
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISSPOKE
AND CARD PLEASE. THANK YOU MISS
WAX FEW QUESTIONS ONE IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE
AGREED TO LIMIT IT TO THE
PROFILE OF THE CHILD INSTEAD OF.
THE ENTIRE ACCOUNT OF THE
PARENTS AND CHILDREN. WE ARE
GOING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
MAKE THAT WORK BECAUSE I WANT
WE WANTED TO BE FOR THE
INTENDED AUDIENCE RIGHT- SO I
THAT. THAT I HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS ONE IS ON AND I
APPRECIATE YOU CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THE DEFINITIONS I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED CLARITY IN
WHAT IT IS ALLOWED AND NOT
ALLOWED- MY- QUESTION THOUGH
IS- FOR ALL THE PARENTS IN THE
ROOM. YOU KNOW WHEN I READ THIS
DANIEL TIGER'S NEIGHBORHOOD WAS
A REGULAR IN MY HOUSE STILL
REGULAR IN MY HOMEWORK IN
YOURS. AND THERE'S A REALLY
GOOD CONTENT ON THERE THAT
ACTUALLY ROADS BULLYING TO
TEACH THE KIDS RIGHT. TO SAY
SOMETHING WHEN THEY SEE
SOMETHING RIGHT AND SO I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ALSO
ADDRESS SORT OF CONTENT THAT IS
APPROPRIATELY TARGETED TO KIDS
TO TEACH THEM ABOUT THESE
THINGS- AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE ADDRESSED. IT'S AN EXCELLENT
POINT. AND ONE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I MEAN I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL. IS USEFUL- I'M
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON YOU
KNOW. THE AUTO PLAY A PIECE OF
IT RIGHT WHERE. ANY OF US WHO
ARE PARENTS. YOU GIVE YOUR KID
YOUR PHONE THEY'RE WATCHING
SOMETHING. THIRTY MINUTES LATER
THEIR WATCHING SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT- SO THOSE.
I THINK WE HAVE MORE SPACE AND
UNDERSTANDING AROUND I THINK
THE CONTENT PIECE IS THE MOST
CHALLENGING PART OF THE BILL TO
BE FRANK WITH YOU. IT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WORK ON-
AND I'M VERY OPEN TO DOING
THIS. IN A RIGHT IN THE RIGHT
WAY AND WANT TO PRESENT A BILL
HOPEFULLY ON THE FLOOR. THAT I
THINK. GETS TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IN A BETTER WAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS I MEAN AS A
MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN. YOU
KNOW THEY'RE AT THE AUTO PLAY
FUNCTION IS SOMETHING THAT.
MAKES ME NOT ALLOW MY CHILDREN
TO USE CERTAIN PLATFORMS YOU.
SEEN IT HAPPEN RIGHT YOU YOU
SORT OF APPROVE WHAT IT IS THEY
WATCH AND THEN THE NEXT THING
STARTS ROLLING AND IT'S-
COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE
CONTACT RATE. AND IT'S I THINK
IT'S A REALLY. ABUSIVE FUTURE
ESPECIALLY WHEN CHILDREN ARE
USING IT- SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS AND I THINK ALL
OF US. YOUR POINT NEED.
CONTROLS AROUND ASK BECAUSE OUR
KIDS ARE USING TECHNOLOGY IN A
NEW WAY WE DID IT FOR
TELEVISION TO YOUR POINT AND
NOW THE- MOST KIDS AREN'T
SITTING AROUND WATCHING
TELEVISION ANYMORE RIGHT
THEY'RE ENGAGING IN THESE
PLATFORMS AND SO WE NEED TO BE.
DOING WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE CHIDREN ARE PROPERLY
PROTECTED- MY LAST QUESTION IS
ON ENFORCEMENT. SO
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
ALTHOUGH PERHAPS IT'S LIMITED
AND I WANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT A
LITTLE FURTHER. AND SAID THAT
THIS IS AN OPENING PLATFORM.
TOURISTS FRAZIER AND I'LL JUST
SAY- I'M OPEN TO RECONSIDERING
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
OKAY WE DO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
THE FIFTH PERSON PIECE. YES AND
I THINK IMPORTANT ENFORCEMENT
IS IMPORTANT I DON'T KNOW THAT.
I MEAN I GUESS I DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH ABOUT TV RICH FASHION
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WOULD
BE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. YEAH
WHERE IS THE ENFORCEMENT AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE HAVE A
ROBUST IMPORTS IN MAGAZINES.
AND FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND FROM
YOUR PRIVATE ACTION ACTUALLY
ALSO DIDN'T PROVIDE FOR MUCH
THAT WOULD. BE A MEANINGFUL
ENFORCEMENT IS SORT OF A
SEPARATE QUESTION SO I THINK.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT NEEDS GOOD ENFORCEMENT
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE SORT OF. LAWSUITS
COMING FROM NOWHERE RIGHT WHICH
IS ALWAYS A CONCERN THANK YOU
THOSE ARE ALL EXCELLENT POINTS
AND- IF YOU WANT TO WORK WITH
ME ON THE BILL WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOUR- SUPPORT VOTE. AND
MAYBE CO AUTHORSHIP. WELL I.
DEFINITELY BE SUPPORTING ABOUT
I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORKING
HIM. TO CONTINUE IT IT'S WITH.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IT MUST BE
ABLE GO HEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL ONLINE
MY COMMENTS WITHOUT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HER INTO- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE TIMES INCLUDING
FOR THE RECENTLY WHERE I'VE
GIVEN MY SON MY FIVE YEAR OLD
SON MY PHONE. TO WATCH AN
EPISODE OF DANIEL TIGER AND I
COME OVER HE'S WATCHING
SOMETHING ON YOUTUBE SO YES-
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN AREA I
THINK DEEP CONCERN FOR A LOT OF
PARENTS AND I YOU KNOW I
APPLAUD YOU FOR DIVING IN HERE
IT'S LIKE A COMPLICATED AND
DIFFICULT ONE AND YOU KNOW WE
HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS YESTERDAY. I JUST WANT TO
CHECK IN I KNOW THE ANALYSIS
NOTED THAT THERE WERE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS AROUND
A NUMBER THE DEFICIT. A
DEFINITIONS INCLUDING THE
DEFINITION OF THE- ARMY. AND I
KNOW THAT YOU SUGGESTED THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ITSELF. I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR THAT I THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT- REALLY DIFFICULT OR
CHALLENGING ISSUES HERE- BUT
ONES THAT ARE REALLY WORTHY OF
ATTENTION SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO DO IT WITH
PRECISION AND TO DO IT IN THE
RIGHT WAY SO THAT WE CAN FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT THE PRODUCT
AND YEP AND- I AM VERY
COMMITTED TO THAT AND I'VE- HAD
A NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
FOLKS UP ON THE DICE ABOUT THAT
SPECIFIC PIECE IN PARTICULAR.
AWESOME THANK YOU BOBBY PART TO
SUPPORT IT'LL CONNECT. COMMENTS
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. QUESTIONS
WHICH GALLAGHER GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES THE AUTHOR AND I HAVE
TALKED IN THE AND OBVIOUSLY-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S CLOSE
TO MY HEART ABOUT INSURING THAT
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS FOR USE-
YOU HAD A- THE BILL. LAST YEAR
REGARDING. RATTLE CONSENT FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS- AND A
AND I THINK THIS IS ALONG THAT
SAME SPIRIT- I WILL START ALL
START WITH THIS MY FAVORITE
PART OF THE BILL- IS. THIS THE
LANGUAGES SAYS ANY DESIGN
FEATURES SETTING THAT ALLOWS A
COVERED USER TO MAKE PURCHASES.
LIKE RIGHT A LOT- BECAUSE HE OF
GOD KNOWS BILLS FROM LIKE WHERE
IS THE THREE NINETY NINE COME
FROM WHAT DID YOU BUY YEAH-
AND- I THINK WE DEFINITELY HAVE
SOME SOME GROUND TYPE ARTICLES
FOR ON THAT ONE. ON THAT- AND I
AND I THINK LIKE IN JUNE THE
CONCEPT HERE IS A GOOD ONE
WHICH IS YOU KNOW A SPECIAL
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED IN ON.
APPS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
FOR KIDS RIGHT. BUT I THINK
RIGHT NOW LANGUAGE DOESN'T
QUITE CAPTURE THAT BECAUSE IT
SAYS KIND OF COPY ANY CONTENT-
ACTED TOWARDS KITTENS AND FACT
I THINK IF MAYBE IF THERE'S A
WAY TO TIGHTEN THAT THAT'S ONE.
YEAH YEP ONE THING I THINKING
ABOUT- AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE WORKING ON THAT- AND
THEN I THINK JUST THE
DEFINITIONS OF. YOU KNOW WHAT
WOULD CONSTITUTE- NO
INAPPROPRIATE CONTENT- I THINK
ON THE VIOLENCE LIKE WAS
BROUGHT UP I MEAN WE'VE SEEN
PLENTY OF CARTOONS DISNEY.
CARTOONS IT MIGHT YOU KNOW
SOMEONE COULD SAY OR ARE
VIOLENT RIGHT. BUT DON'T RISE
TO THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE WE
THINK WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE- I
THINK THE CHALLENGE OF THIS
BILL IS PICKING OUT LIKE HOW DO
WE DETERMINE THAT I MEAN DO YOU
USE LIKE THE P. G. G. RADIANCE.
AND THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING-
ADULT ACTIVITIES. I'M NOT SURE
LIKE WHAT THAT IS AT THIS POINT
I MEAN WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO
GET OUT WITH THAT ONE AS WELL
AS ADULT CONTENT YEAH I MEAN I
THINK IT AND THIS IS ALL STILL
LIKE I MEAN YOU'RE RAISING I
THINK HONESTLY THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS AND MAYBE THAT IS A
WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT IS THAT A
P. G. G. COULD THAT BE IS AN
APPARATUS THAT WE USE FOR THIS-
I DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS.
MR GALLAGHER ON THIS- BUT I DO
THINK IT'S WORTHY OF
EXPLORATION AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT- AND WANT TO DO THIS
IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL WAY THAT
WE ARE ENSURING THAT OUR KIDS
AND I I'M NOT I SHOULD ALSO SAY
I'M NOT ONE THESE SORT OF LIKE
PRUDISH TYPE PEOPLE- BUT I HAVE
A FOUR YEAR OLDS RIGHT AND SHE
USES MY PHONE AND WE START
SOMETHING WE END UP IN A VERY
DIFFERENT PLACE- SO I'M
GRAPPLING TO WITH HOW DO YOU
CREATE A POLICY THAT ENABLES
YOU TO PROTECT YOUR KIDS. AND
ENSURE THAT THEIR VIEWING THE
CONTENT THAT YOU THINK IS
SUITABLE FOR THEM- AND GIVE
PARENTS THAT LEVEL OF CONTROL
RIGHT WITHOUT- YOU KNOW HAVING
SORT OF A NANNY STATE SORT OF
BILL RIGHT SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS I'M I'M GRAPPLING WITH
BUT I'M I'M COMMITTED TO SORT
OF SING IT THROUGH AND TO
WORKING WITH. BOTH THE
OPPOSITION AND ANYONE HERE ON
THE DIETS. TO HAS OPINIONS ON
HOW WE THINK WE CAN DO THAT. SO
AND- AB GRAPPLED WITH THE SAME
THING SO I GUESS MY QUESTION MY
A MAYBE A PLAN LAST QUESTION
FOR YOU AND MAYBE FOR THE UP
ANYBODY ON THE OPPOSITION WANTS
TO TRY AND ANSWER THIS. YOU
KNOW HAVE YOU TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT HOW HOW THEY
COULD DO THAT FOR THEIR UNDER
THIRTEEN APPS YEAH I MEAN WE'VE
HAD ONGOING CONVERSATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PRETTY PRODUCTIVE AND
I THINK WE'LL- AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT- AND MAY
HAVE TO. MORE NARROWLY FOCUSED
THE BILL YOU KNOW DEPENDING ON
KIND OF WHERE WE LAND. FOR A-
AND OUT OF THE OPPOSITION WANTS
TO LAND BECAUSE I MEAN I THINK
TO BEAT PEOPLE CONTENT ON IT
LIKE IF YOU START OFF ON THAT
APP AND IT THAT CONTENT IS OKAY
BUT THEN WHY IS IT THAT YOU'RE
HAVING OTHER VIDEOS COME IN
THAT THE THAT RIDE HAILING SEND
YOU IN A CERTAIN DIRECTION.
RIGHT AND HOW COULD THAT MAY BE
FIXED BY THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE I
MEAN I THINK MY ONE QUESTION WE
SHOULD ALWAYS ASK IS A INDUSTRY
HOW CAN YOU DO THIS. SO YOU CAN
MEET THE EXPECTATION OF. OF
PARENTS. YEAH YOU KNOW AS THE
AS A CONSUMER AS WELL. AS
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT WANTING
THEIR KIDS TO BE A CONSUMER OF
CERTAIN THINGS. RIGHT I MEAN
YOU KNOW I MY DAUGHTER WILL
START ON YOU TO WATCHING PEPPA
PIG AND THEN LIKE THIRTY
MINUTES LATER SHE'S WATCHING
LIKE SKITTLES BEING PICKED UP
AND PUT FROM A CUP TO A BALL
OVER AND OVER AGAIN WHICH
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE. THE BEST
QUALITY CONTENT RIGHT SO HOW DO
YOU WHAT DO IN THE SITUATION I
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE STOPPING
OF AUTO PLAY IS ACTUALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT- WHICH IS IN THE BILL
I THINK THAT THERE ARE
QUESTIONS AROUND THE
DEFINITIONS OF LIKE THE SOME OF
THE CONTENT PIECE THAT YOU'RE
RAISING. AND I AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE ON. NAY
FIGURED OUT THE- I WOULD LOVE
TO WORK OUTLINED DEFINITION ACT.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
GRANT. YEAH I JUST LIKE TO ADD
MY THOUGHTS ON THE THERE'S SORT
OF TWO COMPONENTS OF THE BILL
AS STANDS NOW THAT I THINK ARE
EXCELLENT THAT WOULD GIVE
PARENTS MORE CONTROL AND
PROTECT KIDS AND THAT'S THE
AUTO PLATE OF PORTION OF THE
BILL AND THE PROTECTION ON THE
FINANCIAL PIECE WHICH I'VE
WORKED LIKE MR GALLAGHER AND
YOU ON THE OTHER PRIOR PIECES
OF LEGISLATION WITH. MIXED
SUCCESS TO TRY TO IN THE
PRACTICE OF MARKETING TO
CHILDREN- WHICH IS THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS WHICH IS
NOT A GOOD PRACTICE MIGHT BE.
ARGUABLY SHOULDN'T BE LEGAL- SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I THINK
THOSE ARE GREAT AND THE AUTO
PLAY THING I'VE SEEN I HAD THE
SAME ISSUE IN MY HOUSEHOLD
RIGHT I MEAN. THE KID STARTS
WHY IT'S NOT LIKE CARTOONS ON
SATURDAY MORNING LIKE YOU KNOW
I GREW UP WATCHING DUCKTALES
AND BATMAN OR WHATEVER. AND THE
THING GOES FOR THIRTY MINUTES
AND THEN IT'S DONE. AND THEN
YOU KNOW THE- THE PARENTS KNOW
HOW LONG IT'S GOING N YOU KNOW
WHAT'S ON THE SHOW THEY KNOW
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE YOU GOTTA.
ACCEPTABLE LIST AND
UNACCEPTABLE LIST AND THE
PARENTS HAD THE ABILITY TO
MONITOR THAT AND NOW IT DOESN'T
WORK THAT WAY BECAUSE- THE
THING LEADS TO SOMETHING ELSE
LEAD SOMETHING ELSE LEAD
SOMETHING ELSE. FIRST YOU SAID
YAK YOU KNOW. HEY HEY SIX YEAR
OLD YOU CAN WATCH. YOU CAN
WATCH A LITTLE BIT OF MINECRAFT
OR WATCH OTHER PEOPLE PLAY
MINECRAFT WHICH IS A BIG THING
NOW. JUST WEIRD. AND THEN THE
NEXT THING YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
THERE'S SOME SHOOTING THING OR
SOMETHING'S GOT EFFORTS ON IT
YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT HOW DID YOU
GET TO THAT IN FORTY MINUTES
RIGHT. SO THAT IS GREAT- THE
CONTENT PIECE AS WE'VE TALKED
OFFLINE. I THINK IT'S
PROBLEMATIC. I'M FROM A FIRST
MINUTE STANDPOINT AND- FROM A
PARENTAL CONTROL STANDPOINT. IN
THAT I DON'T WANT TO GIVE SOME.
BUREAUCRAT THE AUTHORITY TO
TELL. TO OVERRIDE EFFECTIVELY
BEFORE MY WIFE AND I AND YOU
KNOW HAVE THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHAT OUR KIDS WATCH AND- WATCH.
SO COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON IT. HI AGAIN TWO PARTS
OF THE SERVER. EXCELLENT IN
ABSOLUTELY WHAT WE NEED IN IN.
IN THIS. IN THE STATE AND IN
THIS COUNTRY. TO PROTECT KIDS
THE LAST PARTS PROBLEMATIC BUT
I HOPE WE CAN. GET TO A PLACE
WHERE. WORK PRESERVING THAT
PARENTAL CONTROL ND PRESERVING
YOU KNOW THE FIRST AMENDMENT
ISSUES. NO I APPRECIATE THAT
I'VE WORKED WITH MANY VIEW ON
THESE TYPES OF BILLS AND I
THINK THIS COMMITTEES VERY
THOUGHTFUL IN. HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THESE THINGS- ESPECIALLY
ALL THE PARENTS HELD. I WELCOME
THE INPUT AS WE MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD HOPEFULLY TODAY AND
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH WITH
YOU WANTED. AND I FOR JUST THAT
YOU MIGHT BE ONE OF THE ONLY
AUTHORS IN THIS BODY THAT CAN
PROBABLY LAND THIS PLANE IN THE
RIGHT PLACE. I'M GLAD YOU'RE
TAKING IT OFF AND GIVE IT MY
BEST SHOT. WAS CARILLO
CURRENTLY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I LOOKING HEARING I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
LUIS OBISPO FOR BRINGING UP
THAT THE CARTOONS OF THE NEED
TO SAY A- DUCKTALES. DUCKTALES
MOVE AND- UNDER VERY UNDERRATED
WAS ALSO DARK WING DUCK.
CLEARLY WE ARE AGING OURSELVES.
HOWEVER IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WHICH HAS NO IDEA
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND
THE MINUTE IN THE MUSEUM NOW-
BUT BUT THANK YOU I THINK A WE
GREW UP VERY DIFFERENTLY AND WE
ARE NOW IN A VERY DIFFERENT
SPACE IN WHICH WE HAVE TO
DEFINE WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE MY
PARENTS WERE VERY STRICT I HAD
ONE HOUR OF TELEVISION SO I WAS
VERY CAREFUL AND- VERY PICKY
ABOUT THE CARTOONS THAT I WOULD
WATCH- AND AFTER THAT IT WAS
LIKE HOMEWORK AND READING AND
PLAYING OUTSIDE AND IT'S- WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT FOR KIDS
NOW IT'S VERY DIFFERENT- MY-
CHIEF OF STAFF WAS LETTING ME
KNOW THAT. HER NEPHEW WAS
WATCHING VIDEOS ON YOUTUBE ON
HOW TO DESTROY TOYS AND STARTED
FLUSHING THEM DOWN THE TOILET
COSTING THE FAMILY THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
REPAIR SIMPLY BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO WAY TO CONTROL THAT SO I
WANT TO I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
BEEN DOING AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO LAND IN A IN A
GOOD PLACE. ON THIS BILL AND
IT'S WE'RE IN A VERY DIFFERENT
SPACE IN WHICH WE ARE IN A NEW
WORLD THAT HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
DEFINE WHAT TECHNOLOGY AN AXIS
LOOKS LIKE AND THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO DO SO THIS
IS COMPLETELY- BUT A DIFFERENT
SPACE BUT I HAD THIS IDEA AS
WELL THAT WHILE PARENTS ARE
ALSO TRYING TO REGULATE WHAT
CHILDREN DO ON. ON THEIR
DIGITAL DEVICES I'VE ALSO
BECOME VERY CONCERNED WITH WHAT
PARENTS DO WITH THEIR CHILDREN
ON DIGITAL DEVICES AND POSTING
PHOTOS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE VERY YOUNG THAT WHEN
THEY GET OLDER THEY HAVE NO
CONTROL OF THEIR DIGITAL
IDENTITY AND THAT'S SOMETHING
ELSE THAT I THINK AS PARENTS
ALSO SOMETHING ELSE TO CONSIDER
IN TERMS OF WHAT DOES THE
FUTURE LOOK LIKE AND WHAT IS
THE IMPACT. THAT SHARING THOSE
PHOTOS OF YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
SEEM VERY INNOCENT THAT LATER
ON IN LIFE WHEN THAT CHILD IS
AN ADULT THAT PHOTO HAS BEEN
OUT THERE AND THEY HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER THERE THE DIGITAL-
IDENTITY SO I HOPE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE YOU AND I
CAN WORK ON ON IN THE FUTURE
I'M VERY HAPPY TO THIS PART OF
YOUR BILL TODAY. I APPRECIATE
THAT I TOTALLY AGREE AND I'M
ALSO SOMEONE WHO DOES POST
PHOTOS OF MY CHILDREN BUT
ESPECIALLY THE PUBLIC FIGURE
I'M MOR MORE MINDFUL OF WHAT
THAT MEANS- BUT WE ARE IN THIS
SORT OF NEW WORLD ORDER- AND
THIS. SPACE IN SO I THINK WE
HAVE A REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP DEFINE. WHAT
THAT CAN LOOK LIKE NOT JUST FOR
HERE BUT FOR THE REST OF THE
pLIKE EVER EVOLVING CHANGING
DYNAMICS THAT WE HAVE. TERMS
ARE HOW WE ACCESS CONTENT
STARTING AT. AGE ZERO I MEAN MY
BUT WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS TO SHE
COULD LIKE SWIPE THE TECHS UP.
PRESSED LIKE THE AD SKIP AD
LIKE SHE WAS TO. SO WE HAVE TO
FIGURE THAT OUT BUT I
APPRECIATE IT WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT. MOSTLY
BECAUSE I HAD. THANK YOU SELLER
WORKS TO BRING THIS IMPORTANT-
BILL FORD. ADVERTISING AND
PRACTICES ESPECIALLY IF THEY GO
DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE OF
ALGORITHMS AND SUCH I KNOW THE
OPPOSITION HAS HAS MADE
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS BEING TOO
BROAD TOO TOO HARD O DEFINE
BUT I WANNA KNOW AND THIS MIGHT
BE HELPFUL FOR THE INCIDENT
SITUATION AND WORKING WITH YOU
IS. UNDER GOOGLE SLASH YOU DO
BECAUSE OF THE SAME COMPANY NOW
THEY ALREADY HAVE GUIDELINES
FOR ADVERTISER FRIENDLY CONTENT
WHICH THEY ACTUALLY CONSTANTLY.
PERUSE CONTENT AND MAKE IT SO
THAT YOU KNOW. IF I IF I VIDEO
HAS AN ADD ON IT IS BECAUSE
THEY FULFILLED SOME CERTAIN
GUIDELINES WHICH HAS ITS OWN
PROBLEMS IN IT BUT HERE JUST
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES THAT THEY
HAVE TO FIND GOOGLE AND YOUTUBE
HAS DEFINED ALREADY. IS
VIOLENCE ADULT CONTENT SHOCKING
CONTENT CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES
SENSITIVE EVENTS IN CITY NEAR
IN CITY HEARING DEMEANING AND
ADULT THEMES AND FAMILY CONCERT
THERE'S LIKE A LONGER LIST OF
THINGS THEY HAVE ALREADY
DEFINED SELVES FOR. ADVERTISER
FRIENDLY CONTENT AND EVEN
CREATE THEIR OWN LANGUAGE SO
PERHAPS IF THEY HAVE. IF THEY
HAVE ISSUES WITH HOW BROAD OUR
DEFINITION IS IN THE BILL MAYBE
THEY CAN REFER TO THEIR OWN
DEFINITIONS THAT THE CREATED.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE
ALREADY FACE BACKLASH FOR MANY
MANY YEARS ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
CONTENT THEY USE WHAT CAN
ADVERTISING YOU TO SO. YOU KNOW
YOU TO ITSELF ALREADY I THINK
HAS A STRONG SENSE OF. OR IS
TRYING TO MODERATE ITSELF IN
MANY WAYS SO I DO HOPE THAT
THEY WILL WORK IN GOOD FAITH
WITH YOU. ACTUALLY PLAYED INTO
THE LONG BECAUSE THEY CLEARLY
DID SOMETHING THEY KNOW IS A
PROBLEM. AND SO I REALLY HOPE
THAT THE OPPOSITION TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THIS AND NOT-
STATES TOO VAGUE SO I WAS HAPPY
IS FOR YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER LEE. IS THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL. MR WE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I- BUT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
MY COLLEAGUES A LOT OF THE SAME
CONCERNS I HAVE ABOUT. A
DEFINITION AND THEN CONTENT
AND- SEEING IF THERE'S ANOTHER
WAY TO DO. PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION BUT HE- THIS IS. A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
ESPECIALLY THE AUTO PLAY A PART
IN THE- RABBIT HOLE THAT. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM. SILICON VALLEY-
WAS MENTIONING AND IT WOULD BE
GREAT IF YOU COULD TAKE CARE OF
THE RABBIT HOLE FOR ADULTS
BECAUSE IT SAYS. ONE OF THOSE.
FORTUNATELY YEAH THAT'S NOT
GREAT OUT WITH SO I WOULD I
WOULD LOVE TO YOU KNOW HELP YOU
WITH THIS BILL GOING FORWARD I
THINK IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE GREAT I APPRECIATE THAT
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY A PODCAST
THE NEW YORK TIMES CALLED
RABBIT HOLE THAT'S ABOUT THIS
EXACT ISSUE FOR ADULT CONTENT
BUT- THAT IS FOR ANOTHER DAY.
MISTER BENNETT JUST JUST MY
COMPLIMENTS AND YOU'VE HEARD A
LOT FROM EVERYBODY BUT YOU'RE
TAKING ON A BIG PROJECT AND I.
EXPECT JUSTICE IS GOOD
GOVERNMENT FOR CALIFORNIA IF
YOU FOCUS ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT. LET'S SEE
WHAT'S CALLED. GREAT DISCUSSION
THIS IS IN FACT ONE OF MY
FAVORITE BILLS AND- YOU KNOW
THE PARENTS SO I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT AND- PLEASE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND TRY TO GET
ASSIGNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
PLEASE CALL CLOSE WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MR SECRETARY PLEASE
ACCOUNTABLE- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM AND INTERNET
MEDIA. CHOPTANK CHOW I TIGHTLY.
KILEY NOPE QUE. QUE HAN AYE
BENNETT. BENNETT I CARILLO.
CARILLO I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
I IRWIN IRWIN I LEE LEE I WITH
HI WICKS HI YOU HAVE NINE VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CONGRATULATIONS. THAT
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA I THINK
ALL OF THE BILLS THAT WE HEARD-
MADE OUT SO FAR BUT AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO JUST CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS LET ME JUST GO
DOWN THE LIST. BOB THIRTY WOULD
ITEM ONE A. B. THREE SEVENTY
ONE JONES SAWYER PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS KILEY. KILEY
I YEAH AREA HI. WITH THE FINAL
CASH THAT IS JUDGED. SEVEN NINE
NINE NINE ZERO NEXT BILL NUMBER
THREE AB THIRTEEN THAT'S CHILD
BILL PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. YEAH I LEAK HI LI AYE
WICKS. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. WICKS
HI. SIX SEVEN EIGHT THAT'S NINE
VOTES NINE BILLS ALSO THANK YOU
NEXT BILL IS ITEM SEVEN AB
FOURTEEN NINETY CHILD PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS LI HI
LEE I.SIX SIX. NINE NINE. A
CUTE NEXT ITEM EIGHT I'M SORRY-
TEN IRWIN AB FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
LEE. HI LARRY I WICKES WICKS HI.
THIS THAT'S EIGHT VOTES EIGHT
AT OUT THERE ARE NONE BILL IS
ITEM THIRTEEN AB EIGHT FIFTY
NINE IRWIN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SARCHEHAN ARE
QUE HAN HI. GABRIEL GABRIEL NOT
VOTING GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I
HIGHLY NOBODY LEE NOT VOTING.
SIX EIGHT VOTES AS HOW MANY
VOTES EIGHT VOTES. APPLE'S UP
NEXT ITEM. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT FOURTEEN LEVINE LATE. HI
LEE I WICKS WICKS HI THAT IS.
COOL SIX TEN BUCKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT ITEM A. B. A
TWENTY FIVE ITEM FIFTEEN ALSO
LEVINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BENNETT. BENNETT I
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER KILEY HI LEE AYE
WICKES WICKES HI THAT IS
UNANIMOUS THANK YOU NEXT ITEM
SIXTEEN AB ONE TEN
PETRIE-NORRIS SO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
HI IRWIN IRWIN HIGHLY NOT
VOTING LEAN NOT VOTING WICKS
WICKS HI THAT HAS TEN VOTES
THANK YOU ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B.
FIFTY SIX SALAS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GABRIEL- APRIL
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I-
WENT THERE WHEN I LEAVE I LEAVE
AYE WICKES WICKES HI THAT IS
UNANIMOUS ITEM TWENTY AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE WHICH IS
HURT I THINK WE PICKED UP
EVERYBODY BUT JUST IN CASE SO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
IF ANY- NO ABSENT MEMBERS VERY
GOOD TO FINALLY ARE THE CONSENT
AGENDA PLEASE CALL THE UPS AND
MEMBER ON THE CONSENT AGENDA-
BARAKAT. RK I. GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER HIGHLY AYE ACTIVELY
AYE WICKS. WICKS HI THAT IS
UNANIMOUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT YOU CAN WALK I'M SORRY
NINETY FOR YOUR BILL FORTY NINE
FOURTEEN NINETY YEAH I THINK WE
CALL IT- DID YOU WANT. TO WE
CAN. HOW IT'S SO COLD THAT WHEN
AGAIN OF. I THANK YOU FOR
TIGHTENING SEVEN AB FOURTEEN
NINETY CHAO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AS I HAVE YOU ON
THIS AND I'LL OKAY. I YES I
HAVE BOTH OF YOU AS I DON'T
KNOW. HOUSING THANK YOU. FOR
YEAH RIGHT. ABOUT THAT OKAY YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS THAT WE A
VERY VERY- VERY PROTECTIVE AND
THOUGHTFUL AND ROBUST
DISCUSSION SO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THAT'S RIGHT SO
WE NEED TO CLEAR OUT OF THE
ROOM IN NEXT FEW MINUTES- SO.
PLEASE WRAP UP. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING THANK YOU.